[Music]
did you know that there are around 4.4
billion internet users today and all
these users undoubtedly generate massive
amounts of data and all of this data is
collectively termed as big data but how
do you think all of this data is
processed well frameworks like hadoop
and spark are used to do this so hey
guys welcome to this big data tutorial
in this video we'll be covering the
fundamentals of big data hadoop and
spark so we will be talking about hadoop
installation and the various components
of hadoop such as hdfs map reduce and
yarn then we look into apache spark its
installation spark m-lid and spark sql
first off we'll have an introduction to
big data and look into the hadoop
installation by our instructor ajay now
when we talk about evolution of big data
we have known that data has evolved in
last five years like never before now in
fact before going to big data or before
understanding these solutions and the
need and why there is a rush towards big
data technology in solution i would like
to ask a question take a couple of
minutes and think why are organizations
interested in big data why is there
certain rush in industry where everyone
would want to ramp up their current
infrastructure or would want to be
working on technologies which allow them
to use this big data think about it what
is happening and why are organizations
interested in this and if you think on
this
you will start thinking about what
organizations have been doing in past
what organizations have not done and why
are organizations interested in big data
now before we learn on big data we can
always look into internet and check for
use cases where organizations have
failed to use legacy systems or
relational databases to work on their
data requirements now over in recent or
over past five years or in recent decade
what has happened is organizations have
started understanding the value of data
and they have decided
not to ignore any data as being
uneconomical now we can talk about
different platforms through which data
is generated take an example of social
media like twitter facebook instagram
whatsapp youtube you have e-commerce and
various portals say ebay amazon flipkart
alibaba.com and then you have various
tech giants such as google oracle sap
amazon microsoft and so on so lots of
data is getting generated every day in
every business sector the point here is
that organizations have slowly started
realizing that they would be interested
in working on all the data now the
question which i asked was why are
organizations interested in big data and
some of you might have already answered
or thought about that organizations are
interested in doing precise analysis or
they want to work on different formats
of data such as structured unstructured
semi-structured data organizations are
interested in gaining insights or
finding the hidden treasure in the so
called big data and this is the main
reason where organizations are
interested in big data now there are
various use cases there are various use
cases we can compare that organizations
from past 50 or more than 50 years have
been handling huge amount of data they
have been working on huge volume of data
but the question here is have they
worked on all the data or have they
worked on some portion of it what have
they used to store this data and if they
have used something to store this data
what is happening what is what is
changing now when we talk about the
businesses we cannot avoid talking about
the dynamism involved now any
organization would want to have a
solution which allows them to store data
and store huge amount of data capture it
process it analyze it and also look into
the data to give more value to the data
organizations have then been looking for
solutions now let's look at some facts
that can convince you or that would
convince you that data is exploding and
needs your attention right 55 billion
messages and 4.5 billion photos are sent
each day on whatsapp 300 hours of video
are uploaded every minute on youtube did
you guys know that youtube is the second
largest search engine after google every
minute users send
31.25 million messages and watched 2.77
million videos on facebook walmart
handles more than 1 million customer
transactions every hour google 40 000
search queries are performed on google
per second that is 3.46 million searches
a day in fact you could also say that a
lot of times people when they are
loading up the google page is basically
just to check their internet connection
however that is also generating data idc
reports that by 2025 real-time data will
be more than a quarter of all the data
and by 2025 the volume of digital data
will increase to 163 zeta bytes that is
we are not even talking about gigabytes
or terabytes anymore we are talking
about petabytes exabytes and zeta bytes
and zeta bytes means 10 to the power 21
bytes so this is how data has evolved
now you can talk about different
companies which would want to use their
data to take business decisions they
would want to collect the data store it
and analyze it and that's how they would
be interested in drawing insights for
the business now this is just a simple
example about facebook and what it does
to work on the data now before we go to
facebook you could always check in
google by just typing in companies using
big data and if we say companies using
big data we should be able to find a
list of different companies which are
using big data for different use cases
there are various sources from where you
can find we could also search for
solution that is hadoop which we'll
discuss later but you could always say
companies using hadoop and that should
take you to the wiki page which will
basically help you know what are the
different companies which are using the
so-called solution called hadoop okay
now coming back to what we were
discussing about so organizations are
interested in big data as we discussed
in gaining insights they would want to
use the data to find hidden information
which probably they ignored earlier now
take an example of rdbms what is biggest
drawback in using an rdbms now you might
think that rdbms is known for stability
and consistency and organizations would
be interested in storing their data in
oracle or db2 or mysql or microsoft sql
server and they have been doing that for
many years now so what has changed now
now when we talk about rdbms the first
question which i would ask is do we have
access to 100 of data being online in
rdbms the answer is no we would only
have 10 or 20 or 30 of data online and
rest of the data would be archived which
means that if an organization is
interested in working on all the data
they would have to move the data from
the archived storage to the processing
layer and that would involve bandwidth
consumption now this is one of the
biggest drawbacks of rdbms you do not
have access to 100 of data online in
many of the cases organizations started
realizing that the data which they were
ignoring as being uneconomical had
hidden value which they had never
exploited i had read a presentation
somewhere which said torture the data
and it will confess to anything now
that's the value of data which
organizations have realized in recent
past take an example of facebook now
this shows what facebook does with its
big data and we'll come to what is big
data but let's understand the use case
now facebook collects huge volumes of
user data whether that is sms whether
that is likes whether that is
advertisements whether that is features
which people are liking or photographs
or even user profiles now by collecting
this data and providing a portal which
people can use to connect facebook is
also accumulating huge volume of data
and that's way beyond petabytes they
would also be interested in analyzing
this data and one of the reasons would
be they would want to personalize the
experience take an example of
personalized news feed depending on a
user behavior depending on what a user
likes what a user would want to know
about they can recommend a personalized
news feed to every particular user
that's just one example of what facebook
does with its data take an example of
photo tag suggestions now when you log
into facebook account you could also get
suggestions on different friends whom
you would like to connect to or you
would want to tag so that they could be
known by others some more examples which
show how facebook uses its data are as
follows so the flashback collection of
photos and posts that receive the most
comments and likes okay there was
something called as i voted that was
used for 2016 elections with reminders
and directions to tell users their time
and place of polling also something
called as safety checks in incidents
such as earthquake hurricane or mass
shooting facebook gives you safety
checks now these are some examples where
facebook is using big data and that
brings us to the question what is big
data this was just an example where we
discussed about one company which is
making use of that data which has been
accumulated and it's not only for
companies which are social media
oriented like facebook where data is
important take an example of ibm take an
example of jpmorgan chase take an
example of ge or any other organization
which is collecting huge amount of data
they would all want to gather insights
they would want to analyze the data they
would want to be more precise in
building their services or solutions
which can take care of their customers
so what is big data big data is
basically a term it is used to describe
the data that is too large and complex
to store in traditional databases and as
i gave an example it's not just about
storing the data it is also about what
you can do with the data it also means
that if there is a lot of dynamism
involved can you change the underlying
storage and handle any kind of data that
comes in now before we get into that
let's just understand what is big data
so big data is basically a term which
has been given to categorize the data if
it has different characteristics
organizations would want to have the big
data stored processed and then analyzed
to get whatever useful information they
can get from this data now there are
five
v's of big data volume velocity variety
value velocity although these are five
v's but then there are other v's which
also categorize the data as big data
such as volatility validity viscosity
virality of data okay so these are five
v's of big data and if the data has one
or all of these characteristics then it
can be considered as big data including
the other ways which i just mentioned so
volume basically means incredible amount
of data huge volumes of data data
generated every second now that could be
used for batch processing that could be
used for real-time stream processing
okay you might have data being generated
from different kind of devices like your
cell phones your social media websites
online transactions variable devices
servers and these days with iot we are
also talking about data of getting
generated via internet of things that is
you could have different devices which
could be communicating to each other you
could be getting data from radars or
leaders or even camera sensors so there
is a huge volume of data which is
getting generated and if we are talking
about data which has huge volume which
is getting generated constantly or has
been accumulated over a period of time
we would say that is big data velocity
now this is one more important aspect of
big data speed with which the data is
getting generated think about stock
markets think about social media
websites think about online surveys or
marketing campaigns or airline industry
so if the data is getting generated with
a lot of speed where it becomes
difficult to capture collect process
cure
mine or analyze the data then we are
certainly talking about big data the
next aspect of big data is variety now
this is where we talk about structured
data semi-structured data or
unstructured data and here i would like
to ask a question what is the difference
when do you call the data is structured
semi-structured or unstructured now
let's look at an example before we
theoretically discuss about this i
always would like to use some examples
let's look at a log file and let's see
what is it so if i look at this log file
and if i would say what kind of data is
this which is the highlighted one the
answer would be
it is structured data it has specific
delimiters such as space it has data
which is separated by space and if i had
a hundred or thousand or million rows
which had similar kind of data i could
certainly store that in a table i could
have a predefined schema to store this
data so i would call the one which is
highlighted and structured but if i look
at this portion where i would look at a
combination of this kind of data where
some data has a pattern and some data
doesn't now this is an example of
semi-structured data so if i would have
a predefined structure to store this
data probably the pattern of data would
break the structure and if i look at all
the data then i would certainly call it
unstructured data because there is no
clear schema which can define this data
now this is what i mean by variety of
data that is structured data which
basically has a schema or has a format
which could be easily understood you
have semi-structured which could be like
an xml or json or even your excel sheets
where you could have some data which is
structured and the other is unstructured
and when we talk about unstructured we
are talking about absence of schema it
does not have a format it does not have
a schema and it is hard to analyze which
brings its own challenges the next
aspect is value now value refers to the
ability to turn your data useful for
business you would have a lot of data
which is being collected as we mentioned
in previous slides right there would be
a lot of data wrangling or data
pre-processing or cleaning up of data
happening and then finally you would
want to draw value from that data but
from all the data collected what
percentage of data gives us value and if
all my data can give me value then why
wouldn't i use it this is an aspect of
big data right veracity now this means
the quality of data billions of dollars
are lost every year by organizations
because the data which was collected was
not of good quality or probably they
collected a lot of data and then it was
erroneous take an example of autonomous
driving projects which are
happening in europe or u.s where there
are car fleets which are on the road
collecting data via radar sensors and
camera sensors and when this data has to
be processed to train algorithms it has
realized that sometimes the data which
was collected was missing in some values
might be was not appropriate
or had a lot of errors and all this
process of collecting the data becomes a
repetitive task because the quality of
data was not good this is just one
example we can take example from
healthcare industry or stock markets or
financial institutions and so on so
extracting loads of data is not useful
if the data is messy or poor in quality
and that basically means that velocity
is a very important v of big data now
apart from veracity volume variety
velocity and value we have the other v
such as viscosity how dense the data is
validity is the data still valid
volatility is my data volatile or
virality is the data viral now all of
these different v's categorize the data
as big data we would like to talk on a
big data case study and we have taken an
example of google which obviously is one
of the companies which is
churning and working on huge amount of
data now it's actually said that if you
compare one grain of sand with one byte
of data then google is processing or
google is handling whole worlds sand
every week that is the kind of data
which google is processing now in early
2000 and since then when the number of
internet users started growing google
also faced lot of problems
in storing increasing user data and
using the traditional servers to manage
that now that was a challenge which
google started facing could they use
traditional data server to store the
data well yes they could right storage
devices have been getting cheaper day by
day but then how much time does it take
to retrieve that data what is the seek
time what is the time taken to read and
process that data thousands of search
queries were raised per second no doubt
now we could say millions and billions
of queries are raised per second every
query read 100 mbs of data and consumed
tens of billions of cpu cycles based on
these queries so the requirement was
that they wanted to have a large
distributed highly fault tolerant file
system large to store to capture process
huge amount of data distributed because
they could not rely just on one server
even if that had multiple disks stacked
up that was not an efficient choice what
would happen if this particular machine
failed what would happen if the whole
server was down so they needed a
distributed storage and a distributed
computing
environment they needed something which
can be highly fault tolerant right so
this was the requirement which google
had and the solution which came out as a
result was gfs google file system now
let's look at how gfs works so normally
in any particular linux system or linux
server you would have a file system you
would have set of processes you would
have set of files and directories which
could store the data gfs was different
so to facilitate gfs which could store
huge amount of data there was an
architecture an architecture which had
one master and multiple chunk servers or
you could say slave servers or slave
machines master machine was to contain
metadata was to contain data about data
when we say metadata we are talking
about information about data and then
you have the chung servers or the slave
machines which could be storing data in
a distributed fashion now any client or
an api or an application which would
want to read the data would first
contact the master server it would
contact the machine where the master
process was running and client would
place a request of
reading the data or showing an interest
of reading the data internally what it
is doing is it is requesting for
metadata your api or an application
would want to know from where it can
read the data master server which has
metadata whether that is in ram or disk
we can discuss that later but then
master server would have the metadata
and it would know which are the chunk
servers or the slave machines where the
data was stored in a distributed fashion
master would respond back with the
metadata information to the client and
then client could use that information
to read or write to these slave machines
where actually the data was stored now
this is what the process or set of
processes work together to make gfs so
when you say a chunk server we would
basically have the files getting divided
into fixed size chunks now how would
they get divided so there would be some
kind of chunk size or a block size which
would determine that if the file is
bigger than the pre-decided chunk size
then it would be split into smaller
chunks and be distributed across the
chunk servers or the slave machines if
the file was smaller then it would still
use one chunk or a block to get stored
on the underlying slave machines so
these junk servers or slave machines are
the ones which actually store the data
on local disks as your linux files
client which is interacting with master
for metadata and then interacting with
chunk servers for read write operations
would be the one which would be
externally connecting to the cluster so
this is how it would look so you have a
master which would obviously be
receiving some kind of heartbeats from
the chunk servers to know their status
and receive information in the form of
packets which would let the master know
which machines were available for
storage which machines already had data
and master would build up the metadata
within itself the files would be broken
down into chunks for example we can look
at file one it is broken down into chunk
one and chunk two and file two has one
chunk which is one portion of it and
then you have file two residing on some
other chunk server which also lets us
know that there is some kind of auto
replication for this file system right
and the data which is getting stored in
the chunk could have a data of 64 mb now
that chunk size could be changed based
on the data size but google file system
had the basic size of the chunk as 64 mb
each chunk would be replicated on
multiple servers the default replication
was three and that could again be
increased or decreased as per
requirement this would also mean that if
a particular slave machine or a chunk
server would die or would get killed or
would crash there would never be any
data loss because a replica of data
residing on the failed machine would
still be available on some other slave
server chunk server or slave machine now
this helped google to store and process
huge volumes of data in a distributed
manner and thus have a fault tolerant
distributed
scalable storage which could allow them
to store a huge amount of data now that
was just one example which actually led
to the solution which today we call as
hadoop now when we talk about
big data here i would like to ask you
some questions that if we were talking
about the rdbms case take an example of
something like nasa which was working on
a
project called set eye search of
extraterrestrial intelligence now this
was a project where they were looking
for a solution to take care of their
problem the problem was that they would
roughly send some waves in space capture
those waves back and then analyze this
data to find if there was any
extraterrestrial object in space now
they had two options for it they could
either have a huge server built which
could take care of storing the data and
processing it or they could go for
volunteer computing now volunteer
computing basically means that you could
have a lot of people volunteering and
being part of this project and what they
would in turn do is they would be
donating their ram and storage from
their machines when they are not using
it how would that happen basically
download some kind of patch on their
machine which would run as a screen
saver and if the user is not using his
machine some portion of data could be
transferred to these machines for
intermittent storage and processing
using ram now this sounds very
interesting and this sounds very easy
however it would have its own challenges
right think about security think about
integrity but those those problems are
not bigger as much as is the requirement
of bandwidth and this is the same thing
which happens in rdbms if you would have
to move data from archived solution to
the processing layer that would consume
huge amount of bandwidth big data brings
its own challenges
huge amount of data is getting generated
every day now the biggest challenge is
storing this huge volume of data and
especially when this data is getting
generated with lot of variety where it
can have different kind of formats where
it could be viral it could be having a
lot of value and nobody has looked into
the veracity of data but the primary
problem would be handling this huge
volume of data variety of the data would
bring in challenges of storing it in
legacy systems if processing of the data
was required now here again i would
suggest you need to think what is the
difference between reading a data and
processing a data so reading might just
mean bringing in the data from disk and
doing some io operations and processing
would mean reading the data probably
doing some transformations on it
extracting some useful information from
it and then storing it in the same
format or probably in a different format
so processing this massive volume of
data is the second challenge
organizations don't just store their big
data they would eventually want to use
it to process it to gather some insights
now processing and extracting insights
from big data would take huge amount of
time unless and until there was an
efficient solution to handle and process
this big data securing the data that's
again a concern for organizations right
encryption of big data is difficult to
perform if you would think about
different compression mechanisms then
that would also mean decompressing of
data which would also mean that you
could take a hit on the cpu cycles or on
disk usage providing user authentication
for every team member now that could
also be dangerous so that led to hadoop
as a solution so big data brings its own
challenges big data brings its own
benefits and here we have a solution
which is hadoop now what is hadoop it's
a open source framework for storing data
and running applications on clusters of
commodity hardware hadoop is an open
source framework and before we discuss
on two main components of hadoop it
would be good to look into the link
which i was suggesting earlier that is
companies using hadoop and any person
who would be interested in learning big
data should start somewhere here where
you could list down different companies
what kind of setup they have why are
they having hadoop what kind of
processing they are doing and how are
they using these so called hadoop
clusters to process and in fact store
capture and process huge amount of data
another link which i would suggest is
looking at different
distributions
of hadoop any person who is interested
in learning in big data should know
about different distributions of hadoop
now in linux we have different different
distributions like ubuntu centos red hat
susie debian in the same way you have
different distributions of hadoop which
we can look on the wiki page and this is
the link which talks about products that
include apache hadoop or derivative
works and commercial support which
basically means that apache hadoop the
sole products that can be called a
release of apache hadoop come from
apache.org that's an open source
community and then you have various
vendor-specific distributions like
amazon web services you have cloud era
you have hotend works you have ibm's big
inside you have map r all these are
different distributions of hadoop so
basically all of these vendor-specific
distributions are depending on using on
core apache hadoop in brief we can say
that these are the vendors which take up
the apache hadoop package it within a
cluster management solution so that
users who intend to use apache hadoop
would not have difficulties of setting
up a cluster setting up a framework they
could just use a vendor-specific
distribution with its cluster
installation solutions clustered
management solution and easily plan
deploy install and manage a cluster here
is a quick demo on setting up cloudera
quickstart vm in case you are interested
in working on a standalone cluster
you can download the cloudera quick
start vm so you can just type in
download cloud error quick start vm and
you can search for package now this can
be used to set up a quick start vm which
would be a single node cloudera based
cluster so you can click on this link
and then basically based on the platform
which you would be choosing to install
such as using a vm box or which version
of cloudera you would install so here i
can select a platform so i can choose
virtualbox and then you can click on get
it now so give your details and
basically then it should allow you to
download the quick start vm which would
look something like this and once you
have the zip file which is downloaded
you can unzip it which can then be used
to set up a single node cloud error
cluster so once you have downloaded the
zip file that would look something like
this so you would have a quick start
virtual box and then a virtual boss disk
now this can be used to set up a cluster
ignore these files which are related to
amazon machines and we you don't need to
have that so you would just have this
and this can be used to set up a cloud
data cluster so for this to be set up
you can click on file import appliance
and here you can choose your quick start
vm by looking into downloads quick start
vm select this and click on open now you
can click on next and that shows you the
specifications of cpu ram which we can
then change later and click on import
this will start importing virtual disk
image dot vmdk file into your vm box
once this is done we will have to change
the specifications or machines to use
two cpu cores minimum and give a little
more ram because cloudera quick start vm
is very cpu intensive and it needs good
amount of ram so to survive i will give
two cpu cores and 5gb ram and that
should be enough for us to bring up a
quick start vm which gives us a cloudera
distribution of hadoop in a single node
cluster setup which can be used for
working learning about different
distributions in cloudera clusters
working with sdfs and other hadoop
ecosystem components let's just wait for
this importing to finish and then we
will go ahead and set up a quick start
vm for our practice here the importing
of appliance is done and vc cloudera
quickstart machine is added to my list
of machines i can click on this and
click on settings as mentioned i would
like to give it more ram and more cpu
cores so click on system and here let's
increase the ram to at least
five and click on processor and let's
give it two cpu cores which would at
least be better than using one cpu core
network it goes for nat and that's fine
click on ok and we would want to start
this machine so that it uses two cpu
cores 5gb ram and it should bring up my
cloudera quick start vm now let's go
ahead and start this machine which has
our quick start vm it might take
initially some time to start up because
internally there will be various
cloudera services which will be starting
up and those services need to be up for
our cloud era quick start vm to be
accessible so unlike your apache hadoop
cluster where we start our cluster and
we will be starting all our processes in
case of cloudera it is your cloudera scm
server and agents which take care of
starting up of your services and
starting up of your different roles for
those services i explained in my
previous session that for a cloud era
cluster it would be these services let
me just show you that so in case of
apache cluster we start our services
that is we start our cluster by running
script and then basically those scripts
will individually start the different
processes on different nodes in case of
cloudera we would always have a cloudera
sem server which would be running on one
machine and then including that machine
we would have clouded icm agents which
would be running on multiple machines
similarly if we had a hortonworks
cluster we would have ambari server
starting up on the first machine and
then embody agents running on other
machines so your server component knows
what are the services which are set up
what are their configurations and agents
running on every node are responsible to
send heartbeats to the server receive
instructions and then take care of
starting and stopping off of individual
roles on different machines in case of
our single node cluster setup in quick
start vm we would just have one scm
server and one sem agent which will
start on the machine which will then
take care of all the roles which need to
be started for your different services
so we will just wait for our machine to
come up and basically have clouded sem
server and agent running and once we
have that we need to follow few steps so
that we can have the cloudera admin
console accessible which allows you to
browse the cluster look at different
services look at the roles for different
services and also work with your cluster
either using command line or using the
web interface that is
now that my machine has come up and it
already is connected to the internet
which we can see here we need to do
certain things so that we can have our
admin console accessible at this point
of time you can click on terminal and
check if you have access to the cluster
so here type in hostname and that shows
you your host name which is
quickstart.cloudera we can also type in
hdfs command to see if we have access
and if my cluster is working these
commands are same as you would give them
in apache hadoop cluster or in any other
distribution of a loop sometimes when
your cluster is up and you have access
to the terminal it might take few
seconds or few minutes before there is a
connection established between cloudera
cm server and cloudera cm agent running
in the background which takes care of
your cluster i have given a sdfs dfs
list command which basically should show
me what by default exists on my sdfs
let's just give it a couple of seconds
before it shows us out we can also check
by giving a service cloud error scm
server status and here it tells me that
if you would want to use cloudera
express
free run this command it needs 8 gb of
ram and it gives 2 virtual cpu cores and
it also mentions it may take several
minutes before cloudera manager has
started i can login as root here and
then give the command service cloud
error scm server status remember the
password for root is clouded so it
basically says that if you would want to
check these settings it is good to have
express edition running so we can close
this my sdfs access is working fine
let's close the terminal and here we
have launch cloud era express click on
this and that will give you that you
need to give a command which is
force let's copy this command let's open
a different terminal and let's give this
command like this which will then go
ahead and shut down your cloudera based
services and then it will restart it
only after which you will be able to
access your admin console so let's just
give it a couple of minutes before it
does this and then we will have access
to our admin console here if you see it
is starting the cloudera manager server
again it is waiting for cloudera manager
api then starting the cloudera manager
agents and then configuring the
deployment as per the new settings which
we have given as to use the express
edition of cloudera once all this is
done it will say the cluster has been
restarted and the admin console can be
accessed by id and password as cloudera
we'll give it a couple of more minutes
and once this is done we are ready to
use our admin console now that
deployment has been configured client
configurations have also been deployed
and it has restarted the cloudera
management service it gives you an
access to quick start admin console
using user name and password as cloud
error let's try accessing it so we can
open up the browser here and let's
change this to 7180
that's the default port and that shows
the admin console which is coming up now
here we can login as cloudera cloud
error and then let's click on login now
as i said cloudera is very cpu intensive
and memory intensive so it would slow
down since we have not given enough gbe
ram to our cloudera cluster and thus it
will be advisable to stop or even remove
the services which we don't need now as
of now if we look at the services all of
them look in a stop status and that's
good in one way because we can then go
ahead and remove the services which we
will not use in the beginning and later
we can anytime add services to the
cluster so for example i can click on
key value store here and then i can
scroll down where it says delete to
remove this service from the admin
console now anytime you are removing a
particular service it will only remove
the service from the management by cloud
direct manager all the role groups under
this service will be removed from host
templates so we can click on delete now
if this service was depending on some
other service it would have prompted me
with a message that remove the relevant
services on which this particular
service depends if the service was
already running then it would have given
me a message that the service has to be
stopped before it can be deleted from
the cloudera admin console now this is
my admin console which allows you to
click on services look at the different
roles and processes which are running
for this service we anyways have access
to our cloud era cluster from the
terminal using our regular sdfs or yarn
or map red commands now i removed a
service i will also remove solar which
we will not be using for the beginning
but then it depends on your choice so we
can here scroll down to delete it and
that says that before deleting the solar
service you must remove the dependencies
on the service from the configuration of
following services that is hue now hue
is a web interface which allows you to
work with your sdfs and that is
depending on this so click on configure
service dependency and here we can make
sure that our hue service does not
depend on a particular service we are
removing so that then we can have a
clean removal of the service so i'll
click on none and i will say save
changes once this is done then we can go
ahead and try removing the solar service
from our admin console which will reduce
some load on my management console which
will also allow me to work faster on my
cluster now here we have removed the
dependency of hue on solar so we can
click on this and then we can delete it
remember i'm only doing this so that my
cluster becomes little lighter and i can
work on my focus services at any point
of time if you want to add more services
to your cluster you can anytime do that
you can fix different configuration
issues like what we see here with
different warning messages and here we
have these services which are already
existing now if we don't need any of the
service i can click on the drop down and
click on delete again this says that
scoop 2 also has
relevance to hue so hue as a web
interface also depends on scope 2. as of
now we'll make it none at any point of
time later you can add the services by
clicking the add service option now this
is a cluster to which you have admin
access and this is a quick start vm
which gives you a single node cloud
error cluster which you can use for
learning and practicing so here we'll
click on scope 2 and then we will say
delete as we have configured the
dependency now and we will remove scope
2 also from the list of services which
your admin console is managing right so
once this is done we have removed three
services which we did not need we can
even remove scope as a client and if we
need we can add that later now there are
various other alerts which your cloudera
admin console shows and we can always
fix them by clicking on the health
issues or configuration issues we can
click here and see what is the health
issue it is pointing to if that is a
critical one or if that can be ignored
so it says there is an issue with a
clock offset which basically relates to
an ntp service network time protocol
which makes sure that one or multiple
machines are in the same time zone and
are in sync so for now we can click on
suppress and we can just say suppress
for all hosts and we can say look into
it later and confirm so now we will not
have that health issue reported that
probably the ntp service and the
machines
might not be in sync now that does not
have an impact for our use case as of
now but if we have a kerberos kind of
setup which is for security then
basically this offset and time zone
becomes important so we can ignore this
message and we are still good to use the
cluster we also have other configuration
issues and you can click on this which
might talk about the heap size or the
ram which is available for machines it
talks about zookeeper should be in odd
numbers q does not have a load balancer
sdfs only has one data node but all of
these issues are not to be worried upon
because this is a single node cluster
setup so if you want to avoid all of
these warnings you can always click on
suppress and you can avoid and let your
cluster be in all green status but
that's nothing to worry so we can click
on cluster and basically we can look at
the services so we have removed some
services which we don't intend to use
now i have also suppressed a offset
warning which is not very critical for
my use case and basically i am good to
start the cluster at any point of time
as i said if you would want to add
services this is the actions button
which you can use to add service so we
will just say restart my cluster which
will restart all the services one by one
starting from zookeeper as the first
service to come up we can always click
on this arrow mark and see what is
happening in the services what services
are coming up and in which order if you
have any issues you can always click on
the link next to it which will take you
to the logs and we can click on close to
let it happen in the background so this
will basically let my services restart
one by one and my cluster will then
become completely accessible either
using hue as a web interface or quick
start terminal which allows you to give
your commands now while my machines are
coming up you can click on hosts and you
can have a look at all the hosts we have
as of now only one which will also tell
you how many roles or processes are
running on this machine so that is 25
rolls it tells you what is the disk
usage it tells you what is the physical
memory being used and using this host
tab we can add new host to the cluster
we can check the configuration we can
check all the hosts in diagnostics you
can look at the logs which will give you
access to all the logs you can even
select the sources from which you would
want to have the logs or you can give
the host name you can click on search
you can build your own charts you can
also do the admin stuff by adding
different users or enabling security
using the administration tab so since we
have clicked on restart of a cluster we
will slowly start seeing all the
services one by one coming up starting
with zookeeper to begin with and once we
have our cluster up and running whether
that is showing all services in green or
in a different status we still should be
able to access the service now as we saw
in apache hadoop cluster even here we
can click on sdfs and we can access the
web ui once our sdfs service is up by
clicking on quick links so the service
is not yet up once it is up we should be
able to see the web ui link which will
allow you to check things from sdfs web
interface similarly yarn as a service
also has a web interface so as soon as
the service comes up under your quick
links we will have access to the yarn ui
and similarly once the service comes up
we will have access to hue which will
give you the web interface which allows
you to work with your sdfs which allows
you to work with your different other
components within the cluster without
even using the command line tools or
command line options so we will have to
give it some time while the cloud error
scm agent on every machine will be able
to restart the roles which are
responsible for your cluster to come up
we can always click here which else that
there are some running commands in the
background which are trying to start my
cluster we can go to the terminal and we
can switch as hdfs user remember sdfs
user is the admin user and it does not
have a password unless you have set one
so you can just log in as sdfs which
might ask you for a password initially
which we do not have so the best way to
do this is by logging in as root where
the password is cloud and then you can
log in as hdfs so that then onwards you
can give your sdfs commands to work with
your file system now since my services
are coming up right now when i try to
give a sdfs dfs command it might not
work or it might also say that it is
trying to connect to the name node which
is not up yet so we will have to give it
some time and only once the name node is
up we will be able to access our sdfs
using commands so this is how you can
quickly set up your quick start and then
you can be working using the command
line options from the terminal like what
you would do in apache hadoop cluster
you could use the web interfaces which
allow you to work with your cluster now
this usually takes more time so you will
have to give it some time before your
services are up and running and for any
reason if you have issues it might
require you to restart your cluster
several times in the beginning before it
gets accustomed to the settings what you
have given and it starts up the services
at any point of time if you have any
error message then you can always go
back and look in logs and see what is
happening and try starting your cluster
so this is how we set up a quick start
vm and you can be using this to work
with your cloud error cluster and
welcome to the tutorial where we will
learn today on setting up a apache
hadoop cluster although there are
various distributions of hadoop as we
have already discussed and you could set
up a apache hadoop cluster which is the
core distribution
you could be setting up a cloud error
distribution of hadoop or even a
hortonworks however for cloudera you
would need machines which are really
powerful at least machines which have 16
gb of ram and in which you can set up
multiple virtual machines each virtual
machine of at least 4 to 5 gb same thing
applies for hortonworks or you could
always download and set up a cloudera
quick start vm or a hortonworks sandbox
in this session we will learn how to set
up apache hadoop cluster which is the
core distribution and if one has learned
how to set up apache hadoop cluster then
they would understand the internals of
setting up a cluster different
configuration properties which are
needed for your clustered setup we can
say that these are the vendors which
take up the apache hadoop package it
within a cluster management solution so
that users who intend to use apache
hadoop would not have difficulties of
setting up a cluster setting up a
framework they could just use a
vendor-specific distribution with its
cluster installation solutions clustered
management solution and easily plan
deploy install and manage a cluster so
look into this link which talks about
different distributions of hadoop coming
back what is hadoop hadoop is a open
source framework for storing huge amount
of data and processing it it also
depends on commodity machines and it
does not need carrier class hardware now
when we say commodity machines we are
still talking about machines which are
higher than a basic laptop or a basic
server but then they are not at the
level of a carrier class hardware and
costing huge to the organization hadoop
as a framework has two main components
or i would say two processing layers it
has a storage layer which is called hdfs
hadoop distributed file system and it
has a processing layer which is called
yarn which can handle different
processing frameworks in which hadoop
map reduce is the oldest most mature and
most evolved processing framework sdfs
derives its existence from gfs it solves
the issue of storing huge amount of data
in a distributed fashion and mapreduce
is a programming model which allows to
process data which is distributed across
a cluster we will learn on sdfs and
mapreduce in further slides sdfs is a
storage layer now compare your laptop
compare your desktop that also has a
processing layer and a storage layer
your disks are your storage layer your
ram and cpu core is your processing
layer similarly hadoop as a solution has
a storage layer that is a distributed
file system which can store huge amount
of data in multiple machines
instead of a single machine or a single
server which basically makes it highly
reliable highly fault tolerant and
distributed for parallel processing
consider a data file of size one
gigabyte now if that was getting stored
in one single machine we would still
have the data getting stored in one or
multiple disks and if you would try to
read the data the seek time time taken
to read the data would be very high in
comparison to reading it from multiple
machines now sdfs like your gfs divides
the file into smaller chunks and stores
the data across the hadoop cluster in
previous versions of hadoop the default
block size was 64 mb however from hadoop
version 2 onwards the block size is 128
mb now that's customizable depending on
the average
size of the data which is coming into
the cluster the block size can be
changed the minimum block size is 128 mb
which basically means that every file
which is
less than or equal to 128 mb would use
one block and any file which goes beyond
the size of block will use multiple
blocks and these blocks would be
residing on the underlying slave
machines files are automatically split
by hadoop framework into blocks of
default block size and stored across the
cluster each node in your hadoop cluster
would have
a bunch of disks that would be storing
these blocks now once we have the data
stored in a distributed fashion that
also gives us the flexibility of going
for distributed computing and when we
say distributed computing we are talking
about performing distributed parallel
processing on large volumes of data take
an example where we are talking about
one single machine or one huge server
which has four i o channels and each
input output channel can take care of
100 megabytes of per second 100
megabytes of data per second so if we
have a data file of one terabyte it
would take approximately 43 minutes for
one machine to process one terabyte of
data if you compare that with
distributed computing where we are
talking about hundreds of machines each
machine having similar number of input
output channels in each channel having
the same capacity to handle 100
megabytes of data per second if a data
file of one terabyte had to be processed
in a parallel processing fashion using
distributed computing it would take just
26 seconds for 100 machines to process
one terabyte of data in this environment
now all of you might be thinking that
yeah this is right but then what about
the processing logic that might be
complicated and yes that would be but
then we have a mapreduce programming
model and a processing framework to help
us doing that now when we look at one of
the distributions of hadoop that is
hortonworks it also has different
resources that provide security to your
big data now before we start talking on
these different services like apache nox
apache ranger which basically allow you
to monitor authorize and audit your
hadoop clusters let's also look at the
history of hadoop which started in 1999
with apache software foundation in 2002
a nudge created by doug cutting and mike
caffreller then doug cutting joined
hadoop and took
much product with him 2008 nuts was
divided and hadoop was born in 2008
yahoo released hadoop as an open source
project to asf in 2008
also hadoop based startup cloud era
incorporated cutting left yahoo for
cloudera yahoo was then coming out with
hortonworks as a commercial hadoop
distribution map r technology
also released hadoop distribution green
plum released hadoop distribution and
pivotal hd so this is a brief on history
of hadoop you can always read about
history of evolution of hadoop how it
started and today there are more than 10
distributions which are existing in
market however cloudera is the dominant
one and as per recent news items
cloudera and hortonworks have merged as
one entity which will bring up better
solutions to the market
now here we will want to learn on hadoop
ecosystem so far we have learned on big
data so what is big data we have learned
on what are the different use cases
one of my reasons is
[Music]
let's spend some time in understanding
the hadoop ecosystem
you might have heard as ecosphere which
has various products or you can say
tools or you can set packages which work
together to comprise
[Music]
from the life that i was living then to
the life that you see today
my name is
and i am a full-time travel content
creator and solo traveler
[Music]
and that data might already be stored in
rdbms and if you are interested in
bringing in the structured data from
your rdbms layer to your hadoop
ecosystem
[Music]
back to our dbas but school mainly is
is a data warehousing package on top of
sdfs where users will write
[Music]
and
now there are lots of no sql databases
there are a lot of data ingestion tools
so if we go to google and if we search
for data ingestion tools if i say data
ingestion tools so you could look at
this link which shows around 18
different data ingestion tools which are
existing in market you have these tools
for import and export for transforming
for governance for even processing the
data while the data is being ingested so
you have apache kafka which is a
published subscribing messaging system
you have apache nifi which is not only
for streaming or structured data but it
also helps with governance you have
wavefront you have data torrent amazon's
kinesis
apache storm samsa sink sort goblin
flume scoop samsa fluenty mufflins white
elephant chokwa heka scribe databus and
many more these are some data ingestion
tools which can be used now we could
also look at nosql databases and if you
just type in nosql databases that can
take you to nosql db.org and that would
show you that there are more than 225
nosql databases existing in market nosql
stands for not only sql so these are
databases which can be created without
defining any schema they could be key
value stores they could be document
based databases which allow a lot of
dynamism which have different kind of
constraints and can allow you to store
your structured unstructured or
semi-structured data so have a look at
this exhaustive list of nosql databases
so coming back to your hadoop ecosystem
your data would be interested in using
one of the data edition tools
becomes a new normal sized
[Music]
is
if you've been following my journey
you've seen me jump off buildings
or any of these components we would have
to manually download the packages edit
the configs set up the processes and
start the cluster and services
however if you were using a
vendor-specific distribution many of
these packages would come as a packaged
solution so oozy is a workflow scheduler
which allows you to create a workflow of
different jobs which could be run on a
hadoop cluster you could have a service
such as zookeeper which is mainly for
management
way you have hive query which allows
users to write their sql queries to
process the data you would also make
interactive analysis using packages like
apache drill you have apache
[Music]
structure data graph-based data
look back on this so the human
experience as such we could ever
assumption
[Music]
and the components which are involved
which can be part of your hadoop
ecosystem are growing so there can be
lots and lots of other components which
can be part of your adobe ecosystem
which can be overall used to store
process capture and analyze big data
this is where we come to
a point where we should now start
learning on hadoop distributed file
system which allows you to store data in
a distributed fashion sdfs basically
makes it easier for organizations to
store huge amount of data in previous
session we were learning on big data its
characteristics what are organizations
interested in when they talk about big
data and different use cases today we
will learn on hadoop distributed file
system which is basically the logical
storage layer for a hadoop cluster sdfs
is fault tolerant is reliable and is
scalable so let's understand and learn
on the working of sdfs that is the
logical storage layer for a hadoop
customer sdfs is a distributed file
system which is designed to store large
volumes of data on commodity machines it
is designed with a low cost hardware and
that is what i mean when i say commodity
machines so we could have a cluster of
tens and hundreds and thousands of nodes
which can still scale and accommodate
huge volume of data it provides access
to data across multiple hadoop clusters
it has a high fault tolerance and
throughput and sdfs stores data in
multiple servers instead of a central
server now earlier when we were
discussing on how storing data on a
single machine can lead to more read or
processing times and basically lead to
high seek time that can be taken care by
a distributed file system such as sdfs
which would rely on file systems of
multiple machines which form your hadoop
cluster now let's understand how sdfs
works for example we have a large file
which is to be stored on sdfs now that
file would be broken down into blocks
and the block size by default is 128 mb
these blocks would then be stored across
different slave machines or different
nodes which are responsible for storing
data sdfs has a default block size of
128 mb which can be increased as per
required
[Music]
we would have one single master unless
it is a high availability cluster where
we could have multiple masters that has
two masters one being active and one
being standby in a normal hadoop cluster
you would have one master and multiple
slave nodes where these data blocks are
getting stored now before we understand
the mapreduce algorithm let's also
understand the working of sdfs and how
data gets stored overall how does it
work so let me just open up a notepad
which could be forming my cluster so i
would have machine 1 machine 2 machine 3
machine 4 and machine 5. now if i say my
hadoop cluster is running on these
machines
which could be of a apache hadoop core
distribution or having a vendor-specific
distribution such as cloudera or hotend
works or mapper or ibm big insight etc
so these are some vendor-specific
distributions of a hadoop cluster now
here we can discuss later on how or what
processes would be running on these
machines now in case of apache hadoop
cluster in case of apache hadoop cluster
to have a hadoop cluster running we
would have to download the hadoop
related packages we would have to untar
then we would have to edit config files
to specify which processes would run on
which nodes and then basically we would
be formatting hdfs and then onwards we
can go ahead and start our cluster so it
looks like in apache adobe cluster we
would have to manually do various things
such as downloading the hadoop related
tar file untiring it editing the config
files formatting sdfs and then going
ahead and starting your cluster in case
of a vendor-specific distribution such
as cloudera or hortonworks let me split
it here so you would have basically a
cluster management solution that would
help you in doing various things to set
up your cluster in case of a cloud error
distribution of hadoop you would have a
cloudera installer file and then you
would have a cloudera manager which will
help in deploying a cloudera cluster so
downloading hadoop related parcels or
packages untiling them editing config
files formatting sdfs and basically
starting your cluster would be taken
care automatically by cloudera manager
in case of hortonworks data platform it
would be ambari software that would be
used for deploying your cluster now no
matter which distribution of hadoop you
would be running you would still have
the same roles or processes which would
be running let me just briefly discuss
here about the terminologies so let me
bring up a file here which could explain
all these details so let's look at this
now here
and if you look at the names we have the
name node we have data nodes we have job
tracker we have secondary name node and
we have task records in case of version
2 you would still call them demons you
could have one or multiple name nodes if
it was a federation or a high
availability kind of setup you would
have data nodes instead of job tracker
you would have resource manager and then
there is a temporary diamond called mr
appmaster if you had a high availability
then secondary name node would not be
allowed and if there was a federation
kind of setup secondary name node would
still be existing instead of task
trackers you would have node managers
now in case of vendor specific
distribution such as cloud error whether
you are talking about older version or
newer version which is five point
something you would have what we call as
roles so in apache hadoop we call them
demins in cloudera we call them roles in
hortonworks
but then the functionality still exists
and you could have a secondary name node
now don't go by name it's not a second
name node we'll discuss about that later
a secondary name node and then we could
have data nodes running in machines so
this is one kind of setup where i am
talking about data node node manager and
here we have a data node node manager
and similarly we would have that on one
more machine now this is one kind of
setup this is not the only setup
possible you could have a different
setup where on the same machines you
could decide to have data node and node
manager running on every node however
that would not be preferred because you
wouldn't want the slaves and the masters
to run on the same machine however this
setup is also possible you could have a
high availability kind of setup which
basically is good for cluster and for an
organization where you could have name
node 1 which would be running here and
say we can have a name node 2 running
here we could have a resource
manager 2 running here and then we could
have a resource manager 1 running here
and i could still have my data node and
node manager running in the same fashion
now this would not be allowed in a high
availability cluster because we have a
standby name node so this is one more
setup which is possible and then you
could have a single node setup which
could be everything having on the same
machine that is name node resource
manager secondary name node data node
and node manager so these are different
setups and if somebody asks which is a
preferable setup then i would still go
forward either
is
foreign
should have noticed
multiple nodes
you have these processes where in your
name node is the master and your data
nodes and secondary name node can be
considered as the slaves you have your
resource manager as the master for your
processing layer and node managers are
the slaves now this is briefly about the
setup which could be in a particular
environment now say the hadoop related
packages or parcels have been downloaded
whether it is a vendor-specific
distribution or apache hadoop cluster
say untarring of that is done editing of
config files is done formatting is done
and your cluster is started in that case
your cluster would be up and running and
then we could basically have and once
your cluster is up we would have the
sdfs up and running ready to allow to
store data now let's imagine that this
is my sdfs which is up and running or
sdfs as a service is up and running
let's imagine that these are my nodes
which is m1 m2 m3 m4 and m5 now while
the config files were edited for each of
these nodes it would have been defined
which processes will run and we would
have also given path where these
processes will store the data so let's
say that this is my m1 this is m2 m3
m4
and m5 m3 m4 and m5 have data nodes
running so we would have defined a path
let's call it say abc slash data abc
slash
again data or d and abc so this is the
path which has been defined on every
node to store hadoop related data and on
m1 where we would have name node running
we would have still defined a path let's
call it abc slash n where name node
could store its data so once your
cluster is up and running and in your
sdfs is available we can have our data
stored on sdfs now let's understand how
does that work so any client or an
application which would want to write
data to the cluster needs to interact
with the master to begin with say let's
say client machine or an api or an
application would be interested in
writing the data now how would name node
know about available data nodes so as
soon as the cluster comes up the first
thing which happens is these data nodes
would be sending in their heartbeat to
the name node every three seconds so
data nodes send the heartbeat to name
node every three seconds to let the name
node know to let the master know that
they are available what does name node
do with this name node is building a
metadata in its ram so it already has
some metadata in the disk which was
created as a result of formatting sdfs
and now we would have metadata in ram
which is getting built so initially name
node would have information of which
data nodes are available in the cluster
now if a client or an application wants
to write data to the cluster it gets in
touch with the name node inquiring about
the slave machines or enquiring about
the data nodes where the data can
actually be written your name node
refers to the metadata collected so far
and responds back mentioning the data
nodes or the slave machines which are
available for data storage based on this
response your client takes the file to
sdfs intending to write it to the
cluster now in hadoop we basically have
two things one is the default block size
which we discussed earlier is 128 mb so
you have 128 mb as the default block
size which is customizable and that can
be changed depending on the average data
size and you have the default
replication which is three now we
imagine the application or api or client
would want to write a file which is 256
mb which is bigger than the block size
and this file has to be broken down into
what we call as blocks which are logical
entities so the file is taken to the
framework framework will split the file
into blocks so let's imagine that this
file is 256 mb it will be broken down
into two blocks b1 and b2 and these
blocks will then be randomly distributed
to the slave machines that is the data
nodes so we would have block one say
getting stored here now you could also
have block one getting stored on any of
these data nodes so we would have block
one and then we could have block two
which could be written here and then you
would also have their replicas sitting
on the machine so the rule of
replication is you will never have two
identical blocks sitting on the same
node so if i have block 1 here then i
will never have a replica of block 1
again on the same machine so we will
have a replica of block 2 here block 1
here and you have a replica of block 2
here there is no differentiation between
which one is the original and which one
is the replica for the cluster all the
blocks are same and what also happens is
after the blocks are written your data
nodes are repeatedly sending their block
report to name node every 10 seconds and
this information is again updated in the
name nodes metadata so now name node
will have information what are the files
the files are broken down into what
blocks the blocks are residing on which
data nodes and this metadata is getting
built in the name node as data nodes
respond with their heartbeats and also
every 10 seconds with their block report
now we need to remember one point here
that name node is basically a master and
data nodes are the slave hadoop as a
framework has been coded in java which
basically means that every directory
every file and file related block is
considered as an object which is getting
stored and for every object which name
node is tracking 150 bytes of name nodes
ram is utilized which also tells us that
if the block sizes were smaller than 128
mb then for the same file we would have
more number of blocks which would mean
that name nodes ram would be over
utilized and overload name node so block
size has to be chosen with lot of
consideration on the master's ram and
what is the average size of the data now
this is how the data is distributed in
blocks and distributed across the data
nodes thus sdfs is very fault tolerant
because if any of the data nodes fail
then you still have other data nodes
which have the replica of data does
making it possible to read the data and
access the data even if multiple data
nodes go down now there are other
internals that is how data nodes are
placed in racks or what has rack
awareness to do in block placement but
we will learn on all that later so this
is how your sdfs works now there are
many other things such as the read and
write process
which is taken care by your methods such
as open and create which internally are
playing a role when a read or write
operation happens also facts like
replication is a sequential process but
right activity is parallel so we can
learn more functionality of sdfs in
later sessions but this is in brief on
how sdfs works how your file is split
into blocks and the blocks are getting
stored on the disks note that the block
contains the data so even if you have a
file which is one kilobyte and if this
file is to be stored on sdfs it will
still use a block of 128 mb which does
not mean that there is a disk space
getting wasted when the block resides on
the data nodes disk it will only occupy
one kilobyte of space for the data it
has which means that block is a logical
entity to take your data to the disk and
get it stored on the disk this is how
your sdfs works and basically takes care
of reliable data storage across machines
in distributed fashion now that we have
set up a two node cluster which has two
data nodes two node managers one master
machine let's try working with sdfs
let's look at quick commands which allow
you to write data to the cluster
although there are different ways the
first way is using commands the second
is using an ide and where you could
write your code to use hadoop's file
system api and the third is a graphical
user interface called hue which normally
does not come with apache although it
can work with apache it comes as a
service with cloud era and other
distributions to work with hdfs we need
some sample data now there are various
websites from where you can get some
sample data so you can open up your
browser and let me show you some sample
places or sample data set links from
where you can download bigger or smaller
files which then can be used to write
data to your sdfs although you could
just pick up a local file or you could
create your own files and write them to
sdfs there are various data set sites
which can be used so for example you can
type in machine learning uci data sets
and this is one link which has more than
200 data sets which can be used for even
data science kind of activities which
can be used for testing with your
algorithms and you can download data
from here on to your local machine and
then from your local machine we will be
writing the data to hdfs which then
based on the size of the data splits the
data into blocks and your blocks would
get stored on your underlying machines
wherever data nodes run so i can click
on this uci machine learning repository
or even just on data sets to be very
specific all we need is some sample data
sets you can get kegel data sets you can
get data sets from yelp website which
are bigger data sets zipped and you can
be using them to write data to see how
your files split into multiple blocks
now here we have lot of data we can
click on any one link to begin with and
here i have the data folder shows me the
sum file and i can
just right click on this
save link as and save the file this is a
simple text file and we can save it and
you can get various data sets from here
you can even go to yelp data set
challenge
and that has bigger files which are
zipped and they can be downloaded so you
can click on download data set although
i will not start the downloading here
you can just given your name here just
some email id
some initials and you can click on
download so this is one more website
where you can download the json data
sets which are 3.6 gigabytes in
compressed format and then you have
photos which are 7.2 gigabytes you can
also say gutenberg download books and
that is again a website from where you
can download
free data sets which are not very huge
so try to get some variety of data sets
in different formats which then you can
write to hdfs you can even use your sdfs
log files which already exist on your
machines and you don't need to download
anything from internet now let's close
this for now so i already have some file
let's copy this from home htc downloads
that was my file let's copy to home htc
and here's my file i can check the
permissions so that's owned by sdc i can
even look into user local hadoop
logs and there are some already log
files so you can even copy some of these
files using copy
user local hadoop logs and let's take
hadoop
data node related log and let's copy to
home sdc for our testing and now we have
some other files now to work with sdfs
as i said you can always type in hdfs
and that shows you various options now
we already used the first option which
is name node iphone format we also used
hd dfs admin to look at how many nodes
we have and to work with your hdfs file
system the option is dfs so you would
say hdfs dfs and then you can always hit
on enter it shows you various options to
work with your distributed file system
like creating a directory copying some
files getting data from your sdfs to
your local machine changing the
permissions changing the replication and
many other options so here let's click
on hdfs dfs let's create it directly and
let's call it my data so this is a
directory i'm creating on hdfs remember
this directory will not be seen on your
local machine it is a hdfs directory now
if i look in my root i don't see my data
because that's a sdfs directory which is
technically getting created on sdfs and
once you start writing data to sdfs the
relevant blocks will start getting
stored under abc slash data so as of now
we can always keep a browser open to see
as we work with sdfs how does the data
propagate or come to your distributed
file system using the web interface
so here let's say http
slash m1
50070 and that's my browser interface
let's click on utilities and let's click
on browse the file system which should
show the directory which we have created
although that does not have any data as
of now let's go in here and now we know
that we have some files here so i will
say hdfs dfs and this has two options
either i can say put or i can say copy
from local both of these do the same
thing and both of these you can find
here so we have put and we should have
copy from local that is you are copying
the data from your local machine to your
hdfs so now i will say copy from local i
will say take the aba directory or file
and put it in my data so now i'm
technically
copying a file from my local file system
to my hdfs which is then using again my
local file systems path so this is done
let's quickly check by clicking on my
data if my file is written now if you
see this file is 187 kilobytes however
this will still use a block of 128 and
in my previous sessions i already
explained why a block of 128 but when it
goes to the disk it will only occupy the
space for the data the block has we can
quickly go in here and we can do a hdfs
dfs listing of my directory which should
have my file now and we can quickly
check if my file is replicated either
using the web interface which says
replication is true that means the file
related blocks should be getting stored
on the underlying data nodes we can
always click on overview if we would
want to browse and scroll down which
says there are three files in a
directory the file has one block so
totally you have four file system
objects we can scroll down to show or
see we have two live nodes and if you
see each node has one block we can
always look from our data path
by looking into abc slash data slash
current that has block pool directory
that has current that has finalized that
has sub directory subdirectory and the
block look at the size of the block it
is 191 which relates to the kilobyte
size which we are talking about
similarly we can check on m2 machine
which also has a data node running to
make sure our file related block is
replicated so look in block pool current
finalized subdirectory subdirectory and
that shows me the same block which is
replicated with its meta file and with
the same size this ensures that my data
is getting replicated as per whatever
factor we have set and my file is
written to htfs and now i can also do a
complete listing i can just say a
recursive listing to show me all the
directories and all the files which i
have in my hdfs i think we are
forgetting something we are logged in as
root which is not right so we need to be
logged in as htc and then we can try our
commands that is hpfs dfs iphone ls
slash which should show me my directory
but then if you would want to do a
recursive listing of showing all the
directories and files you can just add
hyphen r so we have written a file to
hdfs in my data directory similarly i
can write using a put command last time
we used a copy from local i will use a
put command i will say let's take this
log file and let us write it to the my
data directory instead of copy from
local i am using a put command which
also allows me to write the file to my
htfs once this is done let's go to the
web ui and let's go to browse the file
system let's look in our directory and
that shows me that i have a log file
which is even smaller than the first
file which we wrote it is in kilobytes
however it is replicated it is using
still the block size and we can always
go back and look at the terminal to see
if for my new file i have a new block
which should be in my data path and if
you see this this is my block which will
also have an application on machine 2.
so this is how you write one file or you
could write multiple files you could
write multiple files let's create some
files here so i have these log files
let's say hadoop log and let's give it a
name like this so now if you see i just
created multiple files and i can also
say sdfs dfs make directory let's say my
data tool so i'm creating a new
directory on my sdfs and then i can even
copy multiple files or a complete
directory so all i need to do here is
give a matching pattern or a directory
so i'll say sdfs dfs put and then i can
say take all the directories of files
and put it to my data too remember this
one file or multiple files are following
the replication what has been set at a
cluster level now if we do a recursive
listing where i would want to see all
the directories and the files which are
within my hdfs i see that i have a my
data directory and i also have a mydata2
directory which has multiple files and
all of the files within the directory
are following the replication set at a
cluster level so all of them are having
their blocks replicated twice we can
always go back here we can just do a
back and that shows me what i have in my
data too everything is replicated twice
what i have in my data is also
replicated twice now sdfs also has a
functionality where you can write data
with a different replication so let's
create one more directory and now let's
write data with a different replication
so the way i write my files i follow the
same thing however now i will say hyphen
dfs dfs.replication
and i will specify it as one so i am
passing in as argument and i am
specifying that i would want to write
data with a replication of just one so
my blocks will not be considered under
replicated and i am choosing to write
these files in this directory with a
replication of one we can check from our
browser interface by just doing a quick
refresh and here if i click on my data
three it shows it follows a replication
of one there is also a command to check
your replication status using hdfs so we
can say stfs fsck slash files slash
blocks and if i would want to see only
blocks or only files i could choose one
of them now here i have given a complete
sdfs file system i can replace that with
slash my data so i can say my data 3
this is what i would want to see and
this will show me within this directory
how many files i have how many blocks
does each file use and is it replicated
correctly so my fsck command gives me an
information that in my data 3 i have one
file which is 24 kilobytes uses one
block because it's very smaller than 128
and it is replicated only once so there
is no situation of over under
misreplicated blocks we have our files
correctly replicated as they were
specified while writing same thing can
be seen for other files say mydata2 and
that will tell me that all the files
within my data 2 were replicated as per
the default replication which was at a
cluster level and if you see here
everything is replicated twice we don't
have any over under misreplicated blocks
and my file system status is healthy so
this is the sdfs command to make sure
that your files are replicated correctly
so we have seen how your files are
written with default replication we have
seen how your files follow a dynamic
replication what you specify on the
command line now we can also see a
command which allows us to change
replication after the data has been
written so i can say set rep and i can
say path that is my data 3 where i
initially had all my file related blocks
replicated only once and now i'll say my
data 3 and i can specify that this
should follow a replication of 2 which
basically means that it will look into
the directory it will check all the
files which had only one block and now
it will create a replica of those blocks
across other data nodes we can always go
back and look into the data node logs to
see the replication happening we can
also look from the browser interface
which initially was showing an
application of one and now it shows a
replication of two so this is the
command to change the replication after
the data has been written so our rights
can have default replication we can
write files with a different replication
we can change the replication after the
data is written not only that we can
even get the data from our hdfs to my
local machine and for that i'll give
hdfs get command or copy to local so i
can say my data 3 and then i can bring
it to my local machine in home hdc using
a get command so this is to get data
from your sdfs to your local machine
using a hdfs command now if you see i
should have a mydata3 directory which is
in my
local path and we can look in my data 3
it has all the files which we had on
hdfs so we were not only putting data
from our local machine to sdfs we also
successfully brought data from our hdfs
to local machine we have written data
with different replication we have
checked the status of nodes we have
checked the status of blocks and if we
would want to delete some data sdfs also
has options for that so i can say hdfs
dfs remove and i could also do a
recursive remove to remove everything
including the directory from my data3 so
this will delete data from my hdfs
however if thrash is enabled now thrash
basically means recycle bin which
depends on a property in the core hyphen
site file we have not enabled it if
thrash is enabled then your data will be
deleted from hdfs however it will not be
permanently deleted it will sit in
thrash for a time interval what admin
has specified in the configuration file
so right now i deleted thrash and this
seems to be gone from sdfs because we
have not set up any thresh however if a
thrash is set up then either you can
decide to have your data deleted and
still be in thrash so that it could be
restored or you could delete it
permanently using a skip thrash option
however remember this skip thrash option
makes more sense if the thrash is
enabled in your cluster and you do not
want your deleted data to be string in
thrash even for whatever time interval
has been set because even if the data
sits in thrash and your thrash is a
directory structure on hdfs all the data
will still be replicated so we have seen
how you can write data to the cluster
how you can get data from cluster to
your local machine how you can write it
with different replications how you can
delete it from your cluster and do a
recursive listing of your directories
and files now there are various other
commands which can be used for example
something like copy or move or change
permissions and many more
thanks ajay now we have richard and ajay
taking us through the hadoop ecosystem
we will look into hdfs mapreduce yarn
scoop hive pig and hbase suppose you
have a library that has a collection of
huge number of books on each floor and
you want to count the total number of
books present on each floor what would
be your approach you could say i will do
it myself but then don't you think that
will take a lot of time and that's
obviously not an efficient way of
counting the number of books in this
huge collection on every floor by
yourself now there could be a different
approach or an alternative to that you
could think of asking three of your
friends or three of your colleagues and
you could then say if each friend could
count the books on every floor then
obviously that would make your work
faster and easier to count the books on
every floor now this is what we mean by
parallel processing so when you say
parallel processing in technical terms
you are talking about using multiple
machines and each machine would be
contributing its ram and cpu cores for
processing and your data would be
processed on multiple machines at the
same time now this type of process
involves parallel processing in our case
or in our library example where you
would have person 1 who would be taking
care of books on floor 1 and counting
them person 2 on floor 2 then you have
someone on floor 3 and someone on floor
4. so every individual would be counting
the books on every floor in parallel so
that reduces the time consumed for this
activity and then there should be some
mechanism where all these counts from
every floor can be aggregated so what is
each person doing here each person is
mapping the data of a particular floor
or you can say each person is doing a
kind of activity or basically a task on
every floor and the task is counting the
books on every floor now then you could
have some aggregation mechanism that
could basically reduce or summarize this
total count and in terms of map reduce
we would say that's the work of reducer
so when you talk about hadoop map reduce
it processes data on different node
machines now this is the whole concept
of hadoop framework right that you not
only have your data stored across
machines but you would also want to
process the data locally so instead of
transferring the data from one machine
to other machine or bringing all the
data together into some central
processing unit and then processing it
you would rather have the data processed
on the machines wherever that is stored
so we know in case of hadoop cluster we
would have our data stored on multiple
data nodes on their multiple disks and
that is the data which needs to be
processed but the requirement is that we
want to process this data as fast as
possible and that could be achieved by
using parallel processing now in case of
mapreduce we basically have the first
phase which is your mapping phase so in
case of mapreduce programming model you
basically have two phases one is mapping
and one is reducing now who takes care
of things in mapping phase it is a
mapper class and this mapper class has
the function which is provided by the
developer which takes care of these
individual map tasks which will work on
multiple nodes in parallel your reducer
class belongs to the reducing phase so a
reducing phase basically uses a reducer
class which provides a function that
will aggregate and reduce the output of
different data nodes to generate the
final output now that's how your
mapreduce works using mapping and then
obviously reducing now you could have
some other kind of jobs which are map
only jobs wherein there is no reducing
required but we are not talking about
those we are talking about our
requirement where we would want to
process the data using mapping and
reducing especially when data is huge
when data is stored across multiple
machines and you would want to process
the data in parallel so when you talk
about mapreduce you could say it's a
programming model you could say
internally it's a processing engine of
hadoop that allows you to process and
compute huge volumes of data and when we
say huge volumes of data we can talk
about terabytes we can talk about
petabytes exabytes and that amount of
data which needs to be processed on a
huge cluster we could also use mapreduce
programming model and run a mapreduce
algorithm in a local mode but what does
that mean if you would go for a local
mode it basically means it would do all
the mapping and reducing on the same
node using the processing capacity that
is ram and cpu cores on the same machine
which is not really efficient in fact we
would want to have our map reduce work
on multiple nodes which would obviously
have mapping phase followed by a
reducing phase and intermittently there
would be data generated there would be
different other phases which help this
whole processing so when you talk about
hadoop map reduce you are mainly talking
about two main components or two main
phases that is mapping and reducing
mapping taking care of map tasks
reducing taking care of reduced tasks so
you would have your data which would be
stored on multiple machines now when we
talk about data data could be in
different formats we could or the
developer could specify what is the
format which needs to be used to
understand the data which is coming in
that data then goes through the mapping
internally there would be some shuffling
sorting and then reducing which gives
you your final output so the way we
access data from sdfs or the way our
data is getting stored on sdfs we have
our input data which would have one or
multiple files in one or multiple
directories and your final output is
also stored on sdfs to be accessed to be
looked into and to see if the processing
was done correctly so this is how it
looks so you have the input data which
would then be worked upon by multiple
map tasks now how many map tasks that
basically depends on the file that
depends on the input format so normally
we know that in a hadoop cluster you
would have a file which is broken down
into blocks depending on its size so the
default block size is 128 mb which can
then still be customized based on your
average size of data which is getting
stored on the cluster so if i have
really huge files which are getting
stored on the cluster i would certainly
set a higher block size so that my every
file does not have huge number of blocks
creating a load on name notes ram
because that's tracking the number of
elements in your cluster or number of
objects in your cluster so depending on
your file size your file would be split
into multiple chunks and for every chunk
we would have a map task running now
what is this map task doing that is
specified within the mapper class so
within the mapper class you have the
mapper function which basically says
what each of these map tasks has to do
on each of the chunks which has to be
processed this data intermittently is
written to sdfs where it is sorted and
shuffled and then you have internal
phases such as partitioner which decides
how many reduced tasks would be used or
what data goes to which reducer you
could also have a combiner phase which
is like a mini reducer doing the same
reduce operation before it reaches
reduce then you have your reducing face
which is taken care by a reducer class
and internally the reducer function
provided by developer which would have
reduced task running on the data which
comes as an output from map tasks
finally your output is then generated
which is stored on sdfs now in case of
hadoop it accepts data in different
formats your data could be in compressed
format your data could be in part k your
data could be in afro text csv psv
binary format and all of these formats
are supported however remember if you
are talking about data being compressed
then you have to also look into what
kind of split ability the compression
mechanism supports otherwise when
mapreduce processing happens it would
take the complete file as one chunk to
be processed so sdfs accepts input data
in different formats this data is stored
in sdfs and that is basically our input
which is then passing through the
mapping phase now what is mapping phase
doing as i said it reads record by
record depending on the input format it
reads the data so we have multiple map
tasks running on multiple chunks once
this data is being read this is broken
down into individual elements and when i
say individual element i could say this
is my list of key value pairs so your
records based on some kind of delimiter
or without delimiter are broken down
into individual elements and thus your
mac creates key value pairs now these
key value pairs are not my final output
these key value pairs are basically a
list of elements which will then be
subjected to further processing so you
would have internally shuffling and
sorting of data so that all the relevant
key value pairs are brought together
which basically benefits the processing
and then you have your reducing which
aggregates the key value pairs into set
of smaller tuples or tuples as you would
say finally your output is getting
stored in the
designated directory as a list of
aggregated key value pairs which gives
you your output so when we talk about
mapreduce one of the key factors here is
the parallel processing which it can
offer so we know that we have a data is
getting stored across multiple data
nodes and you would have huge volume of
data which is split and randomly
distributed across data nodes and this
is the data which needs to be processed
and the best way would be parallel
processing so you could have your data
getting stored on multiple data nodes or
multiple slave nodes and each slave node
would have again one or multiple disks
to process this data basically we have
to go for parallel processing approach
we have to use the map reduce now let's
look at the mapreduce workflow to
understand how it works so basically you
have your input data stored on sdfs now
this is the data which needs to be
processed it is stored in input files
and the processing which you want can be
done on one single file or it can be
done on a directory which has multiple
files you could also later have multiple
outputs merged which we achieved by
using something called as chaining of
mappers so here you have your data
getting stored on sdfs now input format
is basically something to define the
input specification and how the input
files will be split so there are various
input formats now we can search for that
so we can go to google and we can
basically search for
hadoop map reduce
yahoo tutorial this is one of the good
links and if i look into this link i can
search for different input formats and
output formats so let's search for input
format so when we talk about input
format you basically have something to
define how input files are split so
input files are split up and read based
on what input format is specified so
this is a class that provides following
functionality it selects the files or
other objects that should be used for
input it defines the input split that
break a file into tasks provides a
factory for record reader objects that
read the file so there are different
formats if you look in the table here
and you can see that the text input
format is the default format which reads
lines of a text file and each line is
considered as a record here the key is
the byte offset of the line and the
value is the line content it says you
can have key value input format which
passes lines into key value pairs
everything up to the first tab character
is the key and the remainder is the line
you could also have sequence file input
format which basically works on binary
format so you have input format and in
the same way you can also search for
output format which takes care of how
the data is handled after the processing
is done so the key value pairs provided
to this output collector are then
written to output files the way they are
written is governed by output format so
it functions pretty much like input
format as described in earlier right so
we could set what is the output format
foreign
[Music]
and this logically represents the data
to be processed by individual map tasks
or you could say individual mapper
functions so you could have one or
multiple splits which need to be
processed depending on the file size
depending on what properties have been
set now once this is done you have your
input splits which are subjected to
mapping phase internally you have a
record reader which communicates with
the input split and converts the data
into key value pairs suitable to be read
by mapper and what is mapper doing it is
basically working on these key value
pairs the map task giving you an
intermittent output which would then be
forwarded for further processing now
once that is done and we have these key
value pairs which is being worked upon
my map your map tasks as a part of your
mapper function are generating your key
value pairs which are your intermediate
outputs to be processed further now you
could have as i said a combiner face or
internally a mini radio surface now
combiner does not have its own class so
combiner basically uses the same class
as the reducer class provided by the
developer and its main work is to do the
reducing or its main work is to do some
kind of mini aggregation on the key
value pairs which were generated by map
so once the data is coming in from the
combiner then we have internally a
partitioner phase which decides how
outputs from combiners are sent to the
reducers or you could also say that even
if i did not have a combiner partitioner
would decide based on the keys and
values based on the type of keys how
many reducers would be required or how
many reduced tasks would be required to
work on your output which was generated
by map task now once partitioner has
decided that then your data would be
then sorted and shuffled which is then
fed into the reducer so when you talk
about your reducer it would basically
have one or multiple reduced tasks now
that depends on what or what partitioner
decided or determined for your data to
be processed it can also depend on the
configuration properties which have been
set to decide how many radio stars
should be used now internally all this
data is obviously going through sorting
and shuffling so that your reducing or
aggregation becomes an easier task once
we have this done we basically have the
reducer which is the code for the
reducer is provided by the developer and
all the intermediate data has then to be
aggregated to give you a final output
which would then be stored on sdfs and
who does this you have an internal
record writer which writes these output
key value pairs from reducer to the
output files now this is how your map
reduce works wherein the final output
data can be not only stored but then
read or access from sdfs or even used as
an input for further mapreduce kind of
processing so this is how it overall
looks so you basically have your data
stored on sdfs based on input format you
have the splits then you have record
reader which gives your data to the
mapping phase which is then taken care
by your mapper function and mapper
function basically means one or multiple
map tasks working on your chunks of data
you could have a combiner phase which is
optional which is not mandatory then you
have a partitioner phase which decides
on how many reduced tasks or how many
reducers would be used to work on your
data internally there is sorting and
shuffling of data happening and then
basically based on your output format
your record reader will write the output
to sdfs directory now internally you
could also remember that data is being
processed locally so you would have the
output of each task which is being
worked upon stored locally however we do
not access the data directly from data
nodes we access it from sdfs so our
output is stored on sdfs so that is your
mapreduce workflow when you talk about
mapreduce architecture now this is how
it would look so you would have
basically a edge node or a client
program or an api which intends to
process some data so it submits the job
to the job tracker or you can say
resource manager in case of hadoop yarn
framework right now before this step we
can also say that an interaction with
name node would have already happened
which would have given information of
data nodes which have the relevant data
stored then your master processor so in
hadoop version 1 we had job tracker and
then the slaves were called task
trackers in hadoop version 2 instead of
job tracker you have resource manager
and of task trackers you have node
managers so basically your resource
manager has to assign the job to the
task trackers or node managers so your
node managers as we discussed in yarn
are basically taking care of processing
which happens on every node so
internally there is all of this work
happening by resource manager node
managers and application master then you
can refer to the yarn based tutorial to
understand more about that so here your
processing master is basically breaking
down the application into tasks what it
does internally is once your application
is submitted your application to be run
on yarn processing framework is handled
by resource manager now forget about the
yarn part as of now i mean who does the
negotiating of resources who allocates
them how does the processing happen on
the nodes right so that's all to do with
how yarn handles the processing request
so you have your data which is stored in
sdfs broken down into one or multiple
splits depending on the input format
which has been specified by the
developer your input splits are to be
worked upon by your one or multiple map
tasks which will be running within the
container on the nodes basically you
have the resources which are being
utilized so for each map task you would
have some amount of ram which will be
utilized and then further the same data
which has to go through reducing phase
that is your reduced task will also be
utilizing some ram and cpu cores now
internally you have these functions
which take care of deciding on number of
reducers doing a mini reduce and
basically reading and processing the
data from multiple data nodes now this
is how your mapreduce programming model
makes parallel processing work or
processes your data which is stored
across multiple machines finally you
have your output which is getting stored
on its dfs
so let's have a quick demo on mapreduce
and see how it works on a hadoop cluster
now we have discussed briefly about
mapreduce which contains mainly two
phases that is your mapping phase and
your reducing phase and mapping phase is
taken care by your mapper function and
your reducing phase is taken care by
your reducer function now in between we
also have sorting and shuffling and then
you have other phases which is
partitioner and combiner and we will
discuss about all those in detail in
later sessions but let's have a quick
demo on how we can run a mapreduce which
is already existing as a package jar
file within your apache hadoop cluster
or even in your cloudera cluster now we
can build our own map reduce programs we
can package them as jar transfer them to
the cluster and then run it on a hadoop
cluster on yarn or we could be using
already provided default program so
let's see where they are now these are
my two machines which i have brought up
and basically this would have my apache
hadoop cluster running now we can just
do a simple start hyphen all dot sh now
i know that this script is deprecated
and it says instead use start dfs and
start yarn but then it will still take
care of starting off my cluster on these
two nodes where i would have one single
name node two data nodes one secondary
name node one resource manager and two
node managers now if you have any doubt
in how this cluster came up you can
always look at the previous sessions
where we had a walkthrough in setting up
a cluster on apache and then you could
also have your cluster running using
less than 3gb of your total machine ram
and you could have apache cluster
running on your machine now once this
cluster comes up we will also have a
look at the web ui which is available
for name node and resource manager now
based on the settings what we have given
our uis will show us details of our
cluster but remember the ui is only to
browse now here my cluster has come up i
can just do a jps to look at java
related processes and that will show me
what are the processes which are running
on c1 which is your data node resource
manager node manager and name node and
on my m1 machine which is my second
machine which i've configured here i can
always do a jps and that shows me the
processes running which also means that
my cluster is up with two data nodes
with two node managers and here i can
have a look at my web ui so i can just
do a refresh and the same thing with
this one just to refresh so i had
already opened the web pages so you can
always access the web ui using your name
notes host name and 570 port it tells me
what is my cluster id what is my blog
pool id it gives you information of what
is the space usage how many live nodes
you have and you can even browse your
file system so i have put in a lot of
data here i can click on browse the file
system and this basically shows me
multiple directories and these
directories have one or multiple files
which we will use for our mapreduce
example now if you see here these are my
directories which have some sample files
although these files are very small like
8.7 kilobytes if you look into this
directory if you look into this i have
just pulled in some of my hadoop logs
and i have put it on my sdfs these are a
little bigger files and then we also
have some other data which we can see
here and this is data which i have
downloaded from web now we can either
run a mapreduce on a single file or in a
directory which contains multiple files
let's look at that before looking at
demo and mapreduce also remember
mapreduce will create a output directory
and we need to have that directory
created plus we need to have the
permissions to run the mapreduce job so
by default since i'm running it using
admin id i should not have any problem
but then if you intend to run mapreduce
with a different user then obviously you
will have to ask the admin or you will
have to give the user permission to read
and write from sdfs so this is the
directory which i have created which
will contain my output once the
mapreduce job finishes and this is my
cluster file system if you look on this
ui this shows me about my yarn which is
available for taking care of any
processing it as of now shows that i
have total of 8 gb memory and i have 8 v
cores now that can be depending on what
configuration we have set or how many
nodes are available we can look at nodes
which are available and that shows me i
have two node managers running each has
8 gb memory and 8 v cores now that's not
true actually but then we have not set
the configurations for node managers and
that's why it takes the default
properties that is 8gb laminate we
course now this is my yarn ui we can
also look at scheduler which basically
shows me the different cues if they have
been configured where you will have to
run the jobs we'll discuss about all
these in later in detail now let's go
back to our terminal and let's see where
we can find some sample applications
which we can run on the cluster so once
i go to the terminal i can well submit
the mapreduce job from any terminal now
here i know that my hadoop related
directory is here and within hadoop you
have various directories we have
discussed that in binaries you have the
commands which you can run in s bin you
basically have the startup scripts and
here you also notice there is a share
directory in the end if you look in the
shared directory you would find hadoop
and within hadoop you have various sub
directories in which we will look for
map reduce now this mapreduce directory
has some sample jar files which we can
use to run a mapreduce on the cluster
similarly if you are working on a
cloudera cluster you would have to go
into opt cloudera parcel cdh slash lib
and in that you would have directories
for sdfs mapreduce or sdfs yarn where
you can still find the same jars it is
basically a package which contains your
multiple applications now how do we run
a mapreduce we can just type in hadoop
and hit enter and that shows me that i
have an option called jar which can be
used to run a jar file now at any point
of time if you would want to see what
are the different classes which are
available in a particular
jar you could always do a jar minus xvf
for example i could say jar xv f and i
could say user local hadoop
share hadoop mapreduce and then list
down your jar file so i'll say hadoop
mapreduce examples and if i do this this
should basically unpack it to show me
what classes are available within this
particular jar and it has done this it
has created a meta file and it has
created a org directory we can see that
by doing a ls and here if you look in ls
org since i run the command from your
phone directory i can look into org
patchy hadoop examples which shows me
the classes which i have and those
classes contain which mapper or reducer
classes so it might not be just mapper
and reducer but you can always have a
look so for example i am targeting to
use word count program which does a word
count on files and gives me a list of
words and how many times they occur in a
particular file or in set of files and
this shows me that what are the classes
which belong to word count so we have a
int sum reducer so this is my reducer
class i have tokenizer mapper that is my
mapper class right and basically this is
what is used these classes are used if
you run a word code now there are many
other programs which are part of this
jar file and we can expand and see that
so i can say hadoop jar and give your
path so i'll say hadoop jar user local
hadoop share hadoop map reduce hadoop
mapreduce examples and if i hit on enter
that will show me what are the inbuilt
classes which are already available now
these are certain things which we can
use now there are other jar files also
for example i can look at hadoop and
here we can look at the jar files which
we have in this particular path so this
is one hadoop mapreduce examples which
you can use you can always look in other
jar files like you can look for
hadoop mapreduce client job client and
then you can look at the test one so
that is also an interesting one so you
can always look into hadoop mapreduce
client job client and then you have
something ending with this so if i would
have tried this one using my hadoop jar
command so in my previous example when
we did this it was showing me all the
classes which are available and that
already has a word count now there are
other good programs which you can try
like teragen to generate dummy data
terasort to check your sorting
performance and so on and terra validate
to validate the results similarly we can
also do a hadoop jar as i said on hadoop
mapreduce i think that was client and
then we have
job client and then test star now this
has a lot of other classes which can be
used or programs which can be used for
doing a stress testing or checking your
cluster status and so on one of them
interesting one is test dfs io but let's
not get into all the details in first
instance let's see how we can run a
mapreduce now if i would want to run a
mapreduce i need to give hadoop jar and
then my jar file and if i hit on enter
it would say it needs the input and
output it needs which class you want to
run so for example i would say word
count and again if i hit on enter it
tells me that you need to give me some
input and output to process and
obviously this process will be happening
on cluster that is our yarn processing
framework unless and until you want to
run this job in a local mode so there is
a possibility that you can run the job
in local mode but let's first try how it
runs on the cluster so how do we do that
now here i can do a hdfs
ls slash command see what i have on my
sdfs now through my ui i was already
showing you that we have set up files
and directories which we can use to
process now we can take up one single
file so for example if i pick up new
data and i can look into the files here
what we have and we can basically run a
mapreduce on a single file or multiple
files so let's take this file whatever
that contains and i would like to do a
word count so that i get a list of words
and their occurrence and this file so
let me just copy this now i also need in
addition
output to be written
that
now i need to give my input so that will
be new data and then i will give this
file which we just copied now i am going
to run the word count only on a single
file and i will basically have my output
which will be stored in this directory
the directory which i have created
already mr output so let's do this
output and this is fair enough now you
can give many other properties you can
specify how many map jobs you want to
run how many reduced jobs you want to
run do you want your output to be
compressed do you want your output to be
merged or many other properties can be
defined when you are specifying word
count and then you can pass in an
argument to pass properties from the
command line which will affect your
output now once i go ahead and submit
this this is basically running a simple
inbuilt mapreduce job on our hadoop
cluster now obviously internally it will
be looking for name node now we have
some issue here and it says the output
already exists what does that mean so it
basically means that hadoop will create
an output for you you just need to give
a name but then you don't need to create
it so let's give let's append the output
with number one and then let's go ahead
and run this so i've submitted this
command now this can also be done in
background if you would want to run
multiple jobs on your cluster at the
same time so it takes total input paths
to processes one so that is there is
only one split on which your job has to
work now it will internally try to
contact your resource manager and
basically this is done so here we can
have a look and we can see some counters
here now what i also see is for some
property which it is missing it has run
the job but it has run in a local mode
it has run in a local mode so although
we have submitted so this might be
related to my yarn settings and we can
check that
so if i do a refresh when i have run my
application it has completed it would
have created an output but the only
thing is it did not interact with your
yarn it did not interact with your
resource manager we can check those
properties and here if we look into the
job it basically tells me that it went
for mapping and reducing it would have
created an output it worked on my file
but then it ran in a local mode it ran
in a local mode so mapreduce remember is
a programming model right now if you run
it on yarn you get the facilities of
running it on a cluster where yarn takes
care of resource management if you don't
run it on yarn and run it on a local
mode it will use your machine's ram and
cpu cores for processing but then we can
quickly look at the output and then we
can also try running this on yarn so if
i look into my hdfs and if i look into
my output mr output that's the directory
which was not used actually let's look
into the other directory which is ending
with one and that should show me the
output created by this mapreduce
although it ran in the local mode it
fetched an input file from usdfs and it
would have created output in hdfs now
that's my part file which is created and
if you look at part minus r minus these
zeros if you would have more than one
reducer running then you would have
multiple such files created we can look
into this what does this file contain
which should have my word count and here
i can say cat which basically shows me
what is the output created by my
mapreduce let's have a look into this so
the file which we gave for processing
has been broken down and now we have the
list of words which occur in the file
plus a count of those words so if there
is some word which is in is more then it
shows me the count so this is a list of
my words and the count for that so this
is how we run a sample mapreduce job i
will also show you how we can run it on
yeah now let's run mapreduce on yarn and
initially when we tried running a
mapreduce it did not hit yarn but it ran
in a local mode and that was because
there was a property which had to be
changed in mapreduce hyphen site file so
basically if you look into this file the
error was that i had given a property
which says
mapred.framework.name and that was not
the right property name and it was
ignored and that's why it ran in a local
mode so i changed the property to
mapreduce.framework.name
restarted my cluster and everything
should be fine now and that mapred
hyphen site file has also been copied
across the nodes now to run a mapreduce
on a hadoop cluster so that it uses yarn
and yarn takes care of resource
allocation on one or multiple machines
so i'm just changing the output here and
now i will submit this job which should
first connect to the resource manager
and if it connects to the resource
manager that means our job will be run
using yarn on the cluster rather than in
a local mode so now we have to wait for
this application to internally connect
to resource manager and once it starts
there we can always go back to the web
ui and check if our application has
reached yarn so it shows me that there
is one input part to be processed that's
my job id that's my application id which
you can even monitor status from the
command line now here the job has been
submitted so let's go back here and just
do a refresh on my yarn ui which should
show me the new application which is
submitted it tells me that it is an
accepted state application master has
already started and if you click on this
link it will also give you more details
of how many map and reduced tasks would
run so as of now it says the application
master is running it would be using this
node which is m1 we can always look into
the logs we can see that there is a one
task attempt which is being made and now
if i go back to my terminal i will see
that it is waiting to get some resources
from the cluster and once it gets the
resources it will first start with the
mapping phase where the mapper function
runs it does the map tasks one or
multiple depending on the splits so
right now we have one file and one split
so we will have just one map task
running and once the mapping phase
completes then it will get into reducing
which will finally give me my output so
we can be toggling through these
sessions so here i can just do a refresh
to see what is happening with my
application is it proceeding is it still
waiting for resource manager to allocate
some resources now just couple of
minutes back i tested this application
on yarn and we can see that my first
application completed successfully and
here we will have to give some time so
that yarn can allocate the resources now
if the resources were used by some other
application they will have to be freed
up now internally yarn takes care of all
that which we will learn more detail in
yarn or you might have already followed
the yarn based session now here we will
have to just give it some more time and
let's see if my application proceeds
with the resources what yarn can
allocate to it sometimes you can also
see a slowness in what web ui shows up
and that can be related to the amount of
memory you have allocated to your notes
now for apache we can have less amount
of memory and we can still run the
cluster and as i said the memory which
shows up here 16 gb and 16 cores is not
the true one those are the default
settings right but then my yarn should
be able to facilitate running of this
application let's just give it a couple
of seconds and then let's look into the
output here again i had to make some
changes in the settings because our
application was not getting enough
resources and then basically i restarted
my cluster now let's submit the
application again to the cluster which
first should contact the resource
manager and then basically the map and
reduce process to start so here i have
submitted an application it is
connecting to the resource manager and
then basically it will start internally
in app master that is application master
it is looking for the number of splits
which is one it's getting the
application id and it basically then
starts running the job it also gives you
a tracking url to look at the output and
now we should go back and look at our
yarn ui if our application shows up here
and we will have to give it a couple of
seconds when it can get the final status
change to running and that's where my
application will be getting resources
now if you closely notice here i have
allocated specific amount of memory that
is 1.5 gb for node manager on every node
and i have basically given two cores
each which my machines also have and my
yarn should be utilizing these resources
rather than going for default now the
application has started moving
and we can see the progress bar here
which basically will show what is
happening and if we go back to the
terminal it will show that first it went
in deciding map and reduce it goes for
map once the mapping phase completes
then the reducing phase will come into
existence and here my job has completed
so now it has basically used we can
always look at how many map and reduce
sas were run it shows me that there was
one map and one reduced task now with
the number of map tasks depends on the
number of splits and we had just one
file which is less than 128 mb so that
was one split to be processed and
reduced task is internally decided by
the reducer or depending on what kind of
property has been set in hadoop config
files now it also tells me how many
input records were read which basically
means these were the number of lines in
the file it tells me output records
which gives me the number of total words
in the file now there might be
duplicates and that which is processed
by internal combiner further processing
or forwarding that information to
reducer and basically reducer works on 3
35 records gives us a list of words and
their count now if i do a refresh here
this would obviously show my application
is completed it says succeeded you can
always click on the application to look
for more information it tells me where
it ran now we do not have a history
server running as of now otherwise we
can always access more information so
this leads to history server where all
your applications are stored but i can
click on this attempt tasks and this
will basically show me the history url
or you can always look into the logs so
this is how you can submit a sample
application which is inbuilt which is
available in the jar on your hadoop
cluster and that will utilize your
cluster to run now you could always as i
said when you are running a particular
job remember to change the output
directory and if you would not want it
to be processing is a single individual
file you could also point it to a
directory that basically means it will
have multiple files and depending on the
file sizes there would be multiple
splits and according to that multiple
map tasks will be selected so if i click
on this this would submit my second
application to the cluster which should
first connect to resource manager then
resource manager has to start an
application master now here we are
targeting 10 splits now you have to
sometimes give couple of seconds in your
machines so that the resources which
were used are internally already freed
up so that your cluster can pick it up
and then your yarn can take care of
resources so right now my application is
an undefined status but then as soon as
my yarn provides it the resources we
will have the application running on our
yarn cluster so it has already started
if you see it is going further then it
would launch 10 map tasks and it would
the number of reduced stars would be
decided on either the way your data is
or based on the properties which have
been set at your cluster level let's
just do a quick refresh here on my yarn
ui to show me the progress also take
care that when you are submitting your
application you need to have the output
directory mentioned however do not
create it hadoop will create that for
you now this is how you run a mapreduce
without specifying properties but then
you can specify more properties you can
look into what are the things which can
be changed for your mapper and reducer
or basically having a combiner class
which can do a mini reducing and all
those things can be done so we will
learn about that in the later sessions
now we will compare hadoop version 1
that is with mapreduce version one we
will understand and learn about the
limitations of hadoop version one what
is the need of yarn what is yarn what
kind of workloads can be running on yarn
what are yarn components what is yarn
architecture and finally we will see a
demo on yarn so hadoop version one or
mapreduce version one well that's
outdated now and nobody is using hadoop
version one but it would be good to
understand what was in hadoop version 1
and what were the limitations of hadoop
version 1 which brought in the thought
for the future processing layer that is
yan now when we talk about hadoop we
already know that hadoop is a framework
and hadoop has two layers one is your
storage layer that is your sdfs hadoop
distributed file system which allows for
distributed storage and processing which
allows fault tolerance by inbuilt
replication and which basically allows
you to store huge amount of data across
multiple commodity machines when we talk
about processing we know that map reduce
is the oldest and the most mature
processing programming model which
basically takes care of your data
processing on your distributed file
system so in hadoop version 1 mapreduce
performed both data processing and
resource management and that's how it
was problematic in mapreduce we had
basically when we talked about the
processing layer we had the master which
was called job tracker and then you had
the slaves which were the task records
so your job tracker was taking care of
allocating resources it was performing
scheduling and even monitoring the jobs
it basically was taking care of
assigning map and reduced tasks to the
jobs running on task records and task
trackers which were co-located with data
nodes were responsible for processing
the jobs so task trackers were the
slaves for the processing layer which
reported their progress to the job
tracker so this is what was happening in
hadoop version 1. now when we talk about
hadoop version 1 we would have say
client machines or an api or an
application which basically submits the
job to the master that is job tracker
now obviously we cannot forget that
there would already be an involvement
from name node which basically tells
which are the machines or which are the
data nodes where the data is already
stored now once the job submission
happens to the job tracker job tracker
being the master demon for taking care
of your processing request and also
resource management job scheduling would
then be interacting with your multiple
task trackers which would be running on
multiple machines so each machine would
have a task tracker running and that
task tracker which is a processing slave
would be co-located with the data nodes
now we know that in case of hadoop you
have the concept of moving the
processing to wherever the data is
stored rather than moving the data to
the processing layer so we would have
task trackers which would be running on
multiple machines and these task
trackers would be responsible for
handling the tasks what are these tasks
these are the application which is
broken down into smaller tasks which
would work on the data which is
respectively stored on that particular
node now these were your slave demons
right so your job tracker was not only
tracking the resources so your task
trackers were sending heartbeats they
were sending in packets and information
to the job tracker which would then be
knowing how many resources and when we
talk about resources we are talking
about the cpu cores we are talking about
the ram which would be available on
every node so task trackers would be
sending in their resource information to
job tracker and your job tracker would
be already aware of what amount of
resources are available on a particular
node how loaded a particular node is
what kind of work could be given to the
task tracker so job tracker was taking
care of resource management and it was
also breaking the application into tasks
and doing the job scheduling part assign
different tasks to these slave demons
that is your task trackers so job
tracker was eventually overburdened
right because it was managing jobs it
was tracking the resources from multiple
task trackers and basically it was
taking care of job scheduling so job
tracker would be overburdened and in a
case if job tracker would fail then it
would affect the overall processing so
if the master is skilled if the master
demand dies then the processing cannot
proceed now this was one of the
limitations of hadoop version one so
when you talk about scalability that is
the capability to scale due to a single
job tracker scalability would be hitting
a bottleneck you cannot have a cluster
size of more than 4000 nodes and cannot
run more than 40 000 concurrent tasks
now that's just a number we could always
look into the individual resources which
each machine was having and then we can
come up with an appropriate number
however with a single job tracker there
was no horizontal scalability for the
processing layer because we had single
processing master now when we talk about
availability job tracker as i mentioned
would be a single point of failure now
any failure kills all the queued and
running jobs and jobs would have to be
resubmitted now why would we want that
in a distributed platform in a cluster
which has hundreds and thousands of
machines we would want a processing
layer which can handle huge amount of
processing which could be more scalable
which could be more available and could
handle different kind of workloads when
it comes to resource utilization now if
you would have a predefined number of
map and reduce slots for each task
tracker you would have issues which
would relate to resource utilization and
that again is putting a burden on the
master which is tracking these resources
which has to assign jobs which can run
on multiple machines in parallel so
limitations in running non-map reduce
applications now that was one more
limitation of hadoop version 1 and
mapreduce that the only kind of
processing you could do is mapreduce and
map reduce programming model although it
is good it is oldest it has matured over
a period of time but then it is very
rigid you will have to go for mapping
and reducing approach and that was the
only kind of processing which could be
done in hadoop version 1. so when it
comes to doing a real time analysis or
doing ad hoc query or doing a graph
based processing or massive parallel
processing there were limitations
because that could not be done in hadoop
version 1 which was having mapreduce
version 1 as the processing component
now that brings us to the need for yarn
so yarn it stands for yet another
resource negotiator so as i mentioned
before yarn in hadoop version 1 well you
could have applications which could be
written in different programming
languages but then the only kind of
processing which was possible was
mapreduce we had the storage layer we
had the processing but then kind of
limited processing which could be done
now this was one thing which brought in
a thought that why shouldn't we have a
processing layer which can handle
different kind of workloads as i
mentioned might be graph processing
might be real time processing might be
massive parallel processing or any other
kind of processing which would be a
requirement of an organization now
designed to run mapreduce jobs only and
having issues
in scalability resource utilization job
tracking etc that led to the need of
something what we call as yarn now from
hadoop version 2 onwards we have the two
main layers have changed a little bit
you have the storage layer which is
intact that is your hdfs and then you
have the processing layer which is
called yarn yet another resource
negotiator now we will understand how
yarn works but then yarn is taking care
of your processing layer it does support
mapreduce so mapreduce processing can
still be done but then now you can have
a support to other processing frameworks
yarn can be used to solve the issues
which hadoop version one was posing
something like resource management
something like different kind of
workload processing something like
scalability resource utilization all
that is now taken care by yarn now when
we talk about yarn we can have now a
cluster size of more than 10 000 nodes
and can run more than 100 000 concurrent
tasks that's just to take care of your
scalability when you talk about
compatibility applications which were
developed for hadoop version 1 which
were primarily mapreduce kind of
processing can run on yarn without any
disruption or availability issues when
you talk about resource utilization
there is a mechanism which takes care of
dynamic allocation of cluster resources
and this basically improves the resource
utilization when we talk about
multi-tenancy so basically now the
cluster can handle different kind of
workloads so you can use open source and
proprietary data access engines you can
perform real time analysis you can be
doing graph processing you can be doing
ad hoc querying and this can be
supported for multiple workloads which
can run in parallel so this is what yarn
offers so what is yarn as i mentioned
yarn stands for yet another resource
negotiator so it is the cluster resource
management layer for your apache hadoop
ecosystem which takes care of scheduling
jobs and assigning resources now just
imagine when you would want to run a
particular application you would
basically be telling the cluster that i
would want resources to run my
applications that application might be a
mapreduce application that might be a
hive query which is triggering a
mapreduce that might be a big script
which is triggering a mapreduce that
could be hive with days as an execution
engine that could be a spark application
that could be a graph processing
application in any of these cases you
would still you as in in sense client or
basically an api or the application
would be requesting for resources yan
would take care of that so yarn would
provide the desired resources now when
we talk about resources we are mainly
talking about the network related
resources we are talking about the cpu
cores or as in terms of yarn we say
virtual cpu cores we would talk about
ram that is in gb or mb or in terabytes
which would be offered from multiple
machines and yarn would take care of
this so with yarn you could basically
handle different workloads now these are
some of the workloads which are showing
up here you have the traditional
mapreduce which is
mainly batch oriented you could have an
interactive execution engine something
as space you could have hbase which is a
column oriented or a four dimensional
database and that would be not only
storing data on sdfs but would also need
some kind of processing you could have
streaming functionalities which would be
from storm or kafka or spark you could
have graph processing you could have
in-memory processing such as spark and
its components and you could have many
others so these are different frameworks
which could now run and which can run on
top of yarn so how does the aunt do that
now when we talk about
yarn this is how a overall yarn
architecture looks so at one end you
have the client now client could be
basically your edge node where you have
some applications which are running it
could be an api which would want to
interact with your cluster it could be a
user triggered application which wants
to run some jobs which are doing some
processing so this client would submit a
job request now what is the resource
manager doing resource manager is the
master of your processing layer in
hadoop version 1 we basically had job
tracker and then we had task trackers
which were running on individual nodes
so your task trackers were sending your
heartbeats to the job tracker your task
trackers were sending it their resource
information
and job tracker was the one which was
tracking the resources and it was doing
the job scheduling and that's how as i
mentioned earlier job tracker was
overburdened so job tracker is now
replaced by your resource manager which
is the master for your processing layer
your task trackers are replaced by node
managers which would be then running on
every node and we have a temporary demon
which you see here in blue and that's
your app master so this is what we
mention when we say yet another resource
negotiator so app master would be
existing in a hadoop version 2. now when
we talk about your resource manager
resource manager is the master for
processing layer so it would already be
receiving heartbeats and you can say
resource information from multiple node
managers which would be running on one
or multiple machines and these node
managers are not only updating their
status but they are also giving an
information of the amount of resources
they have now when we talk about
resources we should understand that if i
am talking about this node manager then
this has been allocated some amount of
ram for processing and some amount of
cpu cores and that is just a portion of
what the complete node has
so if my node has say imagine my node
has around 100 gb ram and i have saved
60 cores all of that cannot be allocated
to node manager so node manager is just
one of the components of hadoop
ecosystem it is the slave of the
processing layer so we could say keeping
in all the aspects such as different
services which are running might be
cloudera or hortonworks related services
running system processes running on a
particular node some portion of this
would be assigned to node manager for
processing so we could say for example
say 60 gb ram per node and say 40 cpu
cores so this is what is allocated for
the node manager on every machine
similarly we would have here similarly
we would have here so node manager is
constantly giving an update to resource
manager about the resources what it has
probably there might be some other
applications running and node manager is
already occupied so it gives an update
now we also have a concept of containers
which is basically we will we will talk
about which is about these resources
being broken down into smaller parts so
resource manager is keeping a track of
the resources which every node manager
has and it is also responsible for
taking care of the job request how do
these things happen now as we see here
resource manager at a higher level you
can always say this is the processing
master which does everything but in
reality it is not the resource manager
which is doing it but it has internally
different services or components which
are helping it to do what it is supposed
to do now let's look further now as i
mentioned your resource manager has
these
services or components which basically
helps it to do the things it is
basically a an architecture where
multiple components are working together
to achieve what yarn allows so resource
manager has mainly two components that
is your scheduler and applications
manager and these are at high level four
main components here so we talk about
resource manager which is the processing
master you have node managers which are
the processing slaves which are running
on every nodes you have the concept of
container and you have the concept of
application master how do all these
things work now let's look at yarn
components so resource manager basically
has two main components you can say
which assist resource manager in doing
what it is capable of so you have
scheduler and applications manager now
there is when you talk about resources
there is always a requirement for the
applications which need to run on
cluster of resources so your application
which has to run which was submitted by
client needs resources and these
resources are coming in from multiple
machines wherever the relevant data is
stored and a node manager is running so
we always know that node manager is
co-located with data nodes now what does
the scheduler do so we have different
kind of schedulers here we have
basically a capacity scheduler we have a
fair scheduler or we could have a fifo
scheduler so there are different
schedulers which take care of resource
allocation so your scheduler is
responsible for allocating resources to
various running applications now imagine
a particular environment where you have
different teams or different departments
which are working on the same cluster so
we would call the cluster as a
multi-tenant cluster and on the
multi-tenant cluster you would have
different applications which would want
to run simultaneously accessing the
resources of the cluster how is that
managed so there has to be some
component which has a concept of pooling
or queueing so that different
departments or different users can get
dedicated resources or can share
resources on the cluster so scheduler is
responsible for allocating resources to
various running applications now it does
not perform monitoring or tracking of
the status of applications that's not
the part of scheduler it does not offer
any guarantee about restarting the
failed tasks due to hardware or network
or any other failures scheduler is
mainly responsible for allocating
resources now as i mentioned you could
have different kind of schedulers you
could have a fifo scheduler which was
mainly in older version of hadoop which
stands for first in first out you could
have a fair scheduler which basically
means
multiple applications could be running
in the cluster and they would have a
fair share of the resources you could
have a capacity scheduler which would
basically have dedicated or fixed amount
of resources across the cluster now
whichever scheduler is being used
scheduler is mainly responsible for
allocating resources then it's your
applications manager now this is
responsible for accepting job
submissions now as i said at higher
level we could always say resource
manager state doing everything it is
allocating the resources it is
negotiating the resources it is also
taking care of listening to the clients
and taking care of job submissions but
who is doing it in real it is these
components so you have applications
manager which is responsible for
accepting job submissions it negotiates
the first container for executing the
application specific application master
it provides the service for restarting
the application master now how does this
work how do these things happen in
coordination now as i said your node
manager is the slave process which would
be running on every machine slave is
tracking the resources what it has it is
tracking the processes it is taking care
of running the jobs and basically it is
tracking each container resource
utilization so let's understand what is
this container so normally when you talk
about a application request which comes
from a client so let's say this is my
client which is requesting or which is
coming up with an application which
needs to run on the cluster now this
application could be anything it first
contacts your master that's your
resource manager which is the master for
your processing layer now as i mentioned
and as we already know that your name
node which is the master of your cluster
has the metadata in its ram which is
aware of the data being split into
blocks the blocks when stored on
multiple machines and other information
so obviously there was a interaction
with the master which has given this
information of the relevant nodes where
the data exists now for the processing
need your client basically the
application which needs to run on the
cluster so your resource manager which
basically has the scheduler which takes
care of allocating resources and
resource manager has mainly these two
components which are helping it to do
its work now for a particular
application which might be needing data
from multiple machines now we know that
we would have multiple machines where we
would have node manager running we would
have a data node running and data nodes
are responsible for storing the data on
disk so your resource manager has to
negotiate the resources now when i say
negotiating the resources it could
basically ask each of these node
managers for some amount of resources
for example it would be saying can i
have one gb of ram and one cpi or from
you because there is some data residing
on your machine and that needs to be
processed as part of my
[Music]
and this is again because some relevant
data is stored and this request which
resource manager makes of holding the
so resource manager now we know it is
not actually the resource manager but it
is the application manager which is
negotiating the resources so it
negotiates the resources which
are called container so this request of
holding resource can be considered as a
container so basically a container can
be of different sizes we will talk about
that so resource manager negotiates the
resources with node manager now node
manager which is already giving an
update of the resources it has what
amount of resources it holds how much
busy it is can basically approve or deny
this request so node manager would
basically approve in saying yes i could
hold these resources i could give you
this container of this particular size
now once the container has been approved
or allocated or you can say granted by
your node manager resource manager now
knows that resources to process the
application are available and guaranteed
by the node manager so resource manager
starts a temporary demon called
appmaster so this is a piece of code
which would also be running in one of
the containers it would be running in
one of the containers which would then
take care of execution of tasks in other
containers so your application master is
per application so if i would have 10
different applications coming in from
the client then we would have 10 app
masters one app master being responsible
for per application now what does this
app master do it basically is a piece of
code which is responsible for execution
of the application so your app master
would run in one of the containers and
then it would use the other containers
which node manager is guaranteed that it
will give when the request application
request comes to it and using these
containers the app master will run the
processing tasks within these designated
resources so it is mainly the
responsibility of application master to
get the execution done and then
communicate it to the master so resource
manager is tracking the resources it is
negotiating the resources and once the
resources have been negotiated it
basically gives the control to
application master application master is
then running within one of the
containers on one of the nodes and using
the other containers to take care of
execution this is how it looks so
basically container as i said is a
collection of resources like cpu memory
your disk which would be used or which
already has the data and network so your
node manager is basically looking into
the request from application master and
it basically is granting this request or
basically is allocating these containers
now again we could have different sizing
of the containers let's take an example
here so as i mentioned from the total
resources which are available for a
particular node some portion of
resources are allocated to the node
manager so let's imagine this is my node
where node manager as a processing slave
is running so from the total resources
which the node has some portion of ram
and cpu cores is basically allocated to
the node manager so i could say out of
total 100 gb ram we can say around
60 cores which the particular node has
so this is my ram which the node has and
these are the cpu cores which the node
has some portion of it right so we can
say might be
70 or 60 percent of the total resources
so we could say around 60 gb ram and
then we could say around 40 v cores have
been allocated to node manager so there
are these settings which are given in
the yarn hyphen site file now apart from
this allocation that is 60 gb ram and
40v cores we also have some properties
which say what will be the container
sizes so for example we could have a
small container setting which could say
my every container could have 2 gb ram
and say one virtual cpu core so this is
my smallest container so based on the
total resources you could calculate how
many such small containers could be
running so if i say 2gb ram then i could
have around 30 containers but then i am
talking about one virtual cpu core so
totally i could have around 30
small containers which could be running
in parallel on a particular node and as
of that calculation you would say 10 cpu
cores are not being utilized you could
have a bigger container size which could
say i would go for 2 cpu cores and 3gb
ram
so 3gb ram and 2 cpu cores so that would
give me around 20 containers of bigger
size so this is the container sizing
which is again defined in the yarn
hyphen side file so what we know is on a
particular node which has this kind of
allocation either we could have 30 small
containers running or we could have 20
big containers running and same would
apply to multiple nodes so node manager
based on the request from application
master can allocate these containers now
remember it is within this one of these
containers you would have an application
master running and other containers
could be used for your processing
requirement application master which is
per application it is the one which uses
these resources it basically manages or
uses these resources for individual
application so remember if we have 10
applications running on yarn then it
would be 10 application masters one
responsible for each application your
application master is the one which also
interacts with the scheduler to
basically know how much amount of
resources could be allocated for one
application and your application master
is the one which uses these resources
but it can never negotiate for more
resources to node manager application
master cannot do that application master
has to always go back to resource
manager if it needs more resources so it
is always the resource manager an
internally resource manager component
that is application manager which
negotiates the resources at any point of
time due to some node failures or due to
any other requirements if application
master
needs
more resources on one or multiple nodes
it will always be contacting the
resource manager internally the
applications manager for more containers
now this is how it looks so your client
submits the job request to resource
manager now we know that resource
manager internally has scheduler an
applications manager node managers which
are running on multiple machines are the
ones which are tracking their resources
giving this information to the source
manager so that resource manager or i
would say its component applications
manager could request resources from
multiple node managers when i say
request resources it is these containers
so your resource manager basically will
request for the resources on one or
multiple nodes node manager is the one
which approves these containers and once
the container has been approved your
resource manager triggers a piece of
code that is application master which
obviously needs some resources so it
would run in one of the containers and
will use other containers to do the
execution so your client submits an
application to resource manager resource
manager allocates a container or i would
say this is at a high level right
resource manager is negotiating the
resources and internally who is
negotiating the resources it is your
applications manager who is granting
this request it is node manager and
that's how we can say resource manager
locates a container application master
basically contacts the related node
manager because it needs to use the
containers node manager is the one which
launches the container or basically
gives those resources within which an
application can run an application
master itself will then accommodate
itself in one of the containers and then
use other containers for the processing
and it is within these containers the
actual execution happens now that could
be a map task that could be a reduced
task that could be a spark executor
taking care of spark tasks and many
other processing
so before we look into the demo on how
yarn works i would suggest looking into
one of the blogs from cloudera so you
can just look for yarn untangling and
this is really a good blog which
basically talks about the overall
functionality which i explained just now
so as we mentioned here so you basically
have the master process you have the
worker process which basically takes
care of your processing your resource
manager being the master and node
manager being the slave this also talks
about the resources which each node
manager has
it talks about the yarn configuration
file where you give all these properties
it basically shows you node manager
which reports the amount of resources it
has to resource manager now remember if
worker node shows 18 to 8 cpu cores and
128 gb ram and if your node manager says
64 v cores and ram 128 gb then that's
not the total capacity of your node it
is some portion of your node which is
allocated to node manager now once your
node manager reports that your resource
manager is requesting for containers
based on the application what is a
container it is basically a logical name
given to a combination of vcore and
ram
it is within this container where you
would have basically the process running
so once your application starts and once
node manager is guaranteed these
containers your application or your
resource manager has basically already
started an application master within the
container and what does that application
master do it uses the other containers
where the tasks would run so this is a
very good blog which you can refer to
and this also talks about mapreduce if
you have already followed the mapreduce
tutorials in past then you would know
about the different kind of tasks that
is map and reduce and these map and
reduce tasks could be running within the
container in one or multiple as i said
it could be map task it could be reduced
task it could be a spark based task
which would be running within the
container now once the task finishes
basically that resources can be freed up
so the container is released and the
resources are given back to yarn so that
it can take care of further processing
if you'll further look in this blog you
can also look into the part two of it
where you talk mainly about
configuration settings you can always
look into this which talks about why and
how much resources are allocated to the
node manager it basically talks about
your operating system overhead it talks
about other services it talks about
clouded our hotend works related
services running and other processes
which might be running and based on that
some portion of ram and cpu cores would
be allocated to node manager so that's
how it would be done in the yarn hyphen
site file and this basically shows you
what is the total amount of memory and
cpu cores which is allocated to node
manager then within every machine where
you have a node manager running on every
machine in the yarn hyphen side file you
would have such properties which would
say what is the minimum container size
what is the maximum container size in
terms of ram what is the minimum for cpu
cores what is the maximum for cpu cores
and what is the incremental size in
where ram and cpu cores can increment so
these are some of the properties which
define how containers are allocated for
your application request so have a look
at this and this could be a good
information which talks about different
properties now you can look further
which talks about scheduling if you look
in this particular blog which also talks
about scheduling where it talks about
scheduling in yarn which talks about
fair scheduler or you basically having
different cues in which allocations can
be done you also have different ways in
which queues can be managed and
different schedulers can be used so you
can always look at this series of blog
you can also be checking for yarn
schedulers and then search for a
hadoop
definitive
guide and that could give you some
information on how it looks when you
look for hadoop definitive guide so if
you look into this book which talks
about the different resources as i
mentioned so you could have a fifo
scheduler that is first in first out
which basically means if a long
long-running application is submitted to
the cluster all other small running
applications will have to wait there is
no other way but that would not be a
preferred option if you look in fifo
scheduler if you look for capacity
scheduler it basically means that you
could have different queues created and
those queues would have resources
allocated so then you could have a
production queue where production jobs
are running in a particular queue which
has fixed amount of resources allocated
you could have a development queue where
development jobs are running and both of
them are running in parallel you could
then also look into fair scheduler which
basically means again multiple
applications could be running on the
cluster however they would have a fair
share so when i say fair share in brief
what it means is
if i had given 50 percent of resources
to a queue for production and 50 percent
of resources for a queue of development
and if both of them are running in
parallel then they would have access to
50 percent of cluster resources however
if one of the queue is unutilized then
second queue can utilize all cluster
resources so look into the fair
scheduling part it also shows you about
how allocations can be given and you can
learn more about schedulers and how
queues can be used for managing multiple
applications now we will spend some time
in looking into few ways or few quick
ways in interacting with yarn in the
form of a demo to understand and learn
on how yarn works we can look into a
particular cluster now here we have a
designated cluster which can be used you
could be using the similar kind of
commands on your apache based cluster or
a cloudera quick start vm if you already
have or if you have a cloud error or a
hortonworks cluster running there are
different ways in which we can interact
with yarn and we can look at the
information one is basically looking
into the admin console so if i would
look into cloudera manager which is
basically an admin console for a
cloudera's distribution of hadoop
similarly you could have a hortonworks
cluster than access to the admin console
so if you have even read access for your
cluster and if you have the admin
console then you can search for yarn as
a service which is running you can click
on yarn as a service and that gives you
different tabs so you have the instances
which tells basically what are the
different roles for your yarn service
running so we have here multiple node
managers now some of them show in stop
status but that's nothing to worry so we
have three and six node managers we have
resource manager which is one but then
that can also be in a high availability
where you can have active and standby
you also have a job history server which
would show you the applications once
they have completed now you can look at
the yarn configurations and as i was
explaining you can always look for the
properties which are related to the
allocation so you can here search for
course and that should show you the
properties which talk about the
allocations so here if we see we can be
looking for
yarn app mapreduce application master
resource cpu course what is the cpu
course allocated for map reduce map task
reduce task you can be looking at yarn
node manager resource cpu course which
basically says every node manager on
every node would be allocated with six
cpu cores and the container sizing is
with minimum allocation of one cpu core
and the maximum could be two cpu cores
similarly you could also be searching
for memory allocation and here you could
then scroll down to see what kind of
memory allocation has been done for the
node manager so if we look further it
should give me information of node
manager which basically says here that
the container minimum allocation is 2 gb
the maximum is 3 gb and we can look at
node manager which has been given 25 gb
per node so it's a combination of this
memory and cpu cores which is the total
amount of resources which have been
allocated to every node manager now we
can always look into applications tab
that would show us different
applications which are submitted on yarn
for example right now we see there is a
spark application running which is
basically a user who is using spark
shell which has triggered a application
on spark and that is running on yarn you
can look at different applications
workload information you can always do a
search based on the number of days how
many applications have run and so on you
can always go to the web ui and you can
be searching for the resource manager
web ui and if you have access to that it
will give you overall information of
your cluster so this basically says that
here we have 100 gb memory allocated so
that could be say 25 gb per node and if
we have four node managers running and
we have 24 cores which is six cores per
node if we look further here into nodes
i could get more information so this
tells me that i have four node managers
running and node managers basically have
25 gb memory allocated per node and 6
scores out of which some portion is
being utilized we can always look at the
scheduler here which can give us
information what kind of scheduler has
been allocated so we basically see that
there is just a root q and within root
you have default queue and you have
basically user skew based on different
users we can always scroll here and that
can give us information if it is a fair
share so here we see that my root dot
default has 50 of resources and the
other queue also has 50 percent of
resources which also gives me an idea
that a fair scheduler is being used we
can always confirm that if we are using
a fair scheduler or a capacity scheduler
which takes care of a location so search
for scheduler
and that should give you some
understanding of what kind of scheduler
is being used and what are the
allocations given for that particular
scheduler so here we have fair scheduler
it shows me you have under root you have
the root q which has been given hundred
percent capacity and then you have
within that default which also takes
hundred percent so this is how you can
understand about yarn by looking into
the yarn web ui you can be looking into
the configurations you can look at
applications you can always look at
different actions now since we do not
have admin access the only information
we have is to download the client
configuration we can always look at the
history server which can give us
information of all the applications
which have successfully completed now
this is from your yarn ui what i can
also do is i can be going into hue which
is the web interface and your web
interface also basically allows you to
look into the jobs so you can click on
hue web ui and if you have access to
that it should show up or you should
have a way to get to your hue which is a
graphical user interface mainly comes
with your cloud error you can also
configure that with apache hortonworks
has a different way of giving you the
web ui access you can click and get into
hue and that is also one way where you
can look at yarn you can look at the
jobs which are running if there are some
issues with it and these these are your
web interfaces so either you look from
yarn web ui or here in hue you have
something called as job browser which
can also give you information of your
different applications which might have
run so here i can just remove this one
which would basically give me a list of
all the different kind of jobs or
workflows which were run so either it
was a spark based application or it was
a map reduce or it was coming from hive
so here i have list of all the
applications and it says this was a
mapreduce this was a spark something was
killed something was successful and this
was basically a probably a hive query
which triggered a mapreduce job you can
click on the application and that tells
you how many tasks were run for it so
there was a map task which ran for it
you can get into the metadata
information which you can obviously you
can also look from the yarn ui to look
into your applications which can give
you a detailed information of if it was
a map reduce how many map and reduce
tasks were run what were the different
counters if it was a spark application
it can let you follow through spark
history server or job history server so
you can always use the web ui to look
into the jobs you can be finding in lot
of useful information here you can also
be looking at how many resources were
used and what happened to the job was it
successful did it fail and what was the
job status now apart from
web ui which always you might not have
access to so in a particular cluster in
a production cluster there might be
restrictions and the organization might
not have
access given to all the users to
graphical user interface like you or
might be you would not have access to
the cloud era manager or admin console
because probably organization is
managing multiple clusters using this
admin console so the one way which you
would have access is your web console or
basically your edge node or client
machine from where you can connect to
the cluster and then you can be working
so let's log in here and now here we can
give different commands so this is the
command line from where you can have
access to different details you can
always check by just typing in map red
which gives you different options where
you can look at the map reduce related
jobs you can look at different queues if
there are queues configured you can look
at the history server or you can also be
doing some admin stuff provided you have
access so for example if i just say map
red and q here this basically gives me
an option says what would you want to do
would you want to list all the queues do
you want information on a particular
queue so let's try a list
and that should give you different
queues which were being used now here we
know that per user a queue dynamically
gets created which is under root dot
users and that gives me what is the
status of the queue what is the capacity
has there been any kind of maximum
capacity or capping done so we get to
see a huge list of queues which
dynamically get configured in this
environment and then you also look at
your root dot default i could have also
picked up one particular queue and i
could have said show me the jobs so i
could do that now here we can
also give a yarn command so let me just
clear the screen and i will say yarn and
that shows me different options so apart
from your web interface
something like web ui apart from your
yarn's web ui you could also be looking
for information using yarn commands here
so these are some list of commands which
we can check now you can just type in
yarn and version if you would want to
see the version which basically gives
you information of what is the hadoop
version being used and what is the
vendor-specific distribution version so
here we see we are working on cloudera's
distribution 5.14 which is internally
using hadoop 2.6 now similarly you can
be doing a yarn application list so if
you give this that could be an
exhaustive list of all the applications
which are running or applications which
have completed so here we don't see any
applications because right now probably
there are no applications which are
running it also shows you you could be
pulling out different status such as
submitted accepted or running now you
could also say i would want to see the
services that have finished running so i
could say yarn application list and app
states as finished so here we could be
using our command so i could say yarn
application
list
and then i would want to see the app
states which gives me the applications
which have finished and we would want to
list all the applications which finished
now there that might be applications
which succeeded right and there is a
huge list of application which is coming
in from the history server which is
basically showing you the huge list of
applications which have completed so
this is one way and then you could also
be searching for one particular
application if you would want to search
a particular application if you have the
application id you could always be doing
a grip that's a simple way i could say
basically let's pick up this one and if
i would want to search for this if i
would want more details on this i could
obviously do that
by calling in my previous command
and you could do a grip if that's what
you want to do and if you would want to
search is there any application which is
in the list of my applications that
shows my application i could pull out
more information about my application so
i could look at the log files for a
particular application by giving the
application id so i could say yarn logs
now that's an option and every time
anytime you have a doubt just hit enter
it will always give you options what you
need to give with a particular command
so i can say yarn logs application
id now we copied an application id and
we could just give it here we could give
other options like app owner or if you
would want to get into the container
details or if you would want to check on
a particular node now here i am giving
yarn logs and then i am pointing it to
an application id and it says the log
aggregation has not completed might be
this was might be this was an
application which was triggered based on
a particular interactive shell or based
on a particular query so there is no log
existing for this particular application
you can always look at the status of an
application you can kill an application
so here you can be saying yarn yarn
application and then what would you want
to do with an application hit enter it
shows you the different options so we
just tried app states you could always
look at the last one which says status
and then for my status i could be giving
my application id so that tells me what
is the status of this application it
connects to the resource manager it
tells me what's the application id what
kind of application it was who ran it
which was the queue where the job was
running what was the start and end time
what is the progress the status of it if
it is finished or if it has succeeded
and then it basically gives me also an
information of where the application
master was running it gives me the
information where you can find this job
details in history server if you are
interested in looking into it also gives
you a aggregate resource allocation
which tells how much gb memory and how
many c core seconds it used so this is
basically looking out at the application
details now i could kill an application
if the application was already running i
could always do a yarn application
minus skill and then i could be giving
my application now i could try killing
this however it would say the
application is already finished if i had
an application running and if my
application was already given an
application id by resource manager i
could just kill it i can also say yarn
node list which should give me a list of
the node managers now this is what we
were looking from the yarn web ui and we
were pulling out the information so we
can get this and kind of information
from your command line always remember
and always try to be well accustomed
with the command line so you can do
various things from the command line and
then obviously you have the web uis
which can help you with a graphical
interface easily able to access things
now you could be also starting the
resource manager which we would not be
doing here because we are already
running in a cluster so you could give a
yarn resource manager you could get the
logs of resource manager if you would
want by giving yarn demon so we can try
that so you can say yarn and then demon
so it says it does not find the demon so
you can give something like this get
level and here i will have to give the
node and the ip address where you want
to check the logs of resource manager so
you could be giving this for which we
will have to then get into cloud error
manager to look into the nodes and the
ip address you could be giving a command
something like this which basically
gives you the level of the log which you
have and i got this resource manager
address from the web ui now i can be
giving in this command to look into the
demand log and it basically says you
would want to look at the resource
manager related log and you have the log
4j which is being used for logging the
kind of level which has been set as info
which can again be changed in the way
you're logging the information now you
can try any other commands also from
yarn for example looking at the yarn rm
admin so you can always do a yarn rm
admin and this basically gives you a lot
of other informations like refreshing
the cues or refreshing the nodes or
basically looking at the admin acls or
getting groups so you could always get
group names for a particular user now we
could search for a particular user such
as yarn or hdfs itself so i could just
say here i would want get
groups and then i could be searching for
say username hdfs so that tells me sdfs
belongs to a hadoop group similarly you
could search for say map red or you
could search for yarn so these are
service related users which
automatically get created and you can
pull out information related to these
you can always do a refresh nodes kind
of command and that is mainly done
internally this can be useful when
you're doing commissioning
decommissioning but then in case of
cloudera or hortonworks kind of cluster
you would not be manually giving this
command because if you are doing a
commissioning decommissioning from an
admin console and if you are an
administrator then you could just
restart the services which are affected
and that will take care of this but if
you were working in an apache cluster
and if you were doing commissioning
decommissioning then you would be using
in two commands refresh nodes and
basically that's for refreshing the
nodes which should not be used for
processing and similarly you could have
a command refresh notes which comes with
sdfs so these are different options
which you can use with your yarn on the
command line you could also be using
curl commands to get more information
about your cluster by giving curl minus
x and then basically pointing out to
your resource manager web ui address now
here i would like to print out the
cluster related metrics and i could just
simply do this which basically gives me
a high level information of how many
applications were submitted how many are
pending what is the reserved resources
what is the available amount of memory
or cpu cores and all the information
similarly you can be using the same curl
commands to get more information like
scheduler information so you would just
replace the metrics with scheduler and
you could get the information of the
different queues now that's a huge list
we can cancel this and that would give
me the list of all the queues which are
allocated and what are the resources
allocated for each queue you could also
get cluster information on application
ids and status running of applications
running in yarn so you would have to
replace the last bit of it and you would
say i would want to look at the
applications and that gives me a huge
list of applications then you can do it
good grammar and spelling are important
but if you want to write essays that
inspire similarly
in
is
i have
now once
and the other
similarly
[Music]
is
and then basically what i can be doing
is i can be pointing it to a particular
input path
and then i can have
[Music]
application
foreign
you can click on this particular
application which basically gives you
information of your map and reduce tasks
you can look at different counters for
your application right you can always
look at map specific tasks you can
always look into one particular task
what it did on which node it was running
or you can be looking at the complete
application log so you can always click
on the logs and here you have click here
for full log which gives you the
information and you can always look for
your application which can give you
information of app master being launched
or you could have
search for the word container so you
could see a job which needs one or
multiple containers and then you could
say container is being requested then
you could see container is being
allocated then you can see what is the
container size and then basically your
task moves from initializing to running
in the container and finally you can
even search for release which will tell
you that the container was released so
you can always look into the log for
more information so this is how you can
interact with yarn this is how you can
interact with your command line to look
for more information or using your yarn
web ui my name is richard kirschner i am
with the simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead today we're
going to dive in on scoop one of the
many features of the hadoop ecosystem
for the hadoop file system what's in it
for you today we're going to cover the
need for scoop what is scoop scoop
features scoop architecture scoop import
scoop export scoop processing and then
finally we'll have a little hands-on
demo on scoop so you can see what it
looks like so where does the need for
scoop come in in our big data hadoop
file system processing huge volumes of
data requires loading data from diverse
sources into hadoop cluster you can see
here we have our data processing and
this process of loading data from the
heterogeneous sources comes with a set
of challenges so what are the challenges
maintaining data consistency ensuring
efficient utilization of resources
especially when you're talking about big
data we can certainly use up the
resources when importing terabytes and
petabytes of data over the course of
time loading bulk data to hadoop was not
possible it's one of the big challenges
that came up when they first had the
hadoop file system going and loading
data using script was very slow in other
words you'd write a script in whatever
language you're in and then it would
very slowly load each piece and parse it
in so the solution scoop scooped helped
in overcoming all the challenges to
traditional approach and could lead bulk
data from rdbms to hadoop very easily so
thank your enterprise server you want to
take the from mysql or your sql and you
want to bring that data into your hadoop
warehouse your data filing system and
that's where scoop comes in so what
exactly is scoop scoop is a tool used to
transfer bulk of data between hadoop and
external data stores such as relational
databases and my sql server or the
microsoft sql server or my sql server so
scoop equals sql plus hadoop and you can
see here we have our rdbms all the data
we have stored on there and then your
scoop is the middle ground and brings
the import into the hadoop file system
it also is one of the features that goes
out and grabs the data from hadoop and
exports it back out into an rdbms let's
take a look at scoop features sku
features has parallel import and export
it has import results of sql query
connectors for all major rdbms databases
kerberos security integration provides
full and incremental load so we look at
parallel import and export scoop uses
yarn yet another resource negotiator
framework to import and export data this
provides fault tolerance on a top of
parallelism scoop allows us to import
the result returned from an sql carry
into the hadoop file system or the hdfs
and you can see here where the import
results of sql query come in scoop
provides connectors for multiple
relational database management system
rdbms's databases such as mysql and
microsoft sql server and has connectors
for all major rdbms databases scoop
supports kerberos computer network
authentication protocol that allows
nodes communicating over a non-secure
network to prove their identity to one
another in a secure manner scoop can
load the whole table or parts of the
table by a single command hence it
supports full and incremental load let's
dig a little deeper into the scoop
architecture we have our client in this
case a hooded wizard behind his laptop
you never know who's going to be
accessing the hadoop cluster and the
client comes in and sends their command
which goes into scoop the client submits
the import export command to import or
export data data from different
databases is fetched by scoop and so we
have
enterprise data warehouse document based
systems you have connect connector for
your data warehouse a connector for
document based systems which reaches out
to those two entities and we have our
connector for the rdbms so connectors
help in working with a range of popular
databases multiple mappers perform map
tasks to load the data onto hdfs a
hadoop file system and you can see here
we have the map task if you remember
from hadoop hadoop is based on map
reduce because we're not reducing the
data we're just mapping it over it only
accesses the mappers and it opens up
multiple mappers to do parallel
processing and you can see here the hdfs
hbase hive is where the target is for
this particular one similarly multiple
map tests will export the data from hdfs
onto rdbms using scoop export command so
just like you can import it you can now
export it using the multiple map
routines scoop import so here we have
our dbms data store and we have the
folders on there so maybe it's your
company's database maybe it's an archive
at google with all the searches going on
whatever it is usually you think with
scoop you think sql you think mysql
server or microsoft sql server that kind
of setup
so it gathers the metadata and you see
the scoop import so introspect database
together metadata primary key
information and then it submits so you
can see submits map only job remember we
talked about mapreduce it only needs the
map side of it because we're not
reducing the data we're just mapping it
over scoop divides the input data set
into splits and uses individual map
tests to push the splits into hdfs so
right into the hadoop file system and
you can see down on the right is kind of
a small depiction of a hadoop cluster
and then you have scoop export so we're
going to go the other direction and with
the other direction you have your hadoop
file system storage which is your hadoop
cluster you have your scoop job and each
one of those clusters then gets a map
mapper comes out to each one of the
computers that has data on it
so the first step is you've got to
gather the metadata so step one you
gather the metadata step two submits map
only job introspect database together
metadata primary key information scoop
divides the input data set into splits
and uses individual map tests to push
the splits to rdbms scoop will export
hadoop files back to rdms tables you can
think of this in a number of different
manners one of them would be if you're
restoring a backup from the hadoop file
system into your enterprise machines
there's certainly many others as far as
exploring data and data science so as we
dig a little deeper into scoop input we
have our connect our jdbc and our url so
specified the jdbc connect string
connecting manager we specify the
connection manager class to use you can
see here driver with the class name
manually specify the jdbc driver class
to use hadoop map reduce home directory
override hadoop mapped home username set
authentication username and of course
help print usage instructions and with
the export you'll see that we can
specify the jdbc connect string specify
the connection manager class to use
manually specified jdbc driver class to
use you do have to let it know to
override the hadoop map reduce home and
that's true on both of these and set
authentication username and finally you
can print out all your help setup so you
can see the format for scoop is pretty
straightforward both import and export
so let's uh continue on our path and
look at scoop processing and what the
computer goes through for that and we
talk about scoop processing first scoop
runs in the hadoop cluster it imports
data from the rdbms the nosql database
to the hadoop file system so remember we
might not be importing the data from a
rdbms it might actually be coming from
an osql and there's many out there it
uses mappers to slice the incoming data
into multiple formats and load the data
into hdfs it exports data back into an
rdbms while making sure that the schema
of the data in the database is
maintained so now that we've looked at
the basic commands in our scoop in the
scoop processing or at least the basics
as far as theory is concerned let's just
jump in and take a look at a demo on
scoop
for this demo i'm going to use our
cloudera quick start if you've been
watching our other demos we've done
you'll see that we've been using that
pretty consistently certainly this will
work in any of your
your horton sandbox which is also a
single node testing machine cloudera is
one of um there's a docker version
instead of virtualbox and you can also
set up your own hadoop cluster plan a
little extra time if you're not an admin
it's actually a pretty
significant endeavor for an admin if
you've been admitting linux machines for
a very long time and you know a lot of
the commands i find for most admins it
takes them about two to four hours the
first time they go in and create a
virtual machine and set up their own
hadoop in this case though when you're
just learning and getting set up best to
start with cloudera cloudera also
includes an installed version of mysql
that way you don't have to install the
the sql version for importing data from
into once you're in the cloudera quick
start you'll see it opens a nice centos
linux
interface and it has the desktop setup
on there this is really nice for
learning so you're not just looking at
command lines and from in here it should
open up by default to hue if not you can
click on hue here's a kind of a fun
little web-based interface under hue i
can go under query i can pick an editor
and we'll go right down to scoop so now
i'm just going to load the scoop editor
inner hue now i'm going to switch over
and do this all in command line i just
want to show that you can actually do
this in a hue through the web-based
interface the reason i like to do the
command line is specifically on my
computer it runs much quicker or if i do
the command line here and i run it it
tends to have an extra lag or an added
layer in it so for this we're going to
go ahead and open our command line the
second reason i do this is we're going
to need to go ahead and edit our
mysql so we have something to scoop in
otherwise i don't have anything going in
there and of course we zoom in we'll
zoom in this and increase the size of
our screen
so for this demo our hands-on i'm going
to use oracle virtualbox manager and the
cloudera quick start if you're not
familiar with this we do have another
tutorial we put out and you can send a
note in the youtube video below and let
our team know and they'll send you a
link or come visit
www.simplylearn.com now this creates a
linux box on my windows computer so
we're going to be in linux and it'll be
the cloudera version
with scoop and will also be using mysql
my sql server once inside the cloudera
virtualbox uh we'll go under the hue
editor now we're going to do everything
in terminal window but i just want you
to be aware that under the hue editor
you can go under query editor and you'll
see as we come down here here's our
scoop on this so you can run your scoop
from in here now before we do this we
have to do a little exploration in my
sql and my sql server that way we know
what data is coming in so let me go
ahead and open up a terminal window in
cloudera you have a terminal window at
the top here that you can just click on
it open it up and let me just go ahead
and zoom in on here go view and zoom in
now to get into my sql server you simply
type in mysql and this part will depend
on your setup now the cloudera
quickstart comes up that the username is
root and the password is cloudera kind
of a strange quirk is that you can put a
space between the minus u and the root
but not between the minus p and the
cloudera usually you'd put in a minus
capital p and then it prompts you for
your password on here for this demo i
don't worry too much about you knowing
the password on that so we'll just go
right into my sql server since this is
the standard password for this quick
start and you can see we're now into
mysql and we're going to do just a
couple of quick
commands in here there's show databases
and you follow by the semicolon that's
standard in most of these shell commands
so it knows it's the end of your shell
command and you'll see in here in the
quick start cloudera quickstart the
mysql comes with a standard set of
databases these are just
some of these have to do like with the
uzi which is the uzi part of hadoop
where others of these like customers and
employees and stuff like that those are
just for demo purposes they come as a
standard setup in there so that people
going in for the first time have a
database to play with which is really
good for us so we don't have to recreate
those databases and you will see in the
list here we have a retail underscore db
and then we can simply do uh use
retail underscore db this will set that
as a default in mysql and then we want
to go ahead and show the tables and if
we show the tables you can see under the
database the retail db database we have
categories customers departments order
items orders products so there's a
number of tables in here and we're going
to go ahead and just use a standard
sql command and if you did our hive
language you'll note remember it's the
same for hql also on this we're just
going to select star everything from
departments
so there's our departments table and
we're going to list everything on the
department's table and you'll see we
have about six lines in here and it has
a department id and a department name uh
two for fitness three for footwear so on
and so forth now at this point i can
just go ahead and exit but it's kind of
nice to have this data up here so we can
look at it and flip back and forth
between the screens so i'm going to open
up another terminal window and we'll go
ahead and zoom in on this also and it
isn't too important for this particular
setup but it's always kind of fine fun
to know what your setup you're working
with what is your host name and so we'll
go ahead and just type that in this is a
linux command and it's a
hostname minus f and you see we're on
quick start cloudera no surprise there
now this next command is going to be a
little bit longer because we're going to
be doing our first scoop command and i'm
going to do two of them we're going to
list databases and list tables it's
going to take just a moment to get
through this
because there's a bunch of stuff going
on here so we have scoop we have list
databases we have connect and under the
connect command we need to let it know
how we're connecting we're going to use
the jdbc this is a very standard one uh
jdbc mysql so you'll see that if you're
doing an sql database that's how you
started off with and then the next part
this is where you have to go look it up
it's however it was created so if your
admin created a mysql server with a
certain setup that's what you have to go
by and you'll see that usually they list
this as localhost so you'll see
something like localhost sometimes
there's a lot of different formats but
the most common is either localhost or
the actual connection so in this case we
want to go ahead and do quickstart
3306. and so
use the name of the local host database
and how it's hosted on here and when you
set up the quick start for um for hadoop
under cloudera it's port 3306 is where
that's coming in so that's where all
that's coming from uh and so there's our
path for that and then we have to put in
our password we typically type password
if you look it up password on the
cloudera quickstart is cloudera and we
have to also let it know the username
and again if you're doing this you'd
probably put in a minus capital you can
actually just do it for a prompt
for the password so if you leave that
out it'll prompt you uh but for this
doesn't really matter i don't care if
you see my password it's the default one
for cloudera quickstart and then the
username on here is simply root and then
we're going to put our semicolon at the
end and so we have here our full setup
and we go ahead and list the databases
and you'll see you might get some
warnings on here i haven't run the
updates on the quick start i suggest
you're not running the updates either if
you're doing this for the first time
because it'll do some reformatting on
there and it quickly pass up and you can
see here's all of our the tables we went
in there and if we go back to
on the previous window we should see
that these tables match so here we come
in and here we have our databases and
you can see back up here where we had
the cm customers employees and so on so
the databases match and then we want to
go ahead and list the
tables for a specific database so let's
go ahead and do that i'm a very lazy
typist so i'll put the up arrow in and
you can see here scoop list databases
we're just going to go back and change
this from databases to list tables so we
want to list the tables in here same
connection so most the connection is the
same except we need to know which tables
we're listing an interesting fact is you
can create a table without being under a
database so if you left this blank it
will show the open tables that aren't
connected directly to a database or
under a database but what we want to do
is right past this last slash on the
3306 we want to put that retail
underscore db because that's the
database we're going to be working with
and this will go in there and show the
tables listed under that database and
here we go we got categories customers
departments order items and products if
we flip back here real quick there it is
the same thing we had we had categories
customers departments order items and so
on and so let's go ahead and run our
first import command and again i'm that
lazy typer so we're going to do scoop
and instead of list tables we want to go
ahead and import so there's our import
command and so once we have our import
command in there then we need to tell it
exactly what we're going to import so
everything else is the same we're
importing from the retail db so we keep
that and then at the very end we're
going to tag on dash dash table that
tells us we can tell what table we're
importing from and we're going to import
departments
there we go so this is pretty
straightforward because it what's nice
about this is you can see the commands
are the same i got the same connection
um i change it for whatever database i'm
in um then i come in here our password
and the username are going to be the
same that's all under the mysql server
setup and then we let it know what table
we're entering in we run this and this
is going to actually go through the
mapper process in hadoop so this is a
mapping process it takes the data and it
maps it up to different parts in the
setup in hadoop on there and then saves
that data into the hadoop file system
and it does take it a moment to zip
through which i kind of skipped over for
you since it is running a you know it's
designed to run across the cluster not
on a single node so when you're running
on a single node it's going to run slow
even if you dedicate a couple cores to
it i think i put dedicated four cores to
this one uh and so you can see right
down here we get to the end it's now
mapped in that information and then we
can go in here we can go under
can flip back to our
hue and under hue on the top i have
there's databases and the second icon
over is your hadoop file system and we
can go in here and look at the hadoop
file system and you'll see it show up
underneath our documents there it is
departments cloudera departments and you
can see there's always a delay when i'm
working in hue which i don't like
and that's the quick start issue that's
not necessarily running out on a server
when i'm running it on a server you
pretty much have to run through some
kind of server interface i still prefer
the terminal window it still runs a lot
quicker we'll flip back on over here to
the command line and we can do the
hadoop type in the hadoop fs and then
list minus ls and if we run this you'll
see underneath our hadoop file system
there is our departments which has been
added in and we can also do
hadoop
fs and this is kind of interesting for
those who've gone through the hadoop
file system everything you'll you'll
recognize this on here i'm going to list
that the contents of departments and
you'll see underneath departments uh we
have part part
m0001002003 and so this is interesting
because this is how hadoop saves these
files and this is in the file system
this is not in hive so we didn't
directly import this into hive we put
this in the hadoop file system depending
on what you're doing you would then
write the schema for hive to look at the
hadoop file system certainly visit our
hive tutorial for more information on
hive specific so you can see in here are
different files that it forms that are
part of departments and we can do
something like this we can look at the
contents of one of these files fs minus
ls or a number of the files and we'll
simply do the full path which is user
cloudera and then we already know the
next one is departments
and then after departments we're going
to put slash part star so this is going
to say anything that has part in it
so we have part dash m 0 0 0 and so on
uh we can go ahead and cat use that cut
command or that list command to bring
those up and then we can use the cat
command to actually display the contents
and that's a linux command hadoop linux
command the cat catinate not to be
confused with catatonic catastrophic
there's a lot of cat got your tongue and
we see here fitness footwear apparel
that should look really familiar because
that's what we had in our
my sequel server we went in here we did
a select all on here there it is fitness
footwear apparel golf outdoors and fan
shop and then of course it's really
important let's look back on over here
to be able to tell it where to put the
data so we go back to our import command
so here's our scoop import we have our
connect we have the db underneath our
connection our mysql server we have our
password our username the table going
where it's going to i mean the table
where it's coming from and then we can
add a target on here we can put in uh
target
dash directory and you do have to put
the full path that's a hadoop thing it's
a good practice to be in and we're gonna
add it to department we'll just do
department one and so here we now add a
target directory in here and user
cloudera department one and this will
take just a moment before so i'll go
ahead and skip over the process since
it's going to run very slowly it's only
running on like i said a couple cores
and it's also on a single node and now
we can do the uh hadoop let's just do
the up arrow file system list we want
just straight list and when we do the
hadoop file system uh minus ls or list
you'll see that we now have department
one and we can of course do uh list
department one and you can see we have
the files inside department one and they
mirrored what we saw before with the
same files in there and the part mm-00
and so on if we want to look at him it'd
be the same thing we did before with the
cat so except instead of departments
now one of the important things when
you're importing data and it's always a
question to ask is do you filter the
data before it comes in do we want to
filter this data as it comes in so we're
not storing everything in our file
system you would think could do big data
put it all in there i know from
experience that putting it all in there
can turn a couple hundred terabytes into
a petabyte very rapidly and suddenly
you're having to really add on to that
data store in your story you look at
data sometimes so you really need to be
able to filter your data out and so
let's go ahead and use our up arrow to
go to our last camera
so it's still a lot the same stuff uh so
we have all of our commands under import
we have the target
we're gonna change this to departments
see what this looks like in a minute but
we're going to put m3 in there that
doesn't have nothing to do with the
filtering i'll show you that in a second
though what that's for and we just want
to put in where
where that came from we can flip back on
over here we have department underscore
ids this is where that's coming from
that's just the name of the column on
here so we come in here to department id
is greater than four simple um logic
there you can see where you'd use that
for maybe creating buckets for ages uh
you know age from 10 to 15 20 to 30. you
might be looking for i mean there's all
kinds of reasons why you could use the
where command on here and filter
information out maybe you're doing word
counting and you want to know words that
are used less than a hundred times you
know you want to get rid of the and is
and and and all the stuff that's used
over and over again so we'll go ahead
and put the where and then department id
is greater than four we'll go ahead and
hit enter on here and this will create
our department 2 set up on this and i'll
go ahead and skip over some of the
runtime again it runs really slow on a
single node real quick page through our
commands
let's see here we go
our list and we should see underneath
the list the department two one here now
and there it is department two and then
i can go ahead and do list department
two you'll see the contents in here and
you'll see that there is only three maps
and it could be that the data created
three maps but remember i set it up to
only use three mappers so there's zero
one and two and we can go ahead and do a
cat on there remember this is department
two so we want to look at all the
contents of these three different files
and there it is it's greater than four
so we have golf is five outdoor six uh
fan shop is seven uh so we've
effectively filtered out our data and
just storing the data we want on our
file system so if you're going to store
data on here the next stage is to export
the data remember a lot of times you
have mysql server and we're continually
dumping that data into our long-term
storage and access the hadoop file
system but what happens when you need to
pull that data out and
restore a database or
maybe you have you just merged with a
new company a favorite topic merging
companies emerging databases
that's listed under nightmare and how
many different names for company can you
have so you can see where being able to
export is also equally important and
let's go ahead and do that and i'm going
to flip back over to my sql server here
and we'll need to go ahead and create
our database we're going to export it
now i'm not going to go too much
it's pretty much the same table we
already have in here
in this case we're going to create a
table called d-e-p-t
so it's the same setup but it's it's
just gonna we're just giving a different
name a different schema and so we've
done that and we'll go ahead and do a
select star from dept
there we go and it's empty that's what
we expect a new database a new data
table and it's empty in there uh so now
we need to go ahead and export our data
down into there
over here
let's go back up to one of our commands
here's scoop import in this case instead
of import we're going to take the scoop
and we're going to export so we're going
to just change that export and the
connection is going to remain the same
so same connect same database we're also
we're still doing the retail db we have
the same password so none of that
changes uh the big change here is going
to be the table instead of departments
uh remember we changed it and gave it a
new name and so we want to change it
here also d-e-p-t so department we're
not going to worry about the mapper
count and the where was part of our
import there we go and then finally it
needs to know where to export from so
instead of target directory we have an
export directory that's where it's
coming from uh still user cloudera and
we'll keep it as department 2. just so
you can see how that data is coming back
with that we filtered in and let's go
ahead and run this it'll take it just a
moment
go ahead and skip this so you don't have
to sit through it and once we've wrapped
up our xbox
exported the golf outdoors and fan shop
uh and you can imagine also that you
might have to use the where command in
your export also so there's a lot of
mixing the command line for scoop is
pretty straightforward you're changing
the different variables in there whether
you're creating a table listing a table
listing databases very powerful tool for
bringing your data into the hadoop file
system
that wraps it up for us today first
we're going to start with the history of
hive what is hive architecture
finally we're going to look into the
features of hive and do a quick hands-on
demo on hive in the cloudera hadoop file
system let's dive in with a brief
history of hive so the history of hive
begins with facebook facebook began
using hadoop as a solution to handle the
growing big data and we're not talking
about a data that fits on one or two or
even five computers we're talking due to
the fits on if you've looked at any of
our other hadoop tutorials you'll know
we're talking about very big data and
data pools and facebook certainly has a
lot of data it tracks as we know the
hadoop uses mapreduce for processing
data mapreduce required users to write
long codes and so you'd have these
really extensive java codes very
complicated for the average person to
use not all users were versed in java
and other coding languages this proved
to be a disadvantage for them users were
comfortable with writing queries in sql
sql has been around for a long time the
standard
sql query language hive was developed
with the vision to incorporate the
concepts of tables columns just like sql
so why hive well the problem was for
processing and analyzing data users
found it difficult to code as not all of
them were well versed with the coding
languages you have your processing ever
analyzing and so the solution was
required a language similar to sql which
was well known to all the users and thus
the hive or hql language evolved what is
hive hive is a data warehouse system
which is used for querying and analyzing
large datasets stored in the hdfs or the
hadoop file system hive uses a query
language that we call hive ql or hql
which is similar to sql so if we take
our user the user sends out their hive
queries and then that is converted into
a mapreduce tasks and then accesses the
hadoop mapreduce system let's take a
look at the architecture of hive
architecture of hive we have the hive
client
so that could be the programmer or maybe
it's a manager who knows enough sql to
do a basic query to look up the data
they need the hive client supports
different types of client applications
in different languages prefer for
performing queries and so we have our
thrift application in the hive thrift
client thrift is a software framework
hive server is based on thrift so it can
serve the request from all programming
language that support thrift and then we
have our jdbc application and the hive
jdbc driver jdbc java database
connectivity jdbc application is
connected through the jdbc driver and
then you have the odbc application or
the hive odbc driver the odbc or open
database connectivity the odbc
application is connected through the
odbc driver with the growing development
of all of our different scripting
languages python c plus plus spar
java you can find just about any
connection in any of the main scripting
languages and so we have our hive
services as we look at deeper into the
architecture hive supports various
services
so you have your hive server basically
your thrift application or your hive
thrift client or your jdbc or your hive
jdbc driver your odbc application or
your hive odbc driver they all connect
into the hive server and you have your
hive web interface you also have your
cli now the hive web interface is a gui
is provided to execute hive queries and
we'll actually be using that later on
today so you can see kind of what that
looks like and get a feel for what that
means commands are executed directly in
cli and then the cli is a direct
terminal window and i'll also show you
that too so you can see how those two
different interfaces work these then
push the code into the hive driver hive
driver is responsible for all the
queries submitted so everything goes
through that driver let's take a closer
look at the hive driver the hive driver
now performs three steps internally one
is a compiler hive driver passes query
to compiler where it is checked and
analyzed then the optimizer kicks in and
the optimize logical plan in the form of
a graph of mapreduce and hdfs tests
are executed we look at the architecture
we also have to note the metastore
you can think of this as your schema and
where is it located
processing a resource
these are all different ways of managing
these resources depending on what
version of hadoop
and if you look at our hadoop
tutorials you'll know that these are on
commodity machines and are linearly
scalable that means they're very
affordable a lot of time when you're
talking about big data you're talking
about a tenth of the price of storing it
on enterprise computers and then we look
at the data flow and hive
so in our data flow and hive we have our
hive in the hadoop system and underneath
the user interface or the ui we have our
driver our compiler our execution engine
and our meta store that all goes into
the mapreduce and the hadoop file system
so when we execute a query you see it
coming in here it goes into the driver
step one step two we get a plan what are
we going to do refers to the query
execution then we go to the metadata
it's like well what kind of metadata are
we actually looking at where is this
data located what is the schema on it uh
then this comes back with the metadata
into the compiler then the compiler
takes all that information and the send
plan returns it to the driver the driver
then sends the execute plan to the
execution engine once it's in the
execution engine the execution engine
acts as a bridge between hive and hadoop
to process the query and that's going
into your mapreduce in your hadoop file
system or your hdfs and then we come
back with the metadata operations it
goes back into the metastore to update
or let it know what's going on which
also goes to the between it's a
communication between the execution
engine and the metastore execution
engine communications is
bi-directionally with the metastore to
perform operations like create drop
tables metastore stores information
about tables and columns so again we're
talking about the schema of your
database and once we have that we have a
bi-directional send results
communication back into the driver and
then we have the fetch results which
goes back to the client so let's take a
little bit look at the hive data
modeling hive data modeling so you have
your high data modeling you have your
tables you have your partitions and you
have buckets the tables in hive are
created the same way it is done in rdbms
so when you're looking at your
traditional sql server or my sql server
where you might have enterprise
equipment and a lot of
people pulling and removing stuff off of
there the tables are going to look very
similar and this makes it very easy to
take that information and let's say you
need to keep current information but you
need to store all of your years of
transactions back into the hadoop hive
so you match those those all kind of
look the same the tables are the same
your databases look very similar and you
can easily import them back you can
easily store them into the hive system
partitions here tables are organized
into partitions for grouping same type
of data based on partition key this can
become very important for speeding up
the process of doing queries so if
you're looking at dates as far as like
your employment dates of employees if
that's what you're tracking you might
add a partition there because that might
be one of the key things that you're
always looking up as far as employees
are concerned and finally we have
buckets
data present in partitions can be
further divided into buckets for
efficient querying again there's that
efficiency at this level a lot of times
you're taught you're working with the
programmer and the admin of your hadoop
file system to maximize the efficiency
of that file system so it's usually a
two-person job and we're talking about
hive data modeling you want to make sure
that they work together and you're
maximizing your resources hive data
types so we're talking about hive data
types we have our primitive data types
and our complex data types a lot of this
will look familiar because it mirrors a
lot of stuff in sql in our primitive
data types we have the numerical data
types string data type date time data
type and miscellaneous data type and
these should be very they're kind of
self-explanatory but just in case
numerical data is your floats your
integers your short integers all of that
numerical data comes in as a number a
string of course is characters and
numbers and then you have your date time
stamp and then we have kind of a general
way of pulling your own created data
types in there that's your miscellaneous
data type and we have complex data types
so you can store arrays you can store
maps you can store structures
and even units in there as we dig into
hive data types
and we have the primitive data types and
the complex data types so we look at
primitive data types and we're looking
at numeric data types data types like an
integer a float a decimal those are all
stored as numbers in the hive data
system a string data type data types
like characters and strings you store
the name of the person you're working
with you know john doe the city
memphis the state tennessee maybe it's
boulder colorado usa or maybe it's hyper
bad
india that's all going to be string and
stored as a string character and of
course we have our date time data type
data types like timestamp date interval
those are very common as far as tracking
sales anything like that you just think
if you can type a stamp of time on it or
maybe you're dealing with the race and
you want to know the interval how long
did the person take to complete whatever
task it was all that is date time data
type and then we talk miscellaneous data
type these are like boolean and binary
and when you get into boolean binary you
can actually almost create anything in
there but your yes knows zero one now
let's take a look at complex data types
a little closer uh we have arrays so
your syntax is of data type and it's an
array and you can just think of an array
as a collection of same
entities one two three four if they're
all numbers and you have maps this is a
collection of key value pairs
so understanding maps is so central to
hadoop so we store maps you have a key
which is a set you only have one key per
mapped value and so you in hadoop of
course you collect uh the same keys and
you can add them all up or do something
with all the contents of the same key
but this is our map as a primitive type
data type in our collection of key value
pairs and then collection of complex
data with comment so we can have a
structure we have a column name data
type comment call a c column comment uh
so you can get very complicated
structures in here with your collection
of data and you're commented set up and
then we have units this is a collection
of heterogeneous data types
so the syntax for this is union type
data type data type and so on so it's
all going to be the same a little bit
different than the arrays where you can
actually mix and match different modes
of hive hive operates in two modes
depending on the number and size of data
nodes we have our local mode and our map
reduce mode when we talk about the local
mode it is used when hadoop is having
one data node and the data is small
processing will be very fast on a
smaller data sets which are present in
local machine and this might be that you
have a local file stuff you're uploading
into the hive and you need to do some
processes in there you can go ahead and
run those high processes and queries on
it usually you don't see much in the way
of a single node hadoop system if you're
going to do that you might as well just
use like an sql database or even a java
sqlite or something python is sqlite so
you don't really see a lot of single
node hadoop databases but you do see the
local mode in hive where you're working
with a small amount of data that's going
to be integrated into the larger
database and then we have the map reduce
mode this is used when hadoop is having
multiple data nodes and the data is
spread across various data nodes
processing large data sets can be more
efficient using this mode and this you
can think of instead of it being one two
three or even five computers we're
usually talking with the hadoop file
system we're looking at 10 computers 15
100 where this data is spread across all
those different hadoop nodes difference
between hive and
rdbms remember rdbms stands for the
relational database management system
let's take a look at the difference
between hive and the rdbms with hive
hive enforces schema on read and it's
very important that whatever is coming
in that's when hive is looking at it and
making sure that it fits the model
the rdbms enforces a schema when it
actually writes the data into the
database so it's read the data and then
once it starts to write it that's where
it's going to give you the error tell
you something's incorrect about your
scheme hive data size is in petabytes
that is hard to imagine you know we're
looking at your personal computer on
your desk maybe you have 10 terabytes if
it's a high-end computer we're talking
petabytes so that's hundreds of
computers grouped together when rdbms
data size is in terabytes very rarely do
you see an rdbms system that's spread
over more than five computers and
there's a lot of reasons for that with
the rdbms it actually has a high end
amount of rights to the hard drive
there's a lot more going on there you're
writing and pulling stuff so you really
don't want to get too big with an rd bms
or you're going to run into a lot of
problems with hive you can take it as
big as you want hive is based on the
notion of write once and read many times
this is so important and they call it
worm which is right w ones o read are
many times m they refer to it as worm
and that's true of any of you a lot of
your hadoop setup it's it's altered a
little bit but in general we're looking
at archiving data that you want to do
data analysis on we're looking at
pulling all that stuff off your rd bms
from years and years and years of
business or whatever your company does
or scientific research and putting that
into a huge data pool so that you can
now do queries on it and get that
information out of it with the rdbms
it's based on the notion of read and
write many times so you're continually
updating this database you're
continually bringing up new stuff new
sales
the account changes because they have a
different licensing now whatever
software you're selling all that kind of
stuff where the data is continually
fluctuating and then hive resembles a
traditional database by supporting sql
but it is not a database it is a data
warehouse this is very important it goes
with all the other stuff we've talked
about that we're not looking at a
database but a data warehouse to store
the data and still have fast and easy
access to it for doing queries you can
think of
twitter and facebook they have so many
posts that are archived back
historically those posts aren't going to
change they made the post they're posted
they're there and they're in their
database but they have to store it in a
warehouse in case they want to pull it
back up with the rdbms it's a type of
database management system which is
based on the relational model of data
and then with hive easily scalable at a
low cost again we're talking maybe a
thousand dollars per terabyte
the rdbms is not scalable at a low cost
when you first start on the lower end
you're talking about 10 000 per terabyte
of data including all the backup on the
models and all the added necessities to
support it as you scale it up you have
to scale those computers and hardware up
so you might start off with a basic
server and then you upgrade to a sun
computer to run it and you spend you
know tens of thousands of dollars for
that hardware upgrade with hive you just
put another computer into your hadoop
file system so let's look at some of the
features of hive when we're looking at
the features of hive we're talking about
the use of sql like language called hive
ql a lot of times you'll see that as hql
which is easier than long codes this is
nice if you're working with your
shareholders you come to them and you
say hey you can do a basic sql query on
here and pull up the information you
need this way you don't have to take off
have your programmers jump in every time
they want to look up something in the
database they actually now can easily do
that if they're not
skilled in programming and script
writing tables are used which are
similar to the rdbms hence easier to
understand and one of the things i like
about this is when i'm bringing tables
in from a mysql server or sql server
there's almost a direct reflection
between the two so when you're looking
at one which is the data which is kindly
changing and then you're going into the
archive database it's not this huge jump
where you have to learn a whole new
language
you mirror that same schema into the
hdfs into the hive making it very easy
to go between the two and then using
hive ql multiple users can
simultaneously query data so again you
have multiple clients in there and they
send in their query that's also true
with the rdbms which kind of cues them
up because it's running so fast you
don't notice the lag time well you get
that also with the hql as you add more
computers in the query can go very
quickly depending on how many computers
and how much resources each machine has
to pull the information and high hive
supports a variety of data types
so with hive it's designed to be on the
hadoop system which you can put almost
anything into the hadoop file system so
with all that let's take a look at a
demo on hive ql or hql before i dive
into the hands-on demo let's take a look
at the website hive.apache.org
that's the main website since apache
it's an apache open source
software this is the main software for
the main site for the build and if you
go in here you'll see that they're
slowly migrating hive into beehive and
so if you see beehive versus hive note
the beehive as the new release is coming
out that's all it is it reflects a lot
of the same functionality of hive it's
the same thing and then we like to pull
up some kind of documentation on
commands and for this i'm actually going
to go to hortonworks hive cheat sheet
and that's because hortonworks and
cloudera are two of the most common used
builds for hadoop and four which include
hive and all the different tools in
there and so hortonworks has a pretty
good pdf you can download cheat sheet on
there i believe cloudera does too but
we'll go ahead and just look at the
horton one because it's the one that
comes up really good and you can see
when we look at the query language it
compares mysql server to hive ql or hql
and you can see the basic select we
select from columns
from table where conditions exist the
most basic command on there and they
have different things you can do with it
just like you do with your sql and if
you scroll down you'll see
data types so here's your integer your
flow your binary double string timestamp
and all the different data types you can
use some different semantics different
keys features functions
for running a hive query command line
setup and of course a hive shell set up
in here so you can see right here if we
loop through it it has a lot of your
basic stuff and it is we're basically
looking at sql across a horton database
i'm going to go ahead and run our hadoop
cluster hive
demo and i'm going to go ahead and use
now obviously hadoop and hive are
designed to run across a cluster of
computers so we talk about a single node
is for education testing that kind of
thing and if you have a chance you can
always go back and look at our demo we
had on
setting up a hadoop system in a single
cluster just set a note down below in
the youtube video and our team will get
in contact with you and send you that
link if you don't already have it or you
can contact us at the
www.simplylearn.com now in here it's
always important to note that you do
need
on your computer if you're running on
windows because i'm on a windows machine
you're going to need probably about 12
gigabytes to actually run this it used
to be goodbye with a lot less but as
things have evolved they take up more
and more resources and you need the
professional version if you have the
home version i was able to get that to
run but boy did it take a lot of extra
work to get the home version to let me
use the virtual setup on there and we'll
simply click on the cloudera quick start
and i'm going to go and just start that
up and this is starting up our linux so
we have our windows 10 which is a
computer i'm on and then i have the
virtual box which is going to have a
linux operating system in it and we'll
skip ahead so you don't have to watch
the whole install something interesting
to know about the cloudera is that it's
running on linuxcentos and for whatever
reason i've always had to click on it
and hit the escape button for it to spin
up and then you'll see the dos come in
here now that our cloudera spun up on
our virtual machine with the linux on uh
we can see here we have our it uses the
thunderbird browser on here by default
and automatically opens up a number of
different tabs for us and a quick note
because i mentioned like the
restrictions on getting set up on your
own computer if you have a home edition
computer and you're worried about
setting it up on there you can also go
in there and spin up a one month free
service on amazon web service to play
with this so there's other options
you're not stuck with just doing it on
the quick start menu you can spin this
up in many other ways now the first
thing we want to note is that we've come
in here into cloudera and i'm going to
access this in two ways
the first one is we're going to use hue
and i'm going to open up hue and i'll
take it a moment to load from the setup
on here and hue is nice if i go in and
use hue as an editor into hive or into
the hadoop setup usually i'm doing it as
a
from an admin side because it has a lot
more information a lot of visuals less
to do with you know actually diving in
there and just executing code and you
can also write this code into files and
scripts and there's other things you can
otherwise you can upload it into hive
but today we're going to look at the
command lines and we'll upload it into
hue and then we'll go into and actually
do our work in a terminal window under
the hive shell now in the hue browser
window if you go under query and click
on the pull down menu and then you go
under editor and you'll see hive there
we go there's our hive setup i go and
click on hive and this will open up our
query down here and now it has a nice
little b that shows our hive going and
we can go something very simple down
here like show
databases and we follow it with the
semicolon and that's the standard in
hive is you always add our
punctuation at the end there and i'll go
ahead and run this and the query will
show up underneath and you'll see down
here since this is a new quick start i
just put on here you'll see it has the
default down here for the databases
that's the database name i haven't
actually created any databases on here
and then there's a lot of other like
assistant function tables
your databases up here there's all kinds
of things you can research you can look
at through hue as far as a bigger
picture the downside of this is it
always seems to lag for me whenever i'm
doing this i always seem to run slow so
if you're in cloudera you can open up a
terminal window they actually have an
icon at the top you can also go under
applications and under applications
system tools and terminal either one
will work it's just a regular terminal
window and this terminal window is now
running underneath our linux so this is
a linux terminal window or on our
virtual machine which is resting on our
regular windows 10 machine and we'll go
ahead and zoom this in so you can see
the text better on your own video and i
simply just clicked on view and zoom in
and then all we have to do is type in
hive and this will open up the shell on
here and it takes it just a moment to
load when starting up hive i also want
to note that depending on your rights on
the computer you're on interaction you
might have to do sudo hive and put in
your password and username most
computers are usually set up with the
hive login again it just depends on how
you're accessing the linux system and
the hive shell once we're in here we can
go ahead and do a simple uh hql command
show databases and if we do that we'll
see here that we don't have any
databases so we can go ahead and create
a database and we'll just call it office
for today for this moment now if i do
show we'll just do the up arrow up arrow
is a hotkey that works in both linux and
in hive so i can go back and paste
through all the commands i've typed in
and we can see now that i have my
there's of course a default database and
then there's the office database so now
we've created a database it's pretty
quick and easy and we can go ahead and
drop the database we can do drop
database
office now this will work on this
database because it's empty if your
database was not empty you would have to
do cascade and that drops all the tables
in the database and the database itself
now if we do show database and we'll go
ahead and recreate our database because
we're going to use the office database
for the rest of this hands-on demo a
really handy command to now
set what the sql or hql is to use office
and what that does is that sets office
as a default database so instead of
having to reference the database every
time we work with a table it now
automatically assumes that's the
database being used whatever tables
we're working on the difference is you
put the database name period table and
i'll show you in just a minute what that
looks like and how that's different if
we're going to have a table and a
database we should probably load some
data into it so let me go ahead and
switch gears here and open up a terminal
window you can just open another
terminal window and it'll open up right
on top of the one that you have hive
shell running in and when we're in this
terminal window first we're going to go
ahead and just do a list which is of
course a linux command you can see all
the files i have in here this is the
default load we can change directory to
documents we can list in documents and
we're actually going to be looking at
employee.csv a linux command is the cat
you can use this actually to combine
documents there's all kinds of things
that cat does but if we want to just
display the contents of our employee.csv
file we can simply do cat employee csv
and when we're looking at this we want
to know a couple things one there's a
line at the top okay so the very first
thing we notice is that we have a header
line the next thing we notice is that
the data is comma separated and in this
particular case you'll see a space here
generally with these you got to be real
careful with spaces there's all kinds of
things you got to watch out for because
they can cause issues these spaces won't
because these are all strings that the
space is connected to if this was a
space next to the integer you would get
a null value that comes into the
database without doing something extra
in there now with most of hadoop that's
important to know that you're writing
the data once reading it many times and
that's true of almost all your hadoop
things coming in so you really want to
process the data before it gets into the
database and for those who of you have
studied uh data transformation that's
the adult where you extract transfer
form and then load the data so you
really want to extract and transform
before putting it into the hive then you
load it into the hive with the transform
data and of course we also want to note
the schema we have an integer string
string integer integer uh so we kept it
pretty simple in here as far as the way
the data is set up the last thing that
you're going to want to look up
is the source since we're doing local
uploads we want to know what the path is
we have the whole path in this case it's
home slash cloudera slash documents and
these are just text documents we're
working with right now we're not doing
anything fancy so we can do a simple get
edit employee.csv
and you'll see it comes up here it's
just a text document so i can easily
remove these added spaces there we go
and then we go and just save it and so
now it has the new setup
so any text editor will do back to the
hive shell so let's go ahead and create
a table employee and what i want you to
note here is i did not put the semicolon
on the end here semicolon tells it to
execute that line so this is kind of
nice if you're you can actually just
paste it in if you have it written on
another sheet and you can see right here
where i have create table employee and
it goes into the next line on there so i
can do all of my commands at once now
just so i don't have any typo errors i
went ahead and just pasted the next
three lines in and the next one is our
schema if you remember correctly from
the other side we have different values
which was id
name department year of joining and
salary and the id is an integer name is
a string department string
integer and they're in brackets
and then we have row
so you'll get a bunch of null values
loaded into your table and then finally
our table properties we want to skip the
header line count equals one now this is
a lot of work for uploading a single
file it's kind of goofy when you're
uploading a single file that you have to
put all this in here but keep in mind
hive and hadoop is designed for writing
many files into the database you write
them all in there and then you can
they're saved it's an archive it's a
data warehouse and then you're able to
do all your queries on them so a lot of
times we're not looking at just the one
file coming up we're loading hundreds of
files you have your reports coming off
of your main database all those reports
are being loaded and you have your log
files you have i mean all this different
data is being dumped into hadoop and in
this case hive on top of hadoop and so
we need to let it know hey how do i
handle these files coming in and then we
have the semicolon at the end which lets
us know to go ahead and run this line
and so we'll go ahead and run that and
now if we do a show tables uh you can
see there's our employee on there we can
also describe if we do describe employee
you can see that we have our id integer
name string department string year of
joining integer and salary integer and
then finally let's just do a select star
from employee very basic sql nhql
command selecting data it's going to
come up and we haven't put anything in
it so as we expect there's no data in it
so if we flip back to our
linux terminal window you can see where
we did the cat
employee.csv and you can see all the
data we expect to come into it and we
also did our pwd and right here you see
the path you need that full path when
you are loading data you know you can do
a browse and if i did it right now with
just the employee.csv as a name it will
work but that is a really bad habit in
general when you're loading data because
it's you don't know what else is going
on in the computer you want to do the
full path almost in all your data loads
so let's go ahead and flip back over
here to our hive shell we're working in
and the command for this is load data so
that says hey we're loading data that's
a hive command hql and we want local
data so you got to put down local in
path so now it needs to know where the
path is now to make this more legible
i'm just going to go ahead and hit enter
then we'll just paste the full path in
there which i have stored over on the
side like a good prepared demo and
you'll see here we have home cloudera
documents
employee.csv so it's a whole path for
this text document in here and we go
ahead and hit enter in there and then we
have to let it know where the data is
going so now we have a source and we
need a destination and it's going to go
into the table and we'll just call it
employee we'll just match the table in
there and because i want it to execute
we put the semicolon on the end it goes
ahead and executes all three lines now
if we go back if you remember we did the
select star from employee just using the
up error to page through my different
commands i've already typed in you can
see right here we have as we expect we
have rows sam mike and nick and we have
all their information showing in our
four rows and then let's go ahead and do
uh select
and count let's look at a couple of
these different select options you can
do we're going to count everything from
employee now this is kind of interesting
because the first one just pops up with
the basic select because it doesn't need
to go through the full map reduce phase
but when you start doing a count it does
go through the full map redo setup in
the hive and hadoop and because i'm
doing this demo on a single node
cloudera
box on top of a windows 10 all the
benefits of running it on a cluster are
gone and instead it's now going through
all those added layers so it takes
longer to run you know like i said when
you do a single node as i said earlier
it doesn't do any good as an actual
distribution because you're only running
it on one computer and then you've added
all these different layers to run it and
we see it comes up with four and that's
what we expect we have four rows we
expect four at the end and if you
remember from
our cheat sheet which we brought up here
from hortons it's a pretty good one
there's all these different commands we
can do we'll look at one more command
where we do the uh what they call sub
queries right down here because that's
really common to do a lot of sub queries
and so we'll do select star or all
different columns from
employee now if we weren't using the
office database it would look like this
from office dot employee and either one
will work on this particular one because
we have office set as a default on there
so from office employee and then the
command where creates a subset and in
this case we want to know where the
salary is greater than 25 000 there we
go and of course we end with our
semicolon and if we run this query you
can see it pops up and there's our
salaries of people top earners uh we
have rose and i t and mike and hr kudos
to them of course they're fictional i
don't actually we don't actually have a
rose and a mic in those positions or
maybe we do so finally we want to go
ahead and do is we're done with this
table now remember you're dealing with
the data warehouse so you usually don't
do a lot of dropping of tables and
databases but we're going to go ahead
and drop this table here before we drop
it one more quick note is we can change
it so what we're going to do is we're
going to alter table office employee and
we want to go ahead and rename it
there's some other commands you can do
in here but rename is pretty common and
we're going to rename it to
and it's going to stay in office and uh
turns out one of our
shareholders really doesn't like the
word employee he wants employees plural
it's a big deal to him so let's go ahead
and change that name for the table it's
that easy because it's just changing the
metadata on there and now if we do show
tables you'll see we now have employees
not employee and then at this point
maybe we're doing some house cleaning
because this is all practice so we're
going to go ahead and drop table and
we'll drop table employees because we
changed the name in there so if we did
employee just give us an error and now
if we do show tables you'll see all the
tables are gone now the next thing we
want to take a look at and we're going
to walk back through the loading of data
just real quick because we're going to
load two tables in here and let me just
float back to our terminal window so we
can see what those tables are that we're
loading and so up here we have customer
we have a customer file and we have an
order file we want to go ahead and put
the customers and the orders into here
so those are the two we're doing and of
course it's always nice to see what
you're working with so let's do our cat
customer.csv we could always do g edit
but we don't really need to edit these
we just want to take a look at the data
in customer and important in here is
again we have a header so we have to
skip a line comma separated nothing odd
with the data we have our schema which
is
integer string integer string integer so
you know you'd want to take that note
that down or flip back and forth when
you're doing it and then let's go ahead
and do cat order dot csv and we can see
we have oid which i'm guessing is the
order id we have a date up something new
we've done integers and strings but we
haven't done date when you're importing
new and you never worked with the date
date's always one of the more trickier
fields to port in when that's true of
just about any scripting language i've
worked with all of them have their own
idea of how date's supposed to be
formatted what the default is this
particular format or it's year and it
has all four uh digits dash month two
digits dash day is the standard import
for the hive so you'll have to look up
and see what the different formats are
if you're going to do a different format
in there coming in or you're not able to
pre-process the data but this would be a
pre-processing of the data thing coming
in if you remember correctly from our
edel which is uh e just in case you
weren't able to hear me last time etl
which stands for extract transform then
load so you want to make sure you're
transforming this data before it gets
into here and so we're going to go ahead
and bring
both this data in here and really we're
doing this so we can show you the basic
join there is if you remember from our
setup merge join all kinds of different
things you can do but joining different
data sets is so common so it's really
important to know how to do this we need
to go ahead and bring in these two data
sets and you can see where i just
created a table customer here's our
schema the integer name age address
salary here's our eliminated by commas
and our table properties where we skip a
line well let's go ahead and load the
data first and then we'll do that with
our order and let's go ahead and put
that in here and i've got it split into
three lines so you can see it easily we
got load data local in path so we know
we're loading data we know it's local
and we have the path here's the complete
path for
oops this is supposed to be order csv
grab the wrong one of course it's going
to give me errors because you can't
recreate the same table on there and
here we go create table here's our
integer date customer the basic setup
that we had coming in here for our
schema row format commas table
properties skip header line and then
finally let's load the data into
our order table load data local in path
home cloudera documents order.csv into
table order now if we did everything
right we should be able to do select
star from customer and you can see we
have all seven customers and then we can
do select star from order and we have uh
four orders uh so this is just like a
quick frame we have a lot of times when
you have your customer databases in
business you have thousands of customers
from years and years and some of them
you know they move they close their
business they change names all kinds of
things happen so we want to do is we
want to go ahead and find just the
information connected to these orders
and who's connected to them and so let's
go ahead and do it's a select because
we're going to display information so
select and this is kind of interesting
we're going to do c dot id
and i'm going to define c as customer as
a customer table in just a minute then
we're going to do c dot name and again
we're going to define the c c dot age so
this means from the customer we want to
know their id their name their age and
then you know i'd also like to know the
order amount uh so let's do o for dot
amount and then this is where we need to
go ahead and define uh what we're doing
and i'm going to capitalize from
customer so we're going to take the
customer table in here and we're going
to name it c that's where the c comes
from so that's the customer table c and
we want to join order as o that's where
our o comes from so the o dot amount is
what we're joining in there and then we
want to do this on we got to tell it how
to connect the two tables c dot id
equals o dot customer underscore id so
now we know how they're joined and
remember we have seven customers in here
we have four orders and as it processes
we should get a return of four different
names joined together and they're joined
based on of course the orders on there
and once we're done we now have the
order number the person who made the
order their age and the amount of the
order which came from the order table uh
so you have your different information
and you can see how the join works here
very common use of tables and hql and
sql and let's do one more thing with our
database and then i'll show you a couple
other hive commands and let's go ahead
and do a drop and we're going to drop
database office
and if you're looking at this and you
remember from earlier this will give me
an error and let's just see what that
looks like it says failed to execute
exception one or more tables exist so if
you remember from before you can't just
drop a database unless you tell it to
cascade that lets it no i don't care how
many tables are in it let's get rid of
it and in hadoop since it's an in our
it's a warehouse a data warehouse
usually don't do a lot of dropping uh
maybe at the beginning when you're
developing the schemas and you realize
you messed up you might drop some stuff
but down the road you're really just
adding commodity machines to take up so
you can store more stuff on it so you
usually don't do a lot of database
dropping and some other
fun commands to know is you can do
select round 2.3 is round value you can
do a round off in
hive we can do as floor value which is
going to give us a two so it turns it
into an integer versus a float it goes
down you know basically truncates it but
it goes down and we can also do sealing
which is going to round it up so we're
looking for the next integer above
there's a few commands we didn't show in
here because we're on a single node as
as an admin to help spediate the process
you usually add in partitions for the
data and buckets you can't do that on a
single node because the when you add a
partition it partitions it across
separate nodes but beyond that you can
see that it's very straightforward we
have sql coming in and all your basic
queries that are in sql are very similar
to hql let's get started with pig why
pig what is pig mapreduce versus hive
versus pig hopefully you've had a chance
to do our hive tutorial in our mapreduce
tutorial if you haven't send a note over
to simplylearn and we'll follow up with
a link to you we'll look at pig
architecture working a pig pig latin
data model pig execution modes a use
case twitter and features a pick and
then we'll tag on a short demo so you
can see pig in action so why pig as we
all know hadoop uses mapreduce to
analyze and process big data processing
big data consumed more time so before we
had the hadoop system they'd have to
spend a lot of money on a huge set of
computers and enterprise machines so he
introduced the hadoop map reduce and so
afterwards processing big data was
faster using mapreduce then what is the
problem with map reduce prior to 2006
all mapreduce programs were written in
java non-programmers found it difficult
to write lengthy java codes they faced
issues in incorporating map sort reduced
to fundamentals of mapreduce while
creating a program you can see here map
face shuffle and sort reduce phase
eventually it became a difficult task to
maintain and optimize a code due to
which the processing time increased you
can imagine a manager trying to go in
there and editing a simple query to find
out data and he has to go talk to the
programmers anytime he wants anything so
that was a big problem not everybody
wants to have a on-call programmer for
every manager on their team yahoo face
problems to process and analyze large
data sets using java as the codes were
complex and lengthy there was a
necessity to develop an easier way to
analyze large data sets without using
time-consuming complex java modes and
codes and scripts and all that fun stuff
apache pig was developed by yahoo it was
developed with the vision to analyze and
process large datasets without using
complex java codes pig was developed
especially for non-programmers pig used
simple steps to analyze data sets which
was time efficient so what exactly is
pig pig is a scripting platform that
runs on hadoop clusters designed to
process and analyze large data sets and
so you have your pig which uses sql like
queries they're definitely not sql but
some of them resemble sql queries and
then we use that to analyze our data pig
operates on various types of data like
structured semi-structured and
unstructured data let's take a closer
look at map reduce versus hive versus
pig so we start with a compiled language
your mapreduce and we have hive which is
your sql like query and then we have pig
which is a scripting language it has
some similarities to sql but it has a
lot of its own stuff remember sql like
query which is what hive is based off
looks for structured data and so when
you get into scripting languages like
pig now we're dealing more with
semi-structured and even unstructured
data with a hadoop map reduced we have a
need to write long complex codes with
hive no need to write complex codes you
could just put it in a simple sql query
or hql hive ql and in pig no need to
write complex codes as we have piglet
now remember in the mapreduce it can
produce structured semi-structured and
unstructured data as i mentioned before
hive can process only structured data
think rows and columns where pig can
process structured semi-structured and
unstructured data you can think of
structured data as rows and columns
semi-structured as your html xml
documents like you have on your web
pages and unstructured could be anything
from groups of documents and written
format twitter tweets any of those
things come in as very unstructured data
and with our hadoop map reduce we have a
lower level of abstraction with both
hive and pig we have a higher level
abstraction so it's much more easy for
someone to use without having to dive in
deep and write a very lengthy map reduce
code and those map and reduce codes can
take 70 80 lines of code when you can do
the same thing in one or two lines with
hive or pig this is the advantage pig
has over hive it can process only
structured data and hive while in pig it
can process structured semi-structured
and unstructured data some other
features to note that separates the
different query languages is when we
look at map and reduce mapreduce
supports partitioning features as does
hive pig no concept of partitioning in
picks it doesn't support your
partitioning feature your partitioning
features allow you to partition the data
in such a way that it can be queried
quicker you're not able to do that in
pig mapreduce uses java and python while
hive uses an sql like query language
known as hive ql or hql pig latin is
used which is a procedural data flow
language mapreduce is used by
programmers pretty much as
straightforward on java hive is used by
data analysts pig is used by researchers
and programmers certainly there's a lot
of mix between all three programmers
have been known to go in and use a hive
for quick query and anybody's been able
to use pig for quick query or research
under map and reduce code performance is
really good under hive code performance
is lesser than map and reduce and pig
under pig code performance is lesser
than mapreduce but better than hive so
if we're going to look at speed and time
the map reduce is going to be the
fastest performance on all of those
where pig will have second and high
follows in the back let's look at
components of pig pig has two main
components we have pig latin pig latin
is the procedural data flow language
used in pig to analyze data it is easy
to program using piglet and it is
similar to sql and then we have the
runtime engine runtime engine represents
the execution environment created to run
pig latin programs it is also a compiler
that produces mapreduce programs uses
hdfs or your hadoop file system for
storing and retrieving data and as we
dig deeper into the pig architecture
we'll see that we have pig latin scripts
programmers write a script in piglet to
analyze data using pig then you have the
grunt shell and it actually says grunt
when we start it up and we'll show you
that here in a little bit which goes
into the pig server and this is where we
have our parser parser checks the syntax
of the pig script after checking the
output will be a dag directed acelic
graph and then we have an optimizer
which optimizes after your dag your
logical plan is passed to the logical
optimizer where an optimization takes
place finally the compiler converts the
dag into map reduce jobs and then that
is executed on the map reduce under the
execution engine the results are
displayed using dump statement and
stored in hdfs using store statement and
again we'll show you that
the kind of end you always want to
execute everything once you've created
it and so dump is kind of our execution
statement and you can see right here as
we were talking about earlier once we
get to the execution engine and it's
coded into mapreduce then the map reduce
processes it onto the hdfs
working of pig pig latin script is
written by the users so you have load
data and write pig script and pig
operations so we look at the working of
pig pig latin script is written by the
users there's step one we load data and
write pig script and step two in this
step all the pig operations are
performed by parser optimizer and
compiler so we go into the pig
operations and then we get to step three
execution of the plan in this days the
results are shown on the screen
otherwise stored in the hdfs as per the
code so it might be of a small amount of
data you're reducing it to and you want
to put that on the screen or you might
be converting a huge amount of data
which you want to put back into the
hadoop file system for other use let's
take a look at the pig latin data model
the data model of pig latin helps pig to
handle various types of data for example
we have atom rob or 50. atom represents
any single value of primitive data type
in pig latin like integer float string
it is stored as a string tuple so we go
from our atom which are most basic
things so if you look at just rob or
just 50 that's an atom that's our most
basic object we have in pig latin then
you have a tuple tuple represents
sequence of fields that can be of any
data type it is the same as a row in
rdbms for example a set of data from a
single row and you can see here we have
rob comma five and you can imagine with
many of our other examples we've used
you might have the id number the name
where they live their age their date of
starting the job that would all be one
row and stored as a tuple and then we
create a bag a bag is a collection of
tuples it is the same as a table in
rdbms and is represented by brackets and
you can see here we have our table with
rob5 mic 10 and we also have a map a map
is a set of key value pairs key is of
character array type and a value can be
of any type it is represented by the
brackets and so we have name and age
where the key value is mic in 10. pig
latin has a fully nestable data model
that means one data type can be nested
within another here's a diagram
representation of pig latin data model
and in this particular example we have
basically an id number a name and age
and a place and we break this apart we
look at this model from pig latin
perspective we start with our field and
if you remember a field contains
basically an atom it is one
particular data type and the atom is
stored as a string which then converts
it into either an integer or number or
character string next we have our tuple
and in this case you can see that it
represents a row so our tuple would be
three comma joe comma 29 comma
california and finally we have our bag
which contains three rows in it in this
particular example let's take a quick
look at pig execution modes pig works in
two execution modes depending on where
the data is reciting and where the pig
script is going to run we have local
mode here the pig engine takes input
from the linux file system and the
output is stored in the same file system
local mold local mode is useful in
analyzing small data sets using pig and
we have the map reduced mode here the
pig engine directly interacts and
executes in hdfs and mapreduce in the
map reduce mode queries written in pig
latin are translated into mapreduce jobs
and are run on a hadoop cluster by
default pig runs in this mode there are
three modes in pig depending on how a
pig latin code can be written we have
our interactive mode batch mode and
embedded mode the interactive mode means
coding and executing the script line by
line when we do our example we'll be in
the interactive mode in badge mode all
scripts are coded in a file with the
extension dot pig and the file is
directly executed and then there's
embedded mode pig lets its users define
their own functions udfss in a
programming language such as java so
let's take a look and see how this works
in a use case in this case use case
twitter users on twitter generate about
500 million tweets on a daily basis the
hadoop mapreduce was used to process and
analyze this data analyzing the number
of tweets created by a user in the tweet
table was done using mapreduce and java
programming language and you can see the
problem it was difficult to perform
mapreduce operations as users were not
well versed with written complex java
codes so twitter used apache pig to
overcome these problems and let's see
how let's start with the problem
statement analyze the user table and
tweet table and find out how many tweets
are created by a person and here you can
see we have a user table we have alice
tim and john with their id numbers one
two three and we have a tweet table in
the tweet table you have your the id of
the user and then what they tweeted
google was a good whatever it was
tennis. spacecraft olympics politics
whatever they're tweeting about the
following operations were performed for
analyzing given data first the twitter
data is loaded into the pig storage
using load command and you can see here
we have our data coming in and then
that's going into pig storage and this
data is probably on an enterprise
computer so this is actually active
twitter's going on and then it goes into
hadoop file system remember the hadoop
file system is a data warehouse for
storing data and so the first step is we
want to go ahead and load it into the
pig storage into our data storage system
the remaining operations performed are
shown below in join and group operation
the tweet and user tables are joined and
grouped using co-group command and you
can see here where we add a whole column
when we go from user names and tweet to
the id link directly to the name so
alice was user 1 10 was 2 and john 3.
and so now they're listed with their
actual tweet the next operation is the
aggregation the tweets are counted
according to the names the command used
is count so it's very straightforward we
just want to count how many tweets each
user is doing and finally the result
after the count operation is joined with
the user table to find out the username
and you can see here where alice had 3
tim 2 and john 1. pig reduces the
complexity of the operations which would
have been lengthy using mapreduce in
joining group operation the tweet and
user tables are joined and grouped using
co-group command the next operation is
the aggregation the tweets are counted
according to the names the command used
is count the result after the count
operation is joined with the user table
to find out the username and you can see
we're talking about three lines of
script versus a mapreduce code of about
80 lines finally we could find out the
number of tweets created by a user in a
simple way so let's go quickly over some
of the features of pig that we already
went through most of these
first ease of programming as pig latin
is similar to sql lesser lines of code
need to be written short development
time as the code is simpler so we can
get our queries out rather quickly
instead of having to have a programmer
spend hours on it handles all kinds of
data like structured semi-structured and
unstructured pig lets us create
user-defined functions pig offers a
large set of operators such as join
filter and so on it allows for multiple
queries to process unparalleled and
optimization and compilation is easy as
it is done automatically and internally
so enough theory let's dive in and show
you a quick demo on some of the commands
you can do in pick today's setup will
continue as we have in the last three
demos to go and use cloudera quick start
and we'll be doing this in virtualbox we
do have a tutorial in setting that up
you can send a note to our simplylearn
team and then get that linked to you
once your cloudera quick start has spun
up and remember this is virtualbox we've
created a virtual machine and this
virtual machine is centos linux once
it's spun up you'll be in a full linux
system here and as you can see we have
thunderbird browser which opens up to
the hadoop basic system browser and we
can go underneath the hue where it comes
up by default if you click on the pull
down menu and go under editor you can
see there's our impala our hive
pig along with a bunch of other query
languages you can use and we're going
under pig and then once you're in pig we
can go ahead and use our command line
here and just click that little blue
button to start it up and running we
will actually be working in terminal
window and so if you're in the cloud era
quick start you can open up the terminal
window up top or if you're in your own
setup and you're logged in you can
easily use all of your commands here in
terminal window and we'll zoom in that
way you get a nice view of what's going
on there we go now for our first command
we're going to do a hadoop command and
import some data into the hadoop system
in this case a pig input let's take a
look at this we have uh hadoop now let's
know it's going to be a hadoop command
dfs there's actually four variations of
dfs so if you have hdfs or whatever
that's fine all four of them point used
to be different setups underneath
different things and now they all do the
same thing and we want to put this file
which in this case is under home
cloudera documents and sample and we
just want to take that and put it into
the pig input and let's take a look at
that file if i go under my document
browsers and open this up you'll see
it's got a simple id name profession and
age we have one jack engineer 25 and
that was in one of our earlier things we
had in there and so let's go ahead and
hit enter and execute this and now we've
uploaded that data and it's gone into
our pig input and then a lot of the uh
hadoop commands mimic the linux commands
and so you'll see we have cat as one of
our commands or we has a hyphen before
it so we execute that with hadoop dfs
hyphen cat slash pig input because
that's what we called it that's where we
put our sample csv at and we execute
this you can see from our hadoop system
it's going to go in and pull that up and
sure enough it pulls out the data file
we just put in there and then we can
simply enter the pig latin or pig editor
mode by typing in pig and we can see
here by our grunt i told you that's how
it was going to tell you we're in pig
latin there's our grunt command line so
we are now in the pig shell and then
we'll go ahead and put our load command
in here and the way this works is i'm
going to have office equals load and
here's my load in this case it's going
to be pig input we have that in single
brackets remember that's where the data
is in the hadoop file system where we
dumped it into there we're going to
using pig storage our data was separated
as with a comma so there's our comma
separator and then we have as in this
case we have an id character array name
character array profession character a
and age character ray and we're just
going to do them all as character arrays
just to keep this simple for this one
and then when i hit
put this all in here you can see that's
our full command line going in and we
have our semicolon at the end so when i
hit enter it's now set office up but it
hasn't actually done anything yet it
doesn't do anything until we do dump
office so there's our command to execute
whatever we've loaded or whatever setup
we have in here and we run that you can
see it go through the different
languages and this is going through the
map reduce remember we're not doing this
locally we're doing this on the hadoop
setup and once we finished our dump you
can see we have id name profession age
and all the information that we just
dumped into our pick oh we can now do
let's say oh let's say we have a request
just for we'll keep it simple in here
but just for the name and age and so we
can go office we'll call it each as our
variable underscore each and we'll say
for each office generate name comma h
and for each means that we're going to
do this for each row and if you're
thinking map reduce you know that this
is a map function because it's mapping
each row and generating name and age on
here and of course we want to go ahead
and close it with a semicolon and then
once we've created our query or the
command line in here let's go ahead and
dump office underscore each in with our
semicolon and this will go through our
map reduce uh setup on here and if we
were on a large cluster the same
processing time would happen in fact
it's really slow because i have multiple
things on this computer and this
particular virtual box is only using a
quarter of my processor it's only
dedicated to this and you can see here
there it is name and h and it also
included the top row since we didn't
delete that out of there or tell it not
to and that's fine for this example but
you need to be aware of those things
when you're processing a significantly
large amount of data or any data then we
can also do
office and we'll call this dsc for
descending so maybe the boss comes to
you and says hey can we order office by
id
descending and of course your boss
you've taught them how to uh your
shareholder it sounds a little
druggatory would say boss you've talked
to the shareholder and you said and
you've taught them a little bit of pig
latin and they know that they can now
create office description and we can
order office by id description and of
course once we do that we have to dump
office underscore description so that
it'll actually execute and there goes
into our map reduce we'll take just a
moment for it to come up because again
i'm running on only a quarter of my
processor and you can see we now have
our ids in descending order returned
let's also look at and this is so
important with anytime you're dealing
with big data let's create office with a
limit and you can of course do any of
this instead of with office we could do
this with office descending so you get
just the top two ids on there we're
going to limit just to two and of course
to execute that we have to dump office
underscore limit you can just think of
dumping your garbage into the pig pen
for the pig to eat there we go dump
office limit two and that's going to
just limit our office to the top two and
for our output we get our first row
which had our id name profession and age
and our second row which is jack who's
an engineer let's do an filter we'll
call it office underscore filter you
guessed it equals filter office by
profession equals and keep note this is
similar to how python does it with the
double equal signs for equal for doing a
true false statement so for your logic
statement remember to use two equal
signs in pig and we're going to say it
equals doctor so we want to find out how
many doctors do we have on our list and
we'll go ahead and do our dump we're
dumping all our garbage into the pig pen
and we're letting pig take over and see
what it can find out and see who's a
doctor on our list and we find
employee id number two bob is a doctor
30 years old for this next section uh
we're going to cover something we see a
lot nowadays in data analysis and that's
word counting tokenization that is one
of the next big steps as we move forward
in our data analysis where we go from
say stock market analysis of highs and
lows and all the numbers to what are
people saying about companies on twitter
what are they saying on the web pages
and on facebook suddenly you need to
start counting words and finding out how
many words are totaled how many are in
the first part of the document and so on
we're going to cover a very basic word
count
example and in this case i've created a
document called wordrose.txt
and you can see here we have simply
learn is a company supporting online
learning simply learn helps people
attain their certifications simply learn
is an online community i love simply
learn i love programming i love data
analysis and i went and saved this into
my documents folder so we could use it
and let me go ahead and open up a new
terminal window for our word count let
me go and close the old one so we're
going to go in here and instead of doing
this as pig we're going to do pig minus
x local and what i'm doing is i'm
telling the pig to start the pig shell
but we're going to be looking at files
local to our virtual box or this centos
machine and let me go ahead and hit
enter on there just maximize this up
there we go and it will load pig up and
it's going to look just the same as the
pig we were doing which was defaulted to
hot to our hadoop system to our hdfs
this is now defaulted to the local
system now we're going to create lines
we're going to load it straight from the
file remember last time we took the hdfs
and loaded it into there and then loaded
it into pig since we're going to local
we're just going to run a local script
we have lines equals load home the
actual full path home cloudera documents
and i called it wordrose.txt
and as line as a character array so each
line and i've actually you can change
this to read each document i certainly
have done a lot of document analysis and
then you go through and do word counts
and different kind of counts in there so
once we go ahead and create our line
instead of doing the dump we're going to
go ahead and start entering all of our
different setups for each of our steps
we want to go through and let's just
take a look at this next one because the
load is straightforward we're loading
from this particular file since we're
locals loading it directly from here
instead of going into the hadoop file
system and it says as and then each line
is read as a character array now we're
going to do words equal for each of the
lines generate flat tokenize
line space as word now there's a lot of
ways to do this this is if you're a
programmer you're just splitting the
line up by spaces there's actual ways to
tokenize it you look for periods
capitalization there's all kinds of
other things you play with with this but
for the most basic word count we're just
going to separate it by spaces the
flatten takes the line and just creates
a it flattens each of the words out so
this is we're just going to generate a
bunch of words for each line and then
each each of those words is as a word a
little confusing in there but if you
really think about it we're just going
down each line separating it out and
we're generating a list of words one
thing to note is the default for
tokenize you can just do tokenized line
without the space in there if you do
that it will automatically tokenize it
by space you can do either one and then
we're going to do group we're going to
group it by words so we're going to
group words by word so when we we split
it up each token is a word and it's a
list of words and so we're going to
group equals group words by word so
we're going to group all the same words
together and if we're going to group
them then we want to go ahead and count
them and so for count we'll go ahead and
create a word count variable and here's
our four each so for each grouped
grouped is our line where we group all
the words in the line that are similar
we're going to generate a group and then
we're going to count the words for each
group so for each line where you group
the words together we're going to
generate a group and that's going to
count the words we want to know the word
count in each of those and that comes
back in our word count and finally we
want to take this and we want to go
ahead and dump word count and this is a
little bit more what you see when you
start looking at grunt scripts you'll
see right here these these lines right
here we have each of the steps you take
to get there so we load our file for
each of our
lines we're going to generate and
tokenize it into words then we're going
to take the words and we're going to
group them by same words for each group
we're going to generate a group and
we're just going to count the words so
we're going to summarize all the words
in here and let's go ahead and do our
dump word count which executes all this
and it goes through our mapreduce it's
actually a local runner you'll see down
here you start seeing where they still
have mapreduce but as a special runner
we're mapping it that's a part of each
row being counted and grouped and then
when we do the word count that's the
reducer the reducer creates these keys
and you can see i is used three times a
came up once and came up once is to
continue on down here to attain online
people company analysis simply learn
they took the top rating with four
certification so all these things are
then counted in the how many words are
used in data analysis this is probably
the very the beginnings of data analysis
where you might look at it and say oh
they mentioned love
three times so whatever's going on in
this post it's about love and uh what do
they love and then you might attach that
to the different objects in here so you
can see that pig latin is fairly easy to
use there's nothing really you know it
may it takes a little bit to learn the
script depending on how good your memory
is as i get older my memory leaks a
little bit more so i don't memorize it
as much but that was pretty
straightforward the script we put in
there and then it goes through the full
map reduce localized run comes out and
like i said it's very easy to use that's
why people like pig latin is because
it's intuitive one of the things i like
about pig latin is when i'm
troubleshooting when we're
troubleshooting a lot of times you're
working with a small amount of data and
you start doing one line at a time and
so i can go lines equal load and there's
my loaded text and maybe i'll just dump
lines and then it's going to run it's
going to show me all the lines that i'm
working on in the small amount of data
and that way i can test that if i got an
error on there that said oh this isn't
working maybe they'll be oh my gosh i'm
in map reduce or i'm in the basic grunt
shell instead of the local path grunt
let's start with an introduction to
hbase back in the days data used to be
less and was mostly structured you see
we have structured data here we usually
had it like in a database where you had
every field was exactly the correct
length so if you had a name fill that
exactly 32 characters remember the old
access database and microsoft the files
are small if we had you know hundreds of
people in one database that was
considered big data this data could be
easily stored in relational database or
rdbms when we talk about relational
database you might think of oracle you
might think of sql microsoft sql mysql
all of these have evolved even from back
then to do a lot more today than they
did but they still fall short in a lot
of ways and they're all examples of an
rdms or relationship database then
internet evolved and huge volumes of
structured and semi-structured data got
generated and you can see here with the
semi-structured data we have email if
you look at my spam folder you know
we're talking about all the html pages
xml which is a lot of time is displayed
on our html and help desk pages json all
of this really has just even in the last
each year it almost doubles from the
year before how much of this is
generated so storing and processing this
data on an rdbms has become a major
problem and so the solution is we use
apache age base apache hbase was the
solution for this let's take a look at
the history the hbase history and we
look at the hbase history we're going to
start back in 2006 november google
released the paper on big table and then
in 2017 just a few months later age
based prototype was created as a hadoop
contribution later on in the year 2007
in october first usable hbase along with
the hadoop .15 was released and then in
january of 2008 hbase became the
subproject of hadoop and later on that
year in october all the way into
september the next year hbase was
released the .81 version the 0.19
version and 0.20 and finally in may of
2010 hbase became apache top level
project and so you can see in the course
of about four years hbase started off as
just an idea on paper and has evolved
all the way till 2010 as a solid project
under the apache and since 2010 has
continued to evolve and grow as a major
source for storing data in
semi-structured data so what is hbase
hbase is a column oriented database
management system derived from google's
nosql database bigtable that runs on top
of the hadoop file system or the hdfs
it's an open source project that is
horizontally scalable and that's very
important to understand that you don't
have to buy a bunch of huge expensive
computers you're expanding it by
continually adding commodity machines
and so it's a linear cost expansion as
opposed to being exponential no sql
database written in java which permits
faster querying so java is the back end
for the hbase setup and it's well suited
for sparse data sets so it can contain
missing or n a values and this doesn't
boggle it down like it would in other
database companies using hbase so let's
take a look and see who is using this uh
nosql database for their servers and for
storing their data and we have
hortonworks which isn't a surprise
because they're one of the like cloudera
hortonworks they are behind hadoop and
one of the big developments and backing
of it and of course apache hbase is the
open source behind it and we have
capital one as banks you also see bank
of america where they're collecting
information on people and tracking it so
their information might be very sparse
they might have one bank way back when
they collected information as far as the
person's family and what their income
for the whole family is and their
personal income and maybe another one
doesn't collect the family income as you
start seeing where you have data that is
very difficult to store where it's
missing a bunch of data hubspot's using
it facebook
certainly all of your facebook twitter
most of your social medias are using it
and then of course there's jp morgan
chase and company another bank that uses
the hbase as their data warehouse for
nosql let's take a look at an hbase use
case so we can dig a little bit more
into it to see how it functions
telecommunication company that provides
mobile voice and multimedia services
across china the china mobile and china
mobile they generate billions of call
detailed records or cdr and so these
cdrs and all these records are these
calls and how long they are and
different aspects of the call maybe the
tower they're broadcasted from all that
is being recorded so they can track it a
traditional database systems were unable
to scale up to the vast volumes of data
and provide a cost-effective solution no
good so storing and real-time analysis
of billions of call records was a major
problem for this company solution apache
hbase hbase stores billions of rows of
detailed call records hbc performs fast
processing of records using sql queries
so you can mix your sql and no sql
queries and usually just say no sql
queries because of the way the query
works applications of hbase one of them
would be in the medical industry hbase
is used for storing genome sequences
storing disease history of people of an
area and you can imagine how sparse that
is as far as both of those a genome
sequence might be only have pieces to it
that each person is unique or is unique
to different people and the same thing
with disease you really don't need a
column for every possible disease a
person could get you just want to know
what those diseases those people have
had to deal with in that area e-commerce
hbase is used for storing logs about
customer search history performs
analytics and target advertisement for
better business insights sports hba
stores match details in the history of
each match uses this data for better
prediction so when we look at hbase we
all want to know what's the difference
between hbase versus rdbms that is a
relational database management system
hbase versus rdbms so the hbase does not
have a fixed schema it's schema-less
defines only column families and we'll
show you what that means later on rdbms
has a fixed schema which describes the
structure of the tables and you can
think of this as you have a row and you
have columns and each column is a very
specific structure how much data can go
in there and what it does with the hbase
it works well with structured and
semi-structured data with the rdbms it
works only well with structured data
with the age base it can have
denormalized data it can contain missing
or null values with the rdbms it can
store only normalized data now you can
still store a null value in the rdbms
but it still takes up the same space as
if you're storing a regular value in
many cases and it also for the hbase is
built for y tables it can be scaled
horizontally for instance if you were
doing a tokenizer of words and word
clusters you might have 1.4 million
different words that you're pulling up
and combinations of words so with an
rdbms it's built for thin tables that
are hard to scale you don't want to
store 1.4 million columns in your sql
it's going to crash and it's going to be
very hard to do searches with the age
base it only stores that data which is
part of whatever row you're working on
let's look at some of the features of
the hbase it's scalable data can be
scaled across various nodes as it is
stored in the hdfs and always think
about this it's a linear add-on for each
terabyte of data i'm adding on roughly a
thousand dollars in commodity computing
with an enterprise machine uh we're
looking at about 10 000 at the lower end
for each terabyte of data and that
includes all your backup and redundancy
so it's a big difference it's like a
tenth of the cost to store it across the
hbase it has automatic failure support
right ahead log across clusters which
provides automatic support against
failure consistent read and write hbase
provides consistent read and write of
the data it's a java api for client
access provides easy to use java api for
clients block cache and bloom filters so
the hbase supports block caching and
bloom filters for high volume query
optimization let's dig a little deeper
into the hbase storage hbase column
oriented storage and i told you we're
going to look into this to see how it
stores the data and here you can see you
have a row key and this is really one of
the important references is each row has
to have its own key or your row id and
then you have your column family and in
here you can see we have column family
one column family two column family
three and you have your column
qualifiers so you can have in column
family one you can have three columns in
there and there might not be any data in
that so when you go into column family
one and do a query for every column that
contains a certain thing that row might
not have anything in there and not be
queried where in column family two maybe
you have column one filled out and
column three filled out and so on and so
forth and then each cell is connected to
the row where the data is actually
stored let's take a look at this at what
it looks like when you fill the data in
so in here we have a row key with a row
id and we have our employee id one two
three that's pretty straightforward you
probably would even have that on an sql
server and then you have your column
family this is where it starts really
separating out your column family you
might have personal data and under
personal data you would have name city
age you might have a lot more than just
that you might have number of children
you might have degree all those kinds of
different things that go under personal
data and some of them might be missing
you might only have the name and the age
of an employee you might only have the
name the city and how many children and
not the age and so you can see with the
personal data you can now collect a
large variety of data and store it in
the hbase very easily and then maybe you
have a family of professional data your
designation your salary all the stuff
that the employee is doing for you in
that company let's dig a little deeper
into the hbase architecture and so you
can see here what looks to be a
complicated chart it's not as
complicated as you think from the apache
a space we have the zookeeper which is
used for monitoring what's going on and
you have your h-master this is the hbase
master assigns regions and load
balancing and then underneath the region
or the hbase master then under the h
master or hbase master you have your
reader server serves data for read and
write and the region server which is all
your different computers you have in
your hadoop cluster you'll have a region
an h log you'll have a store memory
store and then you have your different
files for h file that are stored on
there and those are separated across the
different computers and that's all part
of the hdfs storage system so we look at
the architectural components or regions
and we're looking at we're drilling down
a little bit hbase tables are divided
horizontally by a row so you have a key
range into regions so each of those ids
you might have ids 1 to 20 21 to 50 or
whatever they are regions are assigned
to the nodes in the cluster called
region servers a region contains all
rows in the table between the region
start key and the end key again 1 to 10
11 to 20 and so forth these servers
serve data for read and write and you
can see here we have the client and the
get and then git sends it out and it
finds out where that start if it's
between which start keys and n keys and
then it pulls the data from that
different region server and so the
region sign data definition language
operation create delete are handled by
the h-master so the h-master is telling
it what are we doing with this data
what's going out there assigning and
reassigning regions for recovery or load
balancing and monitoring all servers so
that's also part of it so you know if
your ids if you have 500 ids across
three servers you're not going to put
400 ids on server 1 and 100 on the
server 2 and leaves region 3 and region
4 empty you're going to split that up
and that's all handled by the h master
and you can see here it monitors region
servers assigns regions to region
servers assigns regions to reason
servers and so forth and so forth hbase
has a distributed environment where
h-master alone is not sufficient to
manage everything hence zookeeper was
introduced it works with h-master so you
have an active h-master which sends a
heartbeat signal to zookeeper indicating
that it's active and the zookeeper also
has a heartbeat to the region servers so
the region servers send their status to
zoo keeper indicating they are ready for
read and write operation inactive server
acts as a backup if the active hmaster
fails it'll come to the rescue active
h-master and region servers connect with
a session to zoo keeper so you see your
active h-master selection region server
session they're all looking at the
zookeeper keeping that pulse an active
h-master region server connects with a
session to the zookeeper and you can see
here where we have ephemeral nodes for
active sessions via heartbeats to
indicate that the region servers are up
and running so let's take a look at
hbase read or write going on there's a
special hbase catalog table called the
meta table which holds the location of
the regions in the cluster here's what
happens the first time a client reads or
writes data to hbase the client gets the
region server the host the meta table
from zookeeper and you can see right
here the client has a request for your
region server and goes hey zookeeper can
you handle this the zookeeper takes a
look at it and goes ah metal location is
stored in zookeeper so it looks at its
metadata on there and then the metadata
table location is sent back to the
client the client will query the meta
server to get the region server
corresponding to the row key if it wants
to access the client caches this
information along with the midi table
location and you can see here the client
going back and forth to the region
server with the information and it might
be going across multiple region servers
depending on what you're querying so we
get the region server for row key from
the meta table that's where that row key
comes in and says hey this is where
we're going with this and so once it
gets a row key from the corresponding
region server we can now put row or git
row from that region server let's take a
look at the hbase meta table special
hbase catalog table that maintains a
list of all the region servers in the
hbase storage system so you see here we
have the meta table we have a row key
and a value table key region region
server so the meta table is used to find
the region for the given table key and
you can see down here you know meta
table comes in is going to fire out
where it's going with the region server
and we look a little closer at the right
mechanism in hbase we have right ahead
log or wall as you abbreviate it kind of
a way to remember wall is right ahead
log is a file used to store new data
that is yet to be put on permanent
storage it is used for recovery in the
case of failure so you can see here
where the client comes in and it
literally puts the new data coming in
into this kind of temporary storage or
the wall on there once it's gone into
the wall then the memory store memstor
is the right cache that stores a new
data that has not yet been written to
disk there is one mem store per column
family per region and once we've done
that we have three ack once the data is
placed in memstor the client then
receives
the acknowledgement when the mimstar
reaches the threshold it dumps or
commits the data into h file as you can
see right here we've taken our gun into
the wall the wall then source it into
the different memory stores and then the
memory stores it says hey we've reached
we're ready to dump that into our h
files and then it moves it into the h
files h files store the rows as data as
stored key value on disk so here we've
done a lot of theory let's dive in and
just take a look and see what some of
these commands look like and what
happens in our hbase when we're
manipulating a nosql setup
[Music]
so if you're learning a new setup it's
always good to start with where is this
coming from it's open source by apache
and you can go to hbase.apache
and you'll see that there is a lot of
information you can actually download
the hbase separate from the hadoop
although most people just install the
hadoop because it's bundled with it and
if you go in here you'll find a
reference guide and you can go through
the apache reference guide and there's a
number of things to look at but we're
going to be going through apache hbase
shell that's what we're going to be
working with and there's a lot of other
interfaces on the setup and you can look
up a lot of the different commands on
here so we go into the apache hbase
reference guide we can go down to read
hbase shell commands from a command file
you can see here where it gives you
different options of formats for putting
the data in and listing the data
certainly can also create files and
scripts to do this too but we're going
to look at the basics we're going to go
through this on a basic hbase shell and
one last thing to look at is of course
if you continue down the setup you can
see here where they have more detail as
far as how to create and how to get to
your data on your hbase now i will be
working in a virtual box and this is by
oracle you can download the oracle
virtual box you can put a note in below
for the youtube as we did have a
previous session on setting up virtual
setup to run your hadoop system in there
i'm using the cloudera quick start
installed in here there's hortons you
can also use the amazon web service
there's a number of options for trying
this out in this case we have cloudera
on the oracle virtualbox the virtual box
has linux centos installed on it and
then the hadoop has all the different
hadoop flavors including hbase and i
bring this up because my computer is a
windows 10 the operating system of the
virtual box is linux and we're looking
at the hbase data warehouse and so we
have three very different entities all
running on my computer and that can be
confusing if it's the first time in and
working with this kind of setup now
you'll notice in our cloudera up they
actually have some hbase monitoring so i
can go underneath here and click on
hbase and master and it'll tell me
what's going on with my region servers
it'll tell me what's going on with our
backup tables right now i don't have any
user tables because we haven't created
any and this is only a single node and a
single hbase tour so you're not going to
expect anything too extensive in here
since this is for practice and education
and perhaps testing out package you're
working on it's not for really you can
deploy cloudera of course but when you
talk about a quick start or a single
node setup that's what it's really for
so we can go through all the different
hbase and you'll see all kinds of
different information with zookeeper if
you saw it flash by down here what
version we're working in since zookeeper
is part of the hbase setup where we want
to go is we want to open up a terminal
window and in cloudera it happens to be
up at the top and when you click on here
you'll see your cloudera terminal window
open and let me just expand this so we
have a nice full screen and then i'm
also going to zoom in that way you have
a nice big picture and you can see what
i'm typing what's going on and to open
up your hbase shell simply type hbase
shell to get in and hit enter and you'll
see it takes just a moment to load and
we'll be in our hbase shell for doing
hbase commands once we've gotten into
our hbase shell you'll see it'll have
the hbase prompt information ahead of it
we can do something simple like list
this is going to list whatever tables we
have and it so happens that there's a
base table that comes with hbase now we
can go ahead and create and i'm going to
type in just create what's nice about
this is it's going to throw me kind of a
it's going to say hey there's no just
straight create but it does come up and
tell me all these different formats we
can use for create so we can create our
table
and one of our families you can add
splits names versions all kinds of
things you can do with this let's just
start with a very basic one on here and
let's go ahead and create and we'll call
it new
table now let's just call it new tbl for
table new table and then we also want to
do let's do knowledge so let's take a
look at this i'm creating a new table
and it's going to have a family of
knowledge in it and let me hit enter
it's going to come up it's going to take
it a second to go ahead and create it
now we have our new table in here so if
i go list you'll now see table and new
table so you can now see that we have
the new table and of course the default
table that's set up in here and we can
do something like uh describe we can
describe and then we're going to do new
tbl and when we describe it it's going
to come up it's going to say hey name i
have knowledge data block encoding none
bloom filter row replication scope
version all the different information
you need new minimum version zero
forever deleted cells false block size
in memory and you can look this stuff up
on apache.org to really track it down
one of the things that's important to
note is versions so you have your
different versions of the data that's
stored and that's always important to
understand that we might talk about that
a little bit later on and then we have
to describe it we can also do a status
the status says i have one active master
going on that's our hbase as a whole we
can do status
summary i should do the same thing as
status so we got the same thing coming
up and now that we've created let's go
ahead and put something in it so we're
going to put new tbl and then we want
row one you know what before i even do
this let's just type in put and you can
see when i type in put it gives us like
a lot of different options of how it
works and different ways of formatting
our data as it goes in and all of them
usually begin with the new table new tbl
then we have in this case we'll call it
row one and then we'll have knowledge
remember we created knowledge already
and we'll do knowledge
sports and then in knowledge and sports
we're going to set that equal to cricket
so we're going to put underneath this
our knowledge set up that we have a
thing called sports in there and we'll
see what this looks like in just a
second let's go ahead and put in we'll
do a couple of these let's see let's do
another row one and this time instead of
sports let's do science you know this
person not only you know we have row one
which is both knowledgeable and cricket
and also in chemistry so it's a chemist
who plays qriket in row one and uh let's
see if we have let's do another row one
just to keep it going and we'll do
science in this case let's do physics
not only in chemistry but also a
physicist i have quite a joy in physics
myself so here we go we have row one
there we go and then let's do uh row two
let's see what that looks like when we
start putting in row two and in row two
this person is has knowledge in
economics this is a master of business
and how or maybe it's global economics
maybe it's just for the business and how
it fits in with the country's economics
and that we call it macroeconomics so i
guess it is for the whole country there
so we have knowledge economics
macroeconomics and then let's just do
one more we'll keep it as row two and
this time our economist is also a
musician so we'll put music and they
happen to have knowledge and they enjoy
oh let's do pop music they're into the
current pop music going on so we've
loaded our database and you'll see we
have two rows row one and row two in
here and we can do is we can list the
contents of our database by simply doing
scan scan and then let's just do scan by
itself so you can see how that looks you
can always just type in there and it
tells you all the different setups you
can do with scan and how it works in
this case we want to do scan new tbl and
in our scan new tbl we have row one row
one row two row two and you'll see row
one has a column called knowledge
science time step value crickets value
physics so it has information as when it
was created when the time stamp is rule
one also has knowledge sports and a
value of cricket so we have sports and
science and this is interesting because
if you remember up here we also gave it
originally we told it to come in here
and have chemistry we had science
chemistry and science physics and we
come down here i don't see the chemistry
why because we've now replaced chemistry
with physics so the new value is physics
on here let me go ahead and clear down a
little bit and in this we're gonna ask
the question is enabled new table when i
hit enter in here you're gonna see it
comes out true and then we'll go ahead
and disable it let's go ahead disable
new
table make sure i have our quotes around
it and now that we've disabled it what
happens when we do the scan we do the
scan new table and hit enter you're
gonna see that we get an error coming up
so once it's disabled you can't do
anything with it until we re-enable it
now before we enable the table let's do
an alteration on it and here's our new
table and this should look a little
familiar because it's very similar to
create we'll call this test info we'll
hit enter in there it'll take just a
moment for updating and then we want to
go ahead and enable it so let's go ahead
and enable our new table so it's back up
and running and then we want to describe
describe
new table and we come in here you'll now
see we have name knowledge and under
there we have our data encoding and all
the information under knowledge and then
we also have down below test info so now
we have the name test info and all the
information concerning the test info on
here and we'll simply enable it new
table so now it's enabled oops already
did that i guess we'll enable it twice
and so let's start looking at well we
had scan new table and you can see here
it brings up the information like this
what if we want to go ahead and get a
row so we'll do r1 and when we do hbase
r1 you can see we have knowledge science
and it has a time stamp value physics
and we have knowledge sports and it has
a time stamp on it and value cricket and
then let's see what happens when we put
into our new
table and in here we want row one and if
you can guess from earlier because we
did something similar we're going to do
knowledge economics and then it's going
to be instead of i think it was what uh
macro economics is now market economics
and we'll go back and do our get command
and now see what it looks like and we
can see here where we have knowledge
economics it has a timestamp value
market economics physics and cricket and
this is because we have economics
science and sports those are the three
different columns that we have and then
each one has different information in it
and so if you manage to go through all
these commands and look at basics on
here you'll now have the ability to
create a very basic hbase setup nosql
setup based on your columns and your
rows
thank you guys now that we're done with
hadoop ecosystem we have shruti who will
take us to big data applications
before we move on to the applications
let's have a quick look at the big data
market revenue forecast worldwide from
2011 to 2027.
so here's a graph in which the y-axis
represents the revenue in billion us
dollars and the x-axis represents the
years as it is seen clearly from the
graph big data has grown until 2019 and
statistics predict that this growth will
continue even in the future this growth
is made possible as numerous companies
use big data in various domains to boost
their revenue we will look into few of
such applications the first big data
application we will look into is weather
forecast imagine there is a sudden storm
and you're not even prepared that would
be a terrifying situation isn't it
dealing with any calamities such as
hurricane storms floods would be very
inconvenient if we are caught off guard
the solution is to have a tool that
predicts the weather of the coming days
well in advance this tool needs to be
accurate and to make such a tool big
data is used so how does big data help
here well it allows us to gather all the
information required to predict the
weather information such as the climate
change details wind direction
precipitation previous weather reports
and so on after all this data is
collected it becomes easier for us to
spot a trend and identify what's going
to happen next by analyzing all of this
big data a weather prediction engine
works on this analysis it predicts the
weather of every region across the world
for any given time by using such a tool
we can be well prepared to face any
climate change or any natural calamity
let's take an example of a landslide and
try to understand how big data is used
to tackle such a situation predicting a
landslide is very difficult with just
the basic warning signs lack of this
prediction can cause a huge damage to
life and property this challenge was
studied by the university of melbourne
and they developed a tool which is
capable of predicting a landslide this
tool predicts the boundary where a
landslide is likely to occur two weeks
before this magical tool works on both
big data and applied mathematics an
accurate prediction like this which is
made two weeks before can save lives and
help in relocating people in that
particular region it also gives us an
insight into the magnitude of the
upcoming destruction this is how big
data is used in weather forecast and in
predicting any natural calamities across
the world let us now move on to our next
application that is big data application
in the field of media and entertainment
the media and the entertainment industry
is a massive one leveraging big data
here can produce sky-high results and
boost the revenue for any company let us
see the different ways in which big data
is used in this industry have you ever
noticed that you come across relevant
advertisements in your social media
sites and in your mailboxes well this is
done by analyzing all your data such as
your previous browsing history and your
purchase data publishers then display
what you like in the form of ads which
will in turn catch your interest in
looking into it next up is customer
sentiment analysis customers are very
important for a company the happier the
customer the greater the company's
revenue big data helps in gathering all
the emotions of a customer through their
posts messages conversations etc these
emotions are then analyzed to arrive at
a conclusion regarding the customer
satisfaction if the customer is unhappy
the company strives to do better the
next time and provides their customers a
better experience while purchasing an
item from an e-commerce site or while
watching videos on an entertainment site
you might have noticed a segment which
says most recommended list for you this
list is a personalized list which is
made available to you by analyzing all
the data such as your previous watch
history your subscriptions your likes
and so on recommendation engine is a
tool that filters and analyzes all this
data and provides you with a list that
you would most likely be interested in
by doing so the site is able to retain
and engage its customer for a longer
time next is customer churn analysis in
simple words customer churn happens when
a customer stops a subscription with a
service predicting and preventing this
is of paramount importance to any
organization by analyzing the behavioral
patterns of previously churned customers
an organization can identify which of
their current customers are likely to
churn by analyzing all of this data the
organization can then implement
effective programs for customer
retention let us now look into an use
case of starbucks big data is
effectively used by the starbucks app 17
million users use this app and you can
imagine how much data they generate data
in the form of their coffee buying
habits the store they visit and to the
time they purchase all of this data is
fed into the app so when a customer
enters a new starbucks location the
system analyzes all the data and they
are provided with their preferred order
this app also suggests new products to
the customer in addition to this they
also provide personalized offer and
discounts on special occasions moving on
to our next sector which is healthcare
it is one of the most important sectors
big data is widely used here to save
lives with all the available big data
medical researches are done very
effectively they are performed
accurately by analyzing all the previous
medical histories and new treatments and
medicines are discovered cure can be
found out even for few of the incurable
diseases there are cases when one
medication need not be effective for
every patient hence personal care is
very important personal care is provided
to each patient depending on their past
medical history an individual's medical
history along with their body parameters
are analyzed and personal attention is
given to each of them as we all know
medical treatments are not very pocket
friendly every time a medical treatment
is taken the amount increases this can
be reduced if readmissions are brought
down analyzing all the data precisely
will deliver a long-term efficient
result which will in turn prevent a
patient's readmission frequently with
globalization came an increase in the
ease for infectious diseases to spread
widely based on geography and
demographics big data helps in
predicting where an outbreak of epidemic
viruses are most likely to occur an
american healthcare company united
healthcare uses big data to detect any
online medical fraud activities such as
payment of unauthorized benefits
misrepresentation of data and so on the
healthcare company runs disease
management programs the success rates of
these programs are predicted using big
data depending on how patients respond
to it the next sector we will look into
is logistics logistics looks into the
process of transportation and storage of
goods the movement of a product from its
supplier to a consumer is very important
big data is used to make this process
faster and efficient the most important
factor in logistics is the time taken
for the products to reach their
destination to achieve minimum time
sensors within the vehicle analyze the
fastest route this analysis is based on
various data such as the weather traffic
the list of orders and so on by doing so
the fastest route is obtained and the
delivery time is reduced capacity
planning is another factor which needs
to be taken into consideration details
regarding the workforce and the number
of vehicles are analyzed thoroughly and
each vehicle is allocated a different
route this is done as there is no need
for many trucks to travel in the same
direction which will be pointless
depending on the analysis of the
available workforce and resources this
decision is taken big data analytics
also finds its use in managing
warehouses efficiently this analysis
along with tracking sensors provide
information regarding the underutilized
space which results in efficient
resource allocation and eventually
reduces the cost customer satisfaction
is important in logistics just like it
is in any other sector customer
reactions are analyzed from the
available data which will eventually
create an instant feedback loop a happy
customer will always help the company
gain more customers let us now look into
a use case of ups as you know ups is one
of the biggest shipping company in the
world they have a huge customer database
and they work on data every minute ups
uses big data to gather different kinds
of data regarding the weather the
traffic jams the geography the locations
and so on after collecting all this data
they analyze it to discover the best and
the fastest route to the destination in
addition to this they also use big data
to change the routes in real time this
is how efficiently ups leverages big
data next up we have a very interesting
sector that is the travel and tourism
sector the global tourism market is
expected to grow in the near future big
data is used in various ways in this
sector let us look into a few of them
hotels can increase their revenue by
adjusting the room tariffs depending on
the peak seasons such as holiday seasons
festive seasons and so on the tourism
industry uses all of this data to
anticipate the demand and maximize their
revenue big data is also used by resorts
and hotels to analyze various details
regarding their competitors this
analysis result helps them to
incorporate all the good facilities
their competitors are providing and by
doing so the hotel is able to flourish
further a customer always comes back if
they are offered good packages which are
more than just the basic ones looking
into a customer's past travel history
likes and preferences hotels can provide
its customers with personalized
experiences which will interest them
highly investing in an area which could
be the hub of tourism is very wise few
countries use big data to examine the
tourism activities in their country and
this in turn helps them discover new and
fruitful investment opportunities let us
look into one of the best online
homestay networks airbnb and see how big
data is used by them airbnb undoubtedly
provides its customers with the best
accommodation across the world big data
is used by it to analyze the different
kinds of available properties depending
on the customer's preferences the
pricing the keywords previous customers
ratings and experiences airbnb filters
out the best result big data works its
magic yet again now we will move on to
our final sector which is the government
and law enforcement sector maintaining
law and order is of utmost importance to
any government it is a huge task by
itself big data plays an active role
here and in addition to this it also
helps governments bring in new policies
and schemes for the welfare of its
citizens the police department is able
to predict criminal activities way
before it happens by analyzing big data
information such as the previous crime
records in a particular region the
safety aspect in that region and so on
by analyzing these factors they are able
to predict any activity which breaks the
law and order of the region governments
are able to tackle unemployment to a
great extent by using big data by
analyzing the number of students
graduating every year to the number of
relevant job openings the government can
have an idea of the unemployment rate in
the country and then take necessary
measures to tackle it our next factor is
poverty in large countries it is
difficult to analyze which area requires
attention and development big data
analytics makes it easier for
governments to discover such areas
poverty gradually decreases once these
areas begin to develop
governments have to always be on the
lookout for better development a public
survey voices the opinion of a country's
citizens analyzing all the data
collected from such service can help
governments build better policies and
services which will benefit its citizens
let us now move on to our use case did
you know that the new york police
department uses big data analytics to
protect its citizens the department
prevents and identifies crimes by
analyzing a huge amount of data which
includes fingerprints certain emails and
records from previous police
investigations and so on after analyzing
all of this data meaningful insights are
drawn from it which will help the police
in taking the required preventive
measures against crimes
thank you shruti let us now have a look
at the next data processing framework
spark we have our instructor ajay who
will take us through apache spark it's
installation welcome to this tutorial on
apache spark one of the most in demand
technologies and processing frameworks
in the big data world and here we will
learn on apache spark history of spark
what is spark hadoop which is a
framework again wes spark components of
apache spark that is spark core spark
sql spark streaming spark ml lab and
graphics then we will learn on spark
architecture applications of spark spark
use cases so let's begin with
understanding about history of apache
spark it all started in 2009 as a
project at uc berkeley amp labs by mate
in 2010 it was open source under a bsd
license in 2013 spark became an apache
top level project and in 2014 used by
data breaks to sort large-scale data
sets and it set a new world record so
that's how apache spark started and
today it is one of the most in-demand
processing framework or i would say in
memory computing framework which is used
across the big data industry so what is
apache spark let's learn about this
apache spark is a open source in-memory
computing framework or you could say
data processing engine which is used to
process data in batch and also in real
time across various cluster computers
and it has a very simple programming
language behind the scenes that is scala
which is used although if users would
want to work on spark they can work with
python they can work with scala they can
work with java and so on even r for that
matter so it supports all these
programming languages and that's one of
the reasons that it is called polyglot
wherein you have good set of libraries
and support from all the programming
languages and developers and data
scientists incorporate spark into their
applications or build spark based
applications to process analyze query
and transform data at a very large scale
so these are key features of apache
spark now if you compare hadoop wes
spark we know that hadoop is a framework
and it basically has map reduce which
comes with hadoop for processing data
however processing data using mapreduce
in hadoop is quite slow because it is a
batch oriented operation and it is time
consuming if you if you talk about spark
spark can process the same data 100
times faster than mapreduce as it is a
in-memory computing framework well there
can always be conflicting ideas saying
what if my spark application is not
really efficiently coded and my
mapreduce application has been very
efficiently coded well then it's a
different case however
normally if you talk about code which is
efficiently written for mapreduce or for
spark based processing spark will win
the battle by doing almost 100 times
faster than mapreduce so as i mentioned
hadoop performs batch processing and
that is one of the paradigms of map
reduced programming model which involves
mapping and reducing and that's quite
rigid so it performs batch processing
the intermittent data is written to sdfs
and written read back from sdfs and that
makes hadoop's map reduce processing
slower in case of spark it can perform
both batch and real-time processing
however a lot of use cases are based on
real time processing take an example of
macy's take an example of retail giant
such as walmart and there are many use
cases who would prefer to do real time
processing or i would say near real time
processing so when we say real time or
near real time it is about processing
the data as it comes in or you're
talking about streaming kind of data now
hadoop or hadoop's mapreduce obviously
was started to be written in java now
you could also write it in scala or in
python however if you talk about
mapreduce it will have more lines of
code since it is written in java and it
will take more times to execute you have
to manage the dependencies you have to
do the right declarations you have to
create your mapper and reducer and
driver classes however if you compare
spark it has few lines of code as it is
implemented in scala and scala is a
statically typed dynamically inferred
language it's very very concise and the
benefit is it has features from both
functional programming and
object-oriented language and in case of
scala whatever code is written that is
converted into byte codes and then it
runs in the jvm now hadoop supports
kerberos authentication there are
different kind of authentication
mechanisms kerberos is one of the
well-known ones and it can really get
difficult to manage now spark supports
authentication via a shared secret it
can also run on yarn leveraging the
capability of kerberos so what are spark
features which really makes it unique or
in demand processing framework when we
talk about spark features one of the key
features is fast processing so spark
contains resilient distributed data sets
so rdds are the building blocks for
spark and we'll learn more about rdds
later so spark contains rdds which saves
huge time taken in reading and writing
operations so it can be 100 times or you
can say 10 to 100 times faster than
hadoop when we say in memory computing
here i would like to make a note that
there is a difference between caching
and in memory computing think about it
caching is mainly to support read ahead
mechanism where you have your data
pre-loaded so that it can benefit
further queries however when we say in
memory computing we are talking about
lazy valuation we are talking about data
being loaded into memory only and only
when a specific kind of action is
invoked so data is stored in ram so here
we can say ram is not only used for
processing but it can also be used for
storage and we can again decide whether
we would want that ram to be used for
persistence or just for computing so it
can access the data quickly and
accelerate the speed of analytics now
spark is quite flexible it supports
multiple languages as i already
mentioned and it allows the developers
to write applications in java scala r or
python it's quite fault tolerance so
spark contains these rdds or you could
say execution logic or you could say
temporary data sets which initially do
not have any data loaded and the data
will be loaded into rdds only when
execution is happening so these can be
fault tolerant as
these rdds are distributed across
multiple nodes so failure of one worker
node in the cluster will really not
affect the rdds because that portion can
be recomputed so it ensures loss of data
it ensures that there is no data loss
and it is absolutely fault tolerant it
is for better analytics so sparked has
rich set of sql queries machine learning
algorithms complex analytics all of this
supported by various spark components
which we will learn in coming slides
with all these functionalities analytics
can be performed better in terms of
spark so these are some of the key
features of spark however there are many
more features which are related to
different components of spark and we
will learn about them so what are these
components of spark which i am talking
about spark core so this is the core
component which basically has rdds which
has a core engine which takes care of
your processing now you also have spark
sql so people who would be interested in
working on structured data or data which
can be structuralized would want to
prefer using spark sql and spark sql
internally has
components or features like data frames
and data sets which can be used to
process your structured data in a much
much faster way you have spark streaming
now that's again an important component
of spark which allows you to create your
spark streaming applications which not
only works on data which is being
streamed in or data which is constantly
getting generated but you would also or
you could also transform the data you
could analyze or process the data as it
comes in in smaller chunks you have
sparks mlib now this is basically a set
of libraries which allows developers or
data scientists to build their machine
learning algorithms so that they can do
predictive analytics or prescriptive
descriptive pre-emptive analytics or
they could build their recommendation
systems or bigger smarter machine
learning algorithms using these
libraries and then you have graphics so
think about organizations like linkedin
or say twitter where you have data which
naturally has a network kind of flow so
data which could be represented in the
form of graphs now here when i talk
about graphs i am not talking about pie
charts or bar charts but i am talking
about network related data that is data
which can be networked together which
can have some kind of relationship think
about facebook think about linkedin
where you have one person connected to
other person or one company connected to
other companies so if we have our data
which can be represented in the form of
network graphs then spark has a
component called graphics which allows
you to do graph based processing so
these are some of the components of
apache spark spark core spark sql spark
streaming spark ml lab and graphics so
to learn more about components of spark
let's learn here about spark core now
this is the base engine and this is used
for large scale parallel and distributed
data processing so when you work with
spark at least and the minimum you would
work with a spark core which has rdds as
the building blocks of your spark so it
is responsible for your memory
management your fault recovery
scheduling distributing and monitoring
jobs on a cluster and interacting with
storage systems so here i would like to
make a key point that spark by itself
does not have its own storage
it relies on storage now that storage
could be your sdfs that is hadoop's
distributed file system it could be
a database like nosql database such as
hbase or it could be any other database
say rdbms from where you could connect
your spark and then fetch the data
extract the data process it analyze it
so let's learn a little bit about your
rdds resilient distributed data sets now
spark core which is the base engine or
the core engine is embedded with the
building blocks of spark which is
nothing but your resilient distributed
data set so as the name says it is
resilient so it is existing for a
shorter period of time distributed so it
is distributed across nodes and it is a
data set where the data will be loaded
or where the data will be existing for
processing so it is immutable fault
tolerant distributed collection of
objects so that's what your rdd is and
there are mainly two operations which
can be performed on an rdd now to take
an example of this
say i want to process a particular file
now here i could write a simple code in
scala and that would basically mean
something like this so if i say val
which is to declare a variable i would
say val x and then i could use what we
call a spark context which is basically
the most important entry point of your
application so then i could use a method
of spark context for example that is
text file and then i could point it to a
particular file so this is just a method
of your spark context and spark context
is the entry point of your application
now here i could just give a path in
this method so what does this step do it
does not do any evaluation so when i say
val x i'm creating a immutable variable
and to that variable i'm assigning a
file now what this step does is it
actually creates
a rdd resilient distributed data set so
we can imagine this as a simple
execution logic a empty data set which
is created in memory of your note so if
i would say i have multiple notes in
which my data is split and stored
imagining that your yarn your spark is
working with hadoop so i have hadoop
which is using say two nodes and this is
my distributed file system sdfs which
basically means my file is written to
htfs and it also means that the file
related blocks are stored in the
underlying disk of these machines so
when i say val x equals sc dot text file
that is using a method of spark context
now there are various other methods like
whole text files parallel eyes and so on
this step will create an rdd so you can
imagine this as a logical data set which
is created in memory across these nodes
because these nodes have the data
however no data is loaded here so this
is the first rdd and i can say first
step in what we call as a tag a dag
which will have series of steps which
will get executed at later stage now
later i could do further processing on
this i could say val y and then i could
do something on x so i could say x
dot map and i would want to apply a
function to every record or every
element in this file and i could give a
logic here x dot map now this second
step is again creating an rdd a
resilient distributed data set you can
say second step in my dag okay and here
you have a external rdd one more rdd
created which depends on the first rtd
so my first rdd becomes the base rdd or
parent rtd and the resultant rtd becomes
the child rdd then we can go further and
we could say val zed and i would say
okay now i would want to do some filter
on y so this filter which i am doing
here and then i could give a logic might
be i'm searching for a word i am
searching for some pattern so i could
say val z equals
y dot filter which again creates one
more rdd a resilient distributed data
set in memory and a you can say this is
nothing but one more step in the dag so
this is my tag which is a series of
steps which will be executed now here
when does the execution happen when the
data get when will the data get loaded
into these rdds so all of this that is
using a method using a transformation
like map using a transformation like
filter or flat map or anything else
these are your
transformations so the operations such
as map filter join union and many others
will only create rdds which basically
means it is only creating execution
logic no data is evaluated no operation
is happening right now only and only
when you invoke an action that is might
be you want to print some result might
be you want to take some elements and
see that might be you want to do a count
so those are actions which will actually
trigger the execution of this dag right
from the beginning so if i here say z
dot count where i would want to just
count the number of words which i am
filtering this is an action which is
invoked and this will trigger the
execution of dag right from the
beginning so this is what happens in a
spark now if i do a z dot count again it
will start the whole execution of dag
again right from the beginning so my z
dot count second time in action is
invoked again the data will be loaded in
the first rtd then you will have map
then you will have filter and finally
you will have result
so this is the core concept of your rdds
and this is how rtd works so mainly in
spark there are two kind of operations
one is your transformations and one is
your actions transformations or using a
method of spark context will always and
always create an rtd or you could say a
step in the tag actions are something
which will invoke the execution which
will invoke the execution from the first
rdd till the last rdd where you can get
your result so this is how your rdds
work now when we talk about components
of spark let's learn a little bit about
spark sql so spark sql is a component
type processing framework which is used
for structured and semi-structured data
processing so usually people might have
their structured data stored in rdbms or
in files where data is structured with
but particular delimiters and has a
pattern and if one wants to process this
structured data if one wants to
use spark to do in-memory processing and
work on this structured data they would
prefer to use spark sql so you can work
on different data formats say csv json
you can even work on smarter formats
like avro parque even your binary files
or sequence files you could have your
data coming in from an rdbms which can
then be extracted using a jdbc
connection so at the bottom level when
you talk about spark sql it has a data
source api which basically allows you to
get the data in whichever format it is
now spark sql has something called as
data frame api so what are data frames
data frames in short you can visualize
or imagine as rows and columns or if
your data can be represented in the form
of rows and columns with some column
headings so data frame api allows you to
create data frames so like my previous
example when you work on a file when you
want to process it you would convert
that into an rdd using a method of smart
context or by doing some transformations
so in the similar way when you use data
frames or when you want to use spark sql
you would use
sparks context which is sql context or
hive context or spark which allows you
to work with data frames so like in my
earlier example we were saying val x
equals sc dot text file now in case of
data frames instead of sc you would be
using say spark dot something so spark
context is available for your data
frames api to be used in older versions
like spark 1.6 and so on we were using
hive context or sql context so if you
were working with spark 1.6 you would be
saying val x equals sql context dot here
we would be using spark dot so data
frame api basically allows you to create
data frames out of your structured data
which also lets spark know that data is
already in a particular structure it
follows a format and based on that your
sparks back-end dag scheduler right so
when i say about that i talk about your
sequence of steps so spark is already
aware of
what are the different steps involved in
your application so your data frame api
basically allows you to create data
frames out of your data and data frames
when i say i'm talking about rows and
columns with some headings
and then you have your data frame dsl
language or you can use spark sql or
hive query language any of these options
can be used to work with your data
frames so to learn more about data
frames follow in the next sessions when
you talk about spark streaming now this
is very interesting for organizations
who would want to work on streaming data
imagine a store like macy's where they
would want to have machine learning
algorithms now what would these machine
learning algorithms do suppose you have
a lot of customers walking in the store
and they are
searching for particular product or
particular item so there could be
cameras placed in the store and this is
being already done there are cameras
placed in the store which will keep
monitoring in which corner of the store
there are more customers now once camera
captures this information this
information can be streamed in to be
processed by algorithms and those
algorithms will see which product or
which series of product customers might
be interested in and if this algorithm
in real time can process based on the
number of customers based on the
available product in the store it can
come up with a attractive alternative
price so that which the price can be
displayed on the screen and probably
customers would buy the product now this
is a real-time processing where the data
comes in algorithms work on it do some
computation and give out some result and
which can then result in customers
buying a particular product so the whole
essence of this machine learning and
real-time processing will really hold
good if and when customers are in the
store or this could relate to even an
online shopping portal where there might
be machine learning algorithms which
might be doing real time processing
based on the clicks which customer is
doing based on the clicks based on
customer history based on customer
behavior algorithms can come up with
recommendation of products or better
altered price so that the sale happens
now in this case we would be
seeing the essence of real time
processing only in a fixed or in a
particular duration of time and this
also means that you should have
something which can process the data as
it comes in so spark streaming is a
lightweight api that allows developers
to perform batch processing and also
real time streaming and processing of
data so it provides secure reliable fast
processing of live data streams so what
happens here in spark streaming in brief
so you have a input data stream now that
data stream could be a file which is
constantly getting appended it could be
some kind of metrics it could be some
kind of events based on the clicks which
customers are doing or based on the
products which they are choosing in a
store this input data stream is then
pushed in through a spark streaming
application now spark streaming
application will broke break this
content into smaller streams what we
call as disk criticized streams or
batches of smaller data on which
processing can happen in frames so you
could say process my file every five
seconds for the latest data which has
come in now there are also some windows
based uh
options like when i say windows i mean a
window of past three events window of
past three events each event being of
five seconds so your batches of smaller
data is processed by spark engine and
this process data can then be stored or
can be used for further processing so
that's what spark streaming does when
you talk about mlib it's a low level
machine learning library that is simple
to use scalable and compatible with
various programming languages now hadoop
also has some
libraries like you have apache mahout
which can be used for machine learning
algorithms however in terms of spark we
are talking about machine learning
algorithms which can be built using ml
labs libraries and then spark can be
used for processing so ml lib eases the
deployment and development of scalable
machine learning algorithms i mean think
about your clustering techniques
so think about your classification where
you would want to classify the data
where you would want to do supervised or
unsupervised learning think about
collaborative filtering and many other
data science related techniques or
techniques which are required to build
your recommendation engines or machine
learning algorithms can be built using
sparks mlip graphics is spark's own
graph computation engine so this is
mainly if you are interested in doing a
graph based processing think about
facebook think about linkedin where you
can have your data which can be stored
and that data
has some kind of network connections or
you could say it is well networked i
could say x is connected to y y is
connected to z
z is connected to a so x y z a all of
these are in terms of graph
terminologies we call as vertices or
vertex which are basically being
connected and the connection between
these are called edges so i could say a
is friend to b so a and b are vertices
and friend a relation between them is
the edge now if i have my data which can
be represented in the form of graphs if
i would want to do a processing in such
way this could be not only for social
media it could be for your network
devices it could be a cloud platform it
could be about different applications
which are connected in a particular
environment so if you have data which
can be represented in the form of graph
then graphics can be used to do etl that
is extraction transformation load to do
your data analysis and also do
interactive graph computation so
graphics is quite powerful now when you
talk about spark your spark can work
with your different clustering
technologies so it can work with apache
mesos that's how spark came in where it
was initially to prove the credibility
of apache mesos spark can work with yarn
which is usually you will see in
different working environments spark can
also work as standalone that means
without hadoop spark can have its own
setup with master and worker processes
so usually or you can say technically
spark uses a master slave architecture
now that consists of a driver program
that can run on a master node it can
also run on a client node it depends on
how you have configured or what your
application is
and then you have multiple executors
which can run on worker nodes so your
master node has a driver program and
this driver program internally has the
spark context so your spark every spark
application will have a driver program
and that driver program has a inbuilt or
internally used spark context which is
basically your entry point of
application for any spark functionality
so your driver or your driver program
interacts with your cluster manager now
when i say interacts with cluster
manager so you have your spark context
which is the entry point that takes your
application request to the cluster
manager now as i said uber cluster
manager could be say apache mesos it
could be yarn it could be spark
standalone master itself so your cluster
manager in terms of yarn is your
resource manager
so your spark application internally
runs as series or set of tasks and
processes your driver program wherever
that is run will have a spark context
and spark context will take care of your
application execution how does that do
it spark context will talk to cluster
manager so your cluster manager could be
yarn and in terms of when i say cluster
manager for yarn would be resource
manager so at high level we can say a
job is split into multiple tasks and
those tasks will be distributed over the
slave nodes or worker nodes so whenever
you do some kind of transformation or
you use a method of spark context and
rdd is created and this rdd is
distributed across multiple nodes as i
explained earlier worker nodes are the
slaves that run different tasks so this
is how a spark architecture looks like
now we can learn more about spark
architecture and its interaction with
yarn so usually what happens when your
spark context interacts with the cluster
manager so in terms of yarn i could say
resource manager now we already know
about yarn so you would have say node
managers running on multiple machines
and each machine has some ram and cpu
cores allocated for your node manager on
the same machine you have the data nodes
running which obviously are there to
have the hadoop related data so whenever
the application wants to process the
data your application via spark context
contacts the cluster managers that is
resource manager now what does resource
manager do resource manager makes a
request so resource manager makes
requests to the node manager of the
machines wherever the relevant data
resides asking for containers so your
resource manager is negotiating or
asking for containers from node manager
saying hey can i have a container of 1gb
ram and 1 cpu core can i have a
container of 1gb ram and 1 cpu core and
your node manager based on the kind of
processing it is doing will approve or
deny it so node manager would say fine i
can give you the container and once this
container is allocated or approved by
node manager resource manager will
basically start an extra piece of code
called appmaster so appmaster is
responsible for execution of your
applications whether those are spark
applications or mapreduce so your
application master which is a piece of
code will run in one of the containers
that is it will use the ram and cpu core
and then it will use the other
containers which were allocated by node
manager to run the tasks so it is within
this container which can take care of
execution so what is a container a
combination of ram and cpu core so it is
within this container we will have a
executor process which would run and
this executor process is taking care of
your application related tasks so that's
how overall spark works in integration
with yarn now let's learn about this
spark cluster managers as i said spark
can work in a standalone mode so that is
without hadoop so by default application
submitted to spark standalone mode
cluster will run in fifo order and each
application will try to use all the
available nodes so you could have a
spark standalone cluster which basically
means you could have multiple nodes on
one of the nodes you would have the
master process running and on the other
nodes you would have the spark worker
processes running so here we would not
have any distributed file system because
spark is standalone and it will rely on
an external storage to get the data or
probably the file system of the nodes
where the data is stored and processing
will happen across the nodes where your
worker processes are running you could
have spark working with apache mesos now
as i said apache mesos is a open source
project to manage your computer clusters
and can also run hadoop applications
apache mesos was introduced earlier and
spark came in and has existence to prove
the credibility of apache mesos you can
have spark working with hadoop's yarn
this is something which widely you will
see in different working environments so
yarn which takes care of your processing
and can take care of different
processing frameworks also supports
spark you could have kubernetes now that
is something which is making a lot of
news in today's world it is a open
source system for automating deployment
scaling and management of containerized
applications so where you could have
multiple docker based images which can
be connecting to each other so spark
also works with kubernetes now let's
look at some applications of spark so
jpmorgan chase and company uses spark to
detect fraudulent transactions analyze
the business spends of an individual to
suggest offers and identify patterns to
decide how much to invest and where to
invest so this this is one of the
examples of banking a lot of banking
environments are using spark due to its
real-time processing capabilities and
in-memory faster processing where they
could be working on fraud detection or
credit analysis or pattern
identification and many other use cases
alibaba group that uses also spark to
analyze large data sets of data such as
real-time transaction details now that
might be based online or in the stores
of looking at the browsing history in
the form of spark jobs and then provides
recommendations to its users so alibaba
group is using spark in its e-commerce
domain you have iq via now this is a
leading healthcare company that uses arc
to analyze patients data identify
possible health issues and diagnose it
from their medical history so there is a
lot of work happening in healthcare
industry where real time processing is
finding a lot of importance and real
time and faster processing is what is
required so healthcare industry and iqvi
is also using spark you have netflix
which is known and you have riot games
so entertainment and gaming companies
like netflix and ride games use apache
spark to showcase relevant
advertisements to their users the videos
that they have watched shared or liked
so these are few domains which find use
cases of spark that is banking
e-commerce healthcare entertainment and
then there are many more which are using
spark in their day-to-day activities for
real time in memory faster processing
now let's discuss about the sparks use
case and let's talk about conviva which
is world's leading video streaming
companies so video streaming is a
challenge now if you talk about youtube
which has data you could always read
about it so youtube has data which is
worth watching 10 years so there is huge
amount of data where people are
uploading their videos or companies are
doing advertisements and this
videos are streamed in or can be watched
by users so video streaming is a
challenge and especially with increasing
demand for high quality streaming
experiences conviva collects data about
video streaming quality to give their
customers visibility into the end user
experience they are delivering now how
do they do it apache spark again using
apache spark conviva delivers a better
quality of service to its customers by
removing the screen buffering and
learning in detail about network
conditions in real time this information
is then stored in the video player to
manage live video traffic coming in from
4 billion video feeds every month to
ensure maximum retention now using
apache spark conviva has created an auto
diagnostics alert it automatically
detects anomalies along the video
streaming pipeline and diagnoses the
root cause of the issue now this really
makes it one of the leading video
streaming companies based on auto
diagnostic alerts it reduces waiting
time before the video starts it avoids
buffering and recovers the video from a
technical error and the whole goal is to
maximize the viewer engagement so this
is sparks use case where conviva is
using spark in different ways to stay
ahead in video streaming related
deliveries so let's have a quick demo on
setting up spark on windows and trying
out the sparks interactive way of
working for this first thing is you will
have to download spark now you can just
go to google and type spark download and
once you click on this link it shows you
a spark release a package type which
says pre-built so we will have to get a
pre-built apache hadoop related spark so
here i will choose say spark 2.4.3 and i
will choose pre-built for apache 2.6 and
then i can just click and download on
the spark 2.4.3
bin hadoop 2.6 star file once you click
on this link takes you to the mirror
site and you can just click on this link
and download spark 2.4.3
once this is done which i have already
downloaded here i can go to my downloads
and it shows that i have a tar file now
we will have to untie it or unzip it so
i can click on this link and i already
have winzip which allows me to unzip
spark
2.4.3 i can choose a location so i can
say unzip click on unzip choose local
and then i can choose one of my folders
so i have already unzipped it here and
that's how my spark 2.4.4
directory exists here 2.4.3 i'm sorry
now let's go and look into this
directory and what it contains so i can
click on c drive and then spark 2.4.3
and this has the folders which are
required for us to use spark if you look
in bin we have different applications
and commands which we can use and if you
also see i would have added
one of the utilities here either we can
have the vin utils because spark will
need hadoop and we are planning to use
spark on windows so what we need is this
so i have in my desktop a hadoop
directory which has a bin folder and
here i have downloaded a win utils
executable file which you can always
search on internet and you can say
download win
utils.exe for spark 64-bit and then you
can find the link from where you can
download this for example we can click
on this and here we can search for
win utils so here we have the link i can
open this link in a different tab and
this basically shows me when utils for
hadoop 2.7.1 similarly you can search
for hadoop 2.6 and you can download
however 2.7 will also work fine now i
have downloaded winutils.exe
and that's in this hadoop folder within
bin i have this so we need two things
here one is spark which is untard and in
a particular location and then your
hadoop which has been and this has been
utils now once you have these things you
can set your environment variables by
just type in envir go to your edit
system environment variables click on
environment variables and here if you
see i have added two variables so you
can just click on new and then you can
give your variable name as hadoop
underscore home and then you can give
the path where you have your hadoop
directory that contains bin and that
contains
winyutil.exe i also have added spark
home which points to myspark directory
now once you have this you are ready to
use your spark on windows in local mode
once this is done i can open up my
command prompt and here i need to go to
my spark directory i can just say cd
spar 2.4.3
and then i can do a dir slash p which
shows me the folders where we have been
so to execute spark we can look into
what our bin has and it has different
programs such as you have spark shell to
work with scala and in an interactive
way of working with spark you can also
use pi spark which allows you to use
python to work with spark and you also
have spark submit if you have packaged
your application in a jar file to submit
it on a cluster so in this case we would
be using spark in a local mode so let's
use spark shell and test it so i can
just say spark shell in this way to
start my spark in an interactive way now
based on the path which you have set for
your vinnutils.exe
and spark shell you should be able to
use spark so it says welcome to spark
version 2.4.3
it also shows that spark context which
is the entry point of your application
is available as sc wherein it is
connecting to master as local and it has
an application id it also shows you a
spark ui which you can look at and it
says spark session is available as spark
so if you are interested in working with
spark core that is with rdds we would be
using spark context and if you are
interested in working with spark sql
that is data frames and data sets then
we can be using spark session so let's
try it out so we can declare a variable
that is a immutable variable and now i
will use spark context with a method of
spark context so i could just do a tab
to see what are the available options
within your spark context and here we
can use one of them to read a file so i
will use sc.text file and then i need to
point to a file so i already know that
in my spark directory i have a file
called readme dot rd and this is the
method
of spark context if i enter it will
create a rdd now as i've explained about
rdds these are resilient distributed
data sets there is no evaluation
happening right now so even if this file
does not exist i would still have an rdd
created now i can go further and do some
more transformations on this so i could
say val y and then i could say take x i
would like to do a map transformation on
it and i would use to uppercase now this
is a inbuilt function where i would want
to convert the content of this file into
uppercase when i hit on enter it again
creates an rdd and this rdd is basically
a child rdd of the parent rtd created by
text file remember here we don't have
any evaluation happening or any
execution happening it has just
transformations which will lead to
creation of further rdds now we can
invoke an action to see the result and
whenever you invoke an action it will
trigger the execution of your dag
starting from your first rdd till the
last transformation you did before
invoking an action so i could just say
count to see how many lines it has and
once i do this it says input path does
not exist it is not able to find a file
in this location so this clearly
explains that there was no evaluation
happening when we did this when we tried
to read a file and neither when we did a
map transformation only and only when we
invoked an action it tried to search for
file in this location so let's quit this
and check if the file exists to quit you
can just do a control d or you could do
a colon quit now here if you see some
messages like this which says unable to
delete temporary file so that's a known
issue we can fix that but my spark is
working fine now let's go and check if
the file exists so i will go in here and
then i will look in my spark directory
to see if the file exists so this is the
file readme dot md however i had done
readme dot rd so let's do it again and
let's test if our spark shell works fine
so we can go into the spark directory by
just doing this and then either i could
be going into bin directory and then
start spark shell or some people prefer
to do it this way wherein you can say
bin spark
shell and that should start your spark
shell but there was an error in the in
the slash so let's do it this way and
this will start your spark shell an
interactive way of working with your
spark and using spark context or spark
now once we have done this i can again
say val x and i can say sc which is
spark context which is already
initialized when you start your spark
shell i can say text file and i would
want to read a file which is readme dot
md now we know that this file exists
however the checking of the file
existing or not that means an evaluation
does not happen when you do a
transformation or when you use a method
of spark context it just creates an rdd
click on this and this has created an
rdd of string now we can do further
transformation on x by saying map and
then i can say i would want to convert
the content into uppercase and that's
also done now finally let's invoke an
action which will trigger the execution
of my tag which contains these rdds so i
could just say y and i could say take 10
and i could say for each print ln and
this should be able to invoke an action
and it shows me the result from the file
which is converted into uppercase
remember if i do a y dot count which is
another action it will trigger the
execution of dag right from the
beginning where the first rtd was
created the transformation will be done
and then it will show me the count of
lines which exist
as a result of this so we can do this
and this says me that there are 105
lines this is a simple example of using
spark shell and using spar in an
interactive way on your windows machine
now to quit we can always do a colon
quit or we could do a control d and that
basically takes you out of your spark
shell similarly we can work on pi spark
by just saying dot slash
bin
slash pi spark and that's python's way
of working with spark which brings your
python shell it starts the spark context
which is available as sc and if you are
interested in working on data frames or
data sets using spark sql then we would
be using spark now here i can just
declare a variable x and i can just do
sc.text file like what we did using
scala we can be referring to the same
file readme dot md and this has created
an rdd you can just type in x and that
shows the rdd which was created you can
then further do some transformation on
it using x dot
map and then i could say i would want to
convert this to uppercase now in case of
python you would normally use
lambda if you would want to do any kind
of transformation so i would say lambda
x and then i would want to convert this
to uppercase so here we can check if my
rdd was correctly created and as i was
saying we can then do some
transformation on it so i can say again
y equals and then i would want to do
some transformation on x i would say x
dot map so in case of python as i
explained whenever we want to use an
anonymous function or we want to do some
transformation then we can pass in the
function to the transformation so here i
can say lambda and then i can just say
line or i could say x or a whatever that
is and i could say line i would use a
inbuilt function that is upper which
should convert the content of x to
uppercase now remember we are just doing
some transformations here so if i click
on y again and enter sorry if i enter y
it will show me that that has created an
rdd to see the content i can just say y
dot collect and that should show me the
content of first few lines which is
converted in uppercase so this clearly
shows that we can even use python to
work with spark by using pi spark now to
quit this we can just say quit and that
should take you out of your pi spark
shell so this is how you work on spark
shell or pi spark on your windows
machine so this has a local spark setup
or basically spark running in a local
mode and you could be using the
interactive way of working with spark
now if we have packaged our application
in a jar file then i could be using
spark submit to submit my application
how do we do that for this we can
basically bring up one of our ides so in
my case i'm using eclipse and i can get
into my eclipse now there are two
options here one we can be writing code
in your ide that is eclipse we can be
compiling the code based on the spark
related jars and then we can run our
application from ide which would
interact with your spark that's one way
the second way is we can use packaging
tools like sbt to package our
application as jar and then push the jar
to your local spark or a hadoop base
park and then run it using spark submit
now this is a simple sample application
for which i have
set up certain things here the first
thing is when you have downloaded
eclipse for all the people who are new
they might have to add the scala plugin
now if you see here in my eclipse it
shows up java perspective and it shows
scala perspective now how did i get this
you can click on help and you can say
install new software and here you can
say add you can say scala ide and then
you will have to give a link from where
you can get the scala ide how do i get
that so i can go to my browser and i can
say scala ide dot org and once you go to
this link just scroll down click on
stable and that shows you different
releases for your different ides now for
eclipse although this shows for oxygen
and i have eclipse neon but that works
fine you can just copy this link and
here once you have copied the link give
the location here and you can say okay
now once you do that it shows you
different options from where you can
choose color ide for eclipse now in my
case it is already installed so these
options don't show up however if you do
not have this option for example let's
choose something else say i will say
scala
search and once i do this next gets
activated so scala id is already
installed in my case so i can click on
next and this should basically get scala
search plugin also which can be added to
my eclipse now once this is done you
will be prompted to restart your eclipse
and then you should have your scala
perspective so for now i'll just cancel
this because i already have my scala id
dot eclipse so this is done i'll just do
a cancel here now once you have your
scala id or scala plugin added to your
ide you can always click on this icon
here and here you can just click double
click on scala that will open up scala
perspective so that's the first thing
then you can always click on file new
and create a scalar project for example
i could say my test apps and then i can
just say finish so it has added a
project now what we need to do is we
need to make sure that our setup is fine
so first thing i would suggest is click
on this go to your build path and here
click on configure build path so where
it says color compiler it would be good
to choose for your project settings
instead of 2.12 go for 2.11 so sometimes
you might have problems with scala 2.12
which might not be able to compile for
your scala 2.11 so use latest 2.11
bundle and then you can say apply it
says compiler settings have changed a
full rebuild is required for changes to
take effect shall all projects be clean
now we can say okay and we can say okay
so this will build your workspace to use
scala 2.11 bundle now once that is done
second thing what we need is we would
want to write our code and we would want
our code to compile for that as i said
if we want to write our code using an
ide and then run it from our ide rather
than using a build tool like maven or
svt i can just add the spark related
jars to my build path so i can right
click here i can say build path and i
can click on configure build path and
here where it says libraries i can say
add external charts now this needs my
spark related jars now where do i find
it so remember we have downloaded spark
so you can even find it there so you can
click on
wherever your spark is and then you can
click for jars which shows you all spark
related jars you can just do a control a
and just add it to your build path say
apply and then just say okay so once
this is done you have already added the
spark related jars which might be good
enough for you to write an application
once this is done we need to basically
go ahead and write our code now how do i
do that i can just click on source and i
can say new and then i can say package
and here you can say main dot scala
click on finish and that has created
main dot scalar so that would be source
main slash scala in the folders we can
always check that so i can go to c drive
i can look in
users win 10 and then look in my
workspace for my project and if you see
in source we have main and we have scala
now this is where we will be writing our
code so for this then i can just right
click and i can say new and i can just
create an object and i can give it a
name so we can say test app and then we
can say finish so in case of scala and
spark we need to create an object and
then we need to define main class here
once that is done we also need to import
some packages and we need to initialize
the spark context now for that you can
take an example here so i have already
written the code and i can look in the
source
main scala and i have created an app
called firstapp.scala now here we have
the package name we are importing some
packages which are required for us to
initialize part context and spark
configuration so it is part context
sparkconf and here is my object and for
a particular project at least one of
your object or one of your application
needs to be the main so we define the
main here by saying def main args and
array of string then we need to
basically define our spark context
so i'm creating a configuration object
here and then i say new spark conf i am
setting my application name to hello
spark and then this is very important if
you intend to run your spark application
either using spark submit or from your
id you need to specify your master as
local now that could be given with one
thread or multiple threads so this is my
configuration and then i initialize my
spark context pointing to my
configuration so this is the most
important part here now if you see this
is something which i showed you in the
command line so i'm doing a val x and
i'm pointing it to a file in my project
directory which is abc1.txt
so this is just to make sure that you
are giving a windows path and you are
giving the right escape characters now
if it would be if you intend to run this
application on a hadoop based cluster
then you will have to give the path of
the file accordingly which we can see
later so here i have val x i'm pointing
it to a file which i have created here
and this just contains three lines this
is my sample file which i want to test
this is a new file now here i've created
a variable called x further i would say
val y and i would use spark context
method text file like what we did in
interactive way and i'm pointing it to x
i'm also using some extra features like
caching so that i can cache the rdd
which gets created further i create a
variable called counts and then i do it
flat map transformation on y where i
would split the content based on space i
would do a map transformation where i
would get every word from the file and
map it with number one and finally i do
a reduce by key operation once this is
done i do a saves as text file now i
could do a collect i could do a take i
could do a count and i could also do a
save as text file where i would want my
output to be saved in this location plus
i'm using a java utility to append a
random number to my output directory
finally i do a spark context stop so
this is my application and if you see
here my application completely compiles
because i've already added the relevant
jar files in the build path now once
this application is done we need to run
this but before doing that we need to
look into our run configurations so you
can click on run configurations and here
i'm giving my project name i'm
specifying my main class which is first
app then you can straight away go to
environment and here i have added two
variables one is spark underscore local
underscore ip which points to this
machine's local host and then i've said
hadoop underscore home because spark
even when you're running locally would
want if hadoop is existing so we can
just set hadoop underscore home and i am
pointing it to my desktop hadoop
directory which contains bin folder and
that bin folder contains a winnutils.exe
once this is done we are fine and then i
can test my application by just clicking
on run now this should trigger my
application on my windows machine using
my ide i didn't have to package this as
jar and here
my application is completed which should
have created one additional directory
here so i can click on this i can right
click and i can try doing a refresh and
here you see a new output is created we
can look into this it has a part file
which shows my word count so this is a
simple example of setting up your ide
and running your applications from ide
on a local spark now what you also see
is a build file here what is that for so
in case
you would want to
create a project and you would want to
package the application as a jar file
and then run it on the cluster using
spark submit now in that case we can
avoid adding the jars to my build path
but what i would need is i would need
build dot sbt file within my project
folder remember if you intend to package
your application as a jar and then run
it on a cluster or on a local setup you
would not need the build related jars
however the build related jars which are
already here will not cause any harm let
them be there now we have a build.sbt
file also which is existing in my
project folder now just for this run i
can in fact delete this target directory
it will be anyways recreated and if you
would want we can also clean up these
just to avoid the confusion i will
delete these now i just have my project
folder and i have the libraries i have
abc1.txt and i have a build.sbt file
what does that contain so this basically
has a name i'm giving a version which
will be appended to my jar i'm saying
the scala version which i'm using which
is 2.11.8 and i'm saying spark version
which is
2.2.0 you can replace these with the
version which you intend to use other
than that we are pointing to the
different spark components and the
relevant dependency related jars which
your sbt can get for you so i have given
spark core spark sql mlib spark
streaming and spark hive which will be
then fetched from the repository so this
is my
build.sbt file which exists in my
project folder we have our code written
we have our build dot sbt file which is
already existing in my project folder my
code is already fine now we need to use
sbt to package my applications into jar
for which you will have to download sbt
so you can just say download sbt windows
and that should take you to the
installing svt on windows page now here
you can just download the msi installer
and run through the installer which will
basically install sbt on your machine
now i have already done that so my build
file is ready my code is ready all i
need to do is now use sbt so what i can
do is from my command line i can just
say
cd and i will go into users i'll go into
win10 and i'll go into my workspace now
here i can see for my projects and i can
go into my spark apps now once i'm in my
project folder we can double check that
it has a build.sbt which is fine sbt is
already installed on this machine and i
can just say sbt if you would want to
check you can always do sbt version to
check if you have sbt and this command
is also done once you install sbt for
the first time you can always do sbt
version and before displaying it was
displaying sbt's version it will try to
fix all your dependencies it will try to
get all the relevant dependencies so
this is just to check that sbt is
installed on my machine as i said my
code is already ready i have a build.sbt
file and i can just say sbt package
which then we'll refer to build.sbt will
look for your code in source main scala
and then if everything is fine it will
package it as jar and it will create
folders within your project folder we
can click on this we can try doing a
refresh to see now if you see here the
project was again created a target
folder is created within scala 2.11 i
will have my jar created so we can see
that my sbt was fine it has packaged the
code and it has created a jar file as
simple project 2.11 -1 which can be used
to run on the cluster or in a local mode
let's check in eclipse i'll click on
this and i'll just do a refresh and
i see my jar is already existing which
basically means then we can do a spark
submit so this is where we see that i am
already running a spark submit command
now this might show up some error
messages but we can see how we did this
so if you see here once my packaging was
done i went into my spark folder i did a
bin slash spark submit i mentioned my
jar file and then i said my class main
dot scala dot first app so this is my
app and this is how i'm using spark
submit to submit an application which is
running in local mode so we can see
further if it starts processing so here
it says created local directory then it
starts an executor on localhost it goes
for execution and then if we see further
we could also see it will add our jar to
the class path and then finally it
should be doing the execution now if
there is any error message that might be
related to your file not being deleted
or if there is any problem with executor
so we can basically come back and check
here if there was any specific error so
it the error was that it tries to delete
a temp directory but it does not have
the permissions so we have not done that
but as per my application it should be
creating a output in this folder as park
out so let's click on this and see i'll
do a refresh right and if you see a new
spark output has been created previous
sessions we have seen how we can set up
spark on windows or set up our spark
related ide so that we can run our
applications on windows now here we have
a quick demo on setting up spark as a
standalone cluster on ubuntu machines
and then trying out spark way of working
for which we need at least two machines
and here i have ubuntu machines set up
um1 and um2 just to give insights on how
my machines look so if i look in my etc
host i have the ip address of multiple
machines so i can ping one machine to
other machine by just doing a ping um2
and that should work fine similarly i
have also set up ssh access for these
machines both of the machines have hdu
as the user and i can just do a ssh um2
and that logs me into the second machine
without a password similarly i can check
the same thing from my second machine by
doing a ssh um one and that works fine
too so we need two machines which can
ping each other firewall disabled able
to ssh each other so that we can set up
a standalone cluster of spark how do we
do it so first thing is we will have to
download the spark related tar file now
i can just go to google and i can type
in spark 2.2.1
download now that's what i'm interested
in and this takes you to spark release
2.2.1 however here it shows you the
latest release is 2.4 and then
2.4.2 so what we can do is we can go to
archives so i can basically look at
existing versions now here i can click
on download and this shows me a spark
release and also pre-built for apache
hadoop now what we can also do is we can
go to release archives for an older
stable version i click on this and here
i have spark
2.2.1 now i can click on this and we can
either install something which is not
already built or we can download this
one which is spark 2.2.1 bin hadoop 2.6
point t g z so you click on this link
and then save this file which i have
already done and here if you see in my
machine i have home hdu downloads which
has my different packages which i have
downloaded also if you notice i have
downloaded jdk8 so you can check on my
machines so apart from machines being
able to ping each other and being able
to do a ssh we also need machines to
have java which is already installed
once this is done now i have my spark
related package so i go into user local
directory and then you can give a
command here that is sudo tar xvf home
sdu downloads and then give your spark
package now once you do this this will
untar the spark directory and create a
directory in my user local location if
you see here this is the directory which
is created but you also see that there
is a spark link which is pointing to
spark now that is because if you would
want to work on a newer version of spark
you could just do the same thing for
newer version and then make your link
pointing to the newer version of spark
how do you create a link you can just
say sudo ln minus s you can give your
spark directory and then you can create
a link so i've already created a link
and my spark path will then become this
now what do we do with this once we have
done this once we have created a link we
can go into the bash file of my user and
if you carefully see here i have given
my java path so that i can execute java
related commands and i have also added
my spark related path here which says
user local spark so in case you would be
changing your spark version to a latest
one you will not have to change things
in your batch file only thing you will
have to do is unlink the existing spark
link and create a new link to your newer
version so this is done on this machine
and now i can basically be using spark
now before doing that we can go into
user local spark and this has different
directories so if you look in bin these
has a binaries programs like your pi
spark your spark shell spark sql and
spark submit which we will see how we
can use here if you look in sbin it has
other startup scripts to start your
history server or to start your master
or worker processes if you look in conf
this has your config directories now
here by default you might see spark
minusdefault.conf.template
i have renamed that to dot conf slaves
template has been renamed to slaves so
let's look into this so i can go into
conf and then i will look in spark
default conf now here based on our setup
now here we intend to set up a spark
standalone cluster that is without
hadoop but i would want to have a spark
standalone distributed cluster so i have
uncommented this property it says
spark.master and i say spark and i also
mentioned that my master will run on
this machine which is um one spark event
log dot enabled is true because we would
want to track the events i have
mentioned a directory so this is a local
directory in user local spark and we
will have to create it it talks about
the default serializer it talks about
the driver memory which was by default 5
gigabyte i have reduced it to 2 gigabyte
gigabyte based on my machine
configuration you have java options and
then if you intend to run a history
server so that whenever your spark
application is complete you will have
your application stored in history
server i have given the log directory
which is user local spark and then
application history and this also needs
to be created we have spark history
provider for the class which takes care
of history server and the update
interval of looking for your
applications so this is what we have in
our spark default and if you look in
slaves i have given the machines where i
would want my worker processes to run so
that is um1 and um now once you have
made your changes in your spark default
conf and slaves file what you can simply
do is scp assuming that whatever was
done on this machine that is untarring
your spark directory creating a link
updating your bash rc and
renaming your config files same steps
need to be done on the second machine
and your second machine would also be
prepared to be used for your spark
cluster so once you have both the
machines which can ping each other which
can ssh each other both of the machines
have java both of the machines have the
same spark version downloaded and the
basic setup done i can just easily copy
the spark related config from here into
my other machine that is sdu um 2 and
then i can give a path which is user
local spark conf and in this way i don't
need to edit my config files again and
similarly i can even copy the slaves
file this is all we need to basically
have our spark standalone cluster now
since we have updated our bash rc we can
give our spark command from anywhere we
have set up our config files so i can
just do a start minus all dot sh and
that based on my config files based on
the directories which are mentioned it
will start my master process and my
worker process
on both the machines so here we have a
spark standalone cluster which has two
workers and one master now we can always
go to the browser interface and we can
check for the spark ui which should be
available by typing in http
slash my master and then the port is
so this shows that i have a spark master
running i have two worker processes
right now there are no applications
which are running but my spark ui is
already available when we start using
spark either by spark shell or pi spark
or even spark submit we will see our
applications getting populated here
additionally we can also start the start
history server by just saying start
history server dot sh and that will
start my history server once this is
done we have a history server also
running and we can go back and then we
can again pull out the history server
user interface by giving in the port
which is default
18080 so i have a spark standalone
cluster with one master two workers and
also a history server which is running
once we have this we can try working
with spark either with spark shell or pi
spark or if you have packaged your
application as a jar using sbt or mevin
you could also use spark submit
additionally you could also use spark
sql so to work with spark i would just
say spark shell on one of my machines
both my machines which have worker
processes running we can start a spark
shell on any of these machines remember
here our spark will rely on the storage
of these machines that is the file
system because it does not have any
hadoop or distributed file system we
have started our spark shell and that
shows spark context which is available
as sc spark session is available as
spark so to work with spark core and
rdds we would be using spark context and
if you intend to work with spark sql
that is data frames and data sets you
can be using spark let's try this quick
simple example so i'll say val x sc dot
text file and now i would want to point
it to a file so i will say the complete
path remember i am giving the spark
command from my home directory so i will
have to say user local spark and then i
can point to a file which is existing
here and this is what i would want to
use to do some processing we are using
the first step here wherein we are using
a method of spark context which will not
relate in any evaluation and it will
just create an rdt now we are using the
scala's way so let's create one more
variable and then we can do some
transformation on it by saying to upper
case i would just want to convert the
content into uppercase and this is again
a transformation so that will just
create an rdd once this is done we can
invoke an action to basically see some
results so i could just simply do a
collect which is an action and this
action will trigger the execution of dag
which starts from the farthest rtd that
is the first step where your file is
loaded into rdd now once we do this we
should be able to see our result and
that basically is execution of dag so
from the time we have used a text file
which is a method of spark context 2 we
did a transformation until we invoked an
action becomes my one job now if i would
do y dot count which is again a
different action this will trigger the
execution of tag right from the
beginning that is sc.text file where the
data will again be loaded in rdd a map
transformation will happen and then you
will have a count now we can always see
this in the spark ui by just going in
here and just doing a refresh so that
will show me that there is an
application which is running via spark
shell it has utilized three cores it has
utilized memory per executor one
gigabyte and we can click on this
application which shows that it used
both the workers one core and one gb on
this worker and two cores and memory on
this worker i can click on application
detail ui wherein i can see what are the
actions i invoked we also see the number
of tasks which are run and that is
because every rdd which is created by
default is having two partitions and for
each partition you would have one task
well we can change the partitions and
many more things can be done but that
you can learn in later sessions here we
have two jobs one ended with collect and
one ended with count now i can click on
collect and i can see the dag
visualization which tells me we started
a text file we did a map and finally we
did a collect it shows that everything
was done in state 0 that is just one
stage i can click on count and that
again shows me the dag visualization
which is a different stage a different
job id which started with text file map
and then we did account if you would
want to see more details you can always
use these tabs to look at different
stages within your application if you
were doing some caching looking at
environment variables and also to see
how many executors were used including
the one for the driver on which nodes
these executor ran how many cores how
many tasks were run was there any
shuffling involved and so on so this is
how i have used spark shell that is an
interactive way of running my
application and since we have a spark ui
we can always look at applications when
they have run and we can always drill
down and know more details now since my
application is completed i can do a
refresh on history server but that does
not show anything because when we
started a spark shell it started an
application and that application is
still in running status if you see here
under running applications so this is
how we use spark shell on a standalone
spark cluster now we can just do a colon
quit and that takes me out of spark
shell similarly if i would want to work
on pi spark that is python's way of
working with spark i can just type in pi
spark which should bring my python shell
and then i can continue working with
spark and again go back and look at my
ui while my pi spark comes up i can go
here since i quit my spark shell i can
just do a refresh to see if my
application is yet coming up in history
server it might take some time and you
can always go back and look at
incomplete applications or wait till
your application is populated in history
server now if i do a refresh here on
spark ui it says this application was
completed it says finished and then now
we have started pi spark so it has
started a new application pi spark shell
and that is in running status we can
come back here and now we have our
python sway so i can do the same thing
which i did in scala using sc.text
file i will point it to a file which
exists in user local spark read me dot
md so that's the file which i'm
interested in now this would have
created an rdd which we can confirm by
just typing in x now i can create a
different variable and i can say i would
want to do a transformation of map now
in case of python when you use anonymous
functions or when you want to apply some
functions to your transformations you
use lambda functions so we say lambda
line and then i would say what i want to
do to the line i will say i will use a
inbuilt uppercase upper function which
should convert my content into uppercase
but as of now this is a transformation
so it only creates an rdd to see the
result i can do a y dot collect and that
should bring up my result now in case if
it says the file does not exist that is
because there was a typo here and we can
repeat this step so let's bring up here
again x and i can give the right name of
the file i can do a transformation and
finally i can see the result so this is
using pi spark on a standalone spark
cluster which is working without hadoop
which has two worker nodes and one
master node we can always come and do a
refresh here to look at more details so
we have our application we can click on
this again similarly like we did for
scala application detail ui i see my
application ended at collect it ran two
tasks and i can look at my tag so this
is how we can use
spark shell or pi spark thank you ajay
now we have rahul who will tell us how
to become a big data engineer now let's
find out who is a big data engineer a
big data engineer is a professional who
develops maintains tests and evaluates
the company's big data infrastructure in
other words develop big data solutions
based on a company's requirements they
maintain these solutions they test out
these solutions as to the company's
requirements they integrate this
solution with the various tools and
systems of the organization and finally
they evaluate how well the solution is
working to fulfill the company's
requirements next up let's have a look
at the responsibilities of a big data
engineer now they need to be able to
design implement verify and maintain
software systems now for the process of
ingesting data as well as processing it
they need to be able to build highly
scalable as well as robust systems they
need to be able to extract data from one
database transform it as well as load it
into another data store with the process
of etl or the extract transform load
process and they need to research as
well as propose new ways to acquire data
improve the overall data quality and the
efficiency of the system now to ensure
that all the business requirements are
met they need to build a suitable data
architecture they need to be able to
integrate several programming languages
and tools together so that they can
generate a structured solution they need
to build models that reduce the overall
complexity and increase the efficiency
of the whole system by mining data from
various sources and finally they need to
work well with other teams ones that
include data architects data analysts
and data scientists next up let's have a
look at the skills required to become a
big data engineer the first step is to
have programming knowledge one of the
most important skills required to become
a big data engineer is that of
experience with programming languages
especially hands-on experience now the
big data solutions that organizations
would want you to create will not be
possible without experience in
programming languages i can even tell
you an easy way through which you can
get experience with programming
languages practice practice and more
practice some of the most commonly used
programming languages used for big data
engineering are python java and c plus
plus the second skill that you require
is to have in-depth knowledge about dbms
and sql you need to know how data is
maintained as well as managed in a
database you need to know how sql can be
used to transform as well as perform
actions on a database and by extension
know how to write sql queries for any
relational database management systems
some of the commonly used database
management systems for big data
engineering mysql oracle database and
the microsoft sql server the third skill
that you require is to have experience
working with etl and warehousing tools
now you need to know how to construct as
well as use a data warehouse so that you
can perform the etl operation or the
extract transform and load operations
now as a big data engineer you'll be
constantly tasked with extracting
unstructured data from a number of
different sources transforming it into
meaningful information and loading it
into other data storages databases or
data warehouses now what this is is
basically aggregating unstructured data
from multiple sources analyzing it so
that you can take better business
decisions some of the tools used for
this purpose are talent ibm data stage
pentaho and informatica next up we have
the fourth skill that you require which
is knowledge about operating systems now
since most big data tools have unique
demands such as root access to operating
system functionality as well as hardware
having a strong understanding of
operating systems like linux and unix is
absolutely mandatory some of the
operating systems used by big data
engineers are unix linux and solaris now
the fifth skill that you require to have
experience with hadoop based analytics
since hadoop is one of the most commonly
used tools when it comes to big data
engineering it's understood that you
need to have experience with apache
hadoop based technologies technologies
like hdfs hadoop mapreduce apache edge
base hive and pig the sixth skill that
you require is to have worked with
real-time processing frameworks like
apache spark now as a big data engineer
you'll have to deal with vast volumes of
data so for this data you need an
analytics engine like spark which can be
used for large-scale real-time data
processing now spark can process live
streaming data from a number of
different sources like facebook
instagram twitter and so on it can also
perform interactive analysis and data
integration and now we're at our final
skill requirement which is to have
experience with data mining and modeling
so as a data engineer you'll have to
examine massive pre-existing data so
that you can discover patterns as well
as new information with this you'll
create predictive models for your
business so that you can make better
informed decisions some of the tools
used for this are r rapidminer weka and
nine now let's talk about a big data
engineer's salary as well as other roles
they can look forward to now the average
salary of a big data engineer in the
united states is approximately ninety
thousand dollars per year now this
ranges from sixty six thousand dollars
all the way to hundred and thirty
thousand dollars per annum in india the
average salary is around seven lakh
rupees and ranges from four lakhs to
thirteen lakhs per annum after you
become a big data engineer some of the
job roles that you can look forward to
are that of a senior big data engineer a
business intelligence architect and a
data architect now let's talk about
certifications that a big data engineer
can opt for first off we have the
cloudera ccp data engineer a cloudera
certified professional data engineer
possesses the skills to develop reliable
and scalable data pipelines that result
in optimized data sets for a variety of
workloads it is one of the industry's
most demanding performance-based
certification ccp evaluates and
recognizes a candidate's mastery of the
technical skills most sought after by
employers the time limit for this exam
is 240 minutes and it costs 400 next we
have the ibm certified data architect
big data certification an ibm certified
big data architect understands the
complexity of data and can design
systems and models to handle different
data variety including structured
semi-structured unstructured volume
velocity veracity and so on a big data
architect is also able to effectively
address information governance and
security challenges associated with the
system this exam is 75 minutes long and
finally we have the google cloud
certified data engineer a google
certified data engineer enables data
driven decision decision-making by
collecting transforming and publishing
data they should also be able to
leverage deploy and continuously train
pre-existing machine learning models the
length of the certification exam is two
hours and its registration fee is 200
now let's have a look at how simply
learn can help you become a big data
engineer
simply learn provides the big data
architect masters program this includes
a number of different courses like big
data hadoop and spark developer apache
spark in scala mongodb developer and
administrator big data and hadoop
administrator and so much more this
course goes through 50 plus in demand
skills and tools 12 plus real life
projects and the possibility of an
annual average salary of 19 to 26 lakh
rupees per annum it will also help you
get noticed by the top hiring companies
this course will also go through some
major tools like kafka apache spark
flume edge base mongodb hive pig
mapreduce java scala and much more now
why don't you head over to
simplylearn.com and get started on your
journey to get certified and get thank
you rahul now we will have a look at the
hadoop interview questions and answers
our instructor ajay will guide us
through it one single machine with huge
amount of disks and huge amount of ram
but then the time taken to read that
data when all the data is stored in one
machine would be very high and that
would be with least fault tolerance if
you talk about sdfs your data is
distributed so sdfs stands for hadoop
distributed file system so here your
data is distributed and maintained on
multiple systems so it is never one
single machine it is also supporting
reliability so whatever is stored in
hdfs say a file being stored depending
on its size is split into blocks and
those blocks will be
spread across multiple nodes not only
that every block which is stored on a
node will have its replicas stored on
other nodes replication factor depends
but this makes sdfs more reliable in
cases of your slave nodes or data nodes
crashing you will rarely have data loss
because of auto replication feature now
time taken to read the data is
comparatively more as you might have
situations where your data is
distributed across the nodes and even if
you are doing a parallel read your data
read might take more time because it
needs coordination from multiple
machines however if you are working with
huge data which is getting stored it
will still be beneficial in comparison
to reading from a single machine so you
should always think about its
reliability through auto replication
feature its fault tolerance because of
your data getting stored across multiple
machines and its capability to scale so
when you talk about sdfs we are talking
about horizontal scalability or scaling
out when you talk about regular file
system you are talking about vertical
scalability which is scaling up
now let's look at some specific sdfs
questions what is this why is sdfs fault
tolerant now as i just explained in
previous slides your sdfs is fault
tolerant as it replicates data on
different data nodes so you have a
master node and you have multiple slave
nodes or data nodes where actually the
data is getting stored now we also have
a default block size of 128 mb that's
the minimum since hadoop version 2. so
any file which is up to 128 mb would be
using one logical block and if the file
size is bigger than 128 mb then it will
be split into blocks and those blocks
will be stored across multiple machines
now since these blocks are stored across
multiple machines it makes it more fault
tolerant because even if your machines
fail you would still have a copy of your
block existing on some other machine now
there are two aspects here one we talk
about the first rule of replication
which basically means you will never
have two identical blocks sitting on the
same machine and the second rule of
replication is in terms of rack
awareness so if your machines are placed
in racks as we see in the right image
you will never have all the replicas
placed on the same rack even if they are
on different machines so it has to be
fault tolerant and it has to maintain
redundancy so at least one replica will
be placed on some other node on some
other rack that's how sdfs is fault
tolerant now here let's understand the
architecture of sdfs now as i mentioned
earlier you would in a hadoop cluster
the main service is your hdfs
so for your sdfs service you would have
a name node which is your master process
running on one of the machines and you
would have data nodes which are your
slave machines getting stored across or
getting or the processes running across
multiple machines each one of these
processes has an important role to play
when you talk about sdfs whatever data
is written to hdfs that data is split
into blocks depending on its size and
the blocks are randomly distributed
across nodes with auto replication
feature these blocks are also
auto replicated across multiple machines
with the first condition that no two
identical blocks will sit on the same
machine now as soon as the cluster comes
up your data nodes which are part of the
cluster and based on config files would
start sending their heartbeat to the
name node and this would be every three
seconds what does name node do with that
name node will store this information in
its ram so name node starts building a
metadata in its ram and that metadata
has information of what are the data
nodes which are available in the
beginning now when a data
writing activity starts and the blocks
are distributed across data nodes data
nodes every 10 seconds will also send a
block report to name note so name node
is again adding up this information in
its ram or the metadata in ram which
earlier had only data node information
now name node will also have information
about what are the files the files are
split in which blocks the blocks are
stored on which machines and what are
the file permissions now while name node
is maintaining this metadata in ram name
node is also maintaining metadata in
disk now that is what we see in the red
box which basically has information of
whatever information was written to hdfs
so to summarize your name node has
metadata in ram and metadata in disk
your data nodes are the machines where
your blocks or data is actually getting
stored and then there is a auto
replication feature which is always
existing unless and until you have
disabled it and your read and write
activity is a parallel activity however
replication is a sequential activity now
this is what i mentioned about when you
talk about name node which is the master
process hosting metadata in disk and ram
so when we talk about disk it basically
has a edit log which is your transaction
log and your fs image which is your file
system image right from the time the
cluster was started this metadata in
disk was existing and this gets appended
every time read write or any other
operations happen on sdfs
metadata in ram is dynamically built
every time the cluster comes up which
basically means that if your cluster is
coming up name node in the initial few
seconds or few minutes would be in a
safe mode which basically means it is
busy registering the information from
data nodes so name node is one of the
most critical processes if name node is
down and if all other processes are
running you will not be able to access
the cluster
name nodes metadata in disk is very
important for name node to come up and
maintain the cluster name nodes metadata
in ram is basically for all or
satisfying all your client requests now
when we look at data nodes as i
mentioned data nodes hold the actual
data blocks and they are sending these
block reports every 10 seconds so the
metadata in name nodes ram is constantly
getting updated and metadata in disk is
also constantly getting updated based on
any kind of write activity happening on
the cluster now data node which is
storing the block will also help in any
kind of read activity whenever a client
requests so whenever a client or an
application or an api would want to read
the data it would first talk to name
node name node would look into its
metadata on ram and confirm to the
client which machines could be reached
to get to that data that's where your
client would try to read the data from
sdfs which is actually getting the data
from data nodes and that's how your read
write requests are satisfied now what
are the two types of metadata in name
node server holds as i mentioned earlier
metadata in disk very important to
remember edit log nfs image metadata in
ram which is information about your data
nodes files files being split into
blocks blocks residing on data nodes and
file permissions so i will share a very
good link on this and you can always
look for more detailed information about
your metadata so you can search for sdfs
metadata directories explained now this
is from hortonworks however it talks
about the metadata in disk which name
node manages and details about this so
have a look at this link if you are more
interested in learning about metadata on
disk coming back
let's look at the next question what is
the difference between federation and
high availability now these are the
features which were introduced in hadoop
version 2. both of these features are
about
horizontal scalability of name node so
prior to version 2 the only possibility
was that you could have one single
master which basically
means that your cluster could become
unavailable if name node would crash so
hadoop version 2 introduced two new
features federation and high
availability however high availability
is a popular one so when you talk about
federation it basically means any number
of name nodes so there is no limitation
to the number of name nodes your name
nodes are in a federated cluster which
basically means name nodes
still belong to the same cluster but
they are not coordinating with each
other so whenever a write request comes
in one of the name node picks up that
request and it guides that request for
the blocks to be written on data nodes
but for this your name node does not
have to coordinate with other name node
to find out if the block id which was
being assigned was the same one as
assigned by other name node so all of
them belong to a federated cluster they
are linked via a cluster id so whenever
an application or an api is trying to
talk to cluster it is always going via
an cluster id and one of the name node
would pick up the read activity or write
activity or processing activity so all
the name nodes are sharing a pool of
metadata in which each name node will
have its own dedicated pool and we can
remember that by a term called namespace
or name service so this also provides
high fault tolerance supposed your one
name node goes down it will not affect
or make your cluster unavailable you
will still have your cluster reachable
because there are other name nodes
running and they are available now when
it comes to heartbeats all your data
nodes are sending their heart beats to
all the name nodes and all the name
nodes are aware of all the data nodes
when you talk about high availability
this is where you would only have two
name nodes so you would have an active
and you would have a standby now
normally in any environment you would
see a
high availability setup with zookeeper
so zookeeper is a centralized
coordination service so when you talk
about your active and standby name notes
election of a name node to be made as
active and taking care of an automatic
failover is done by your zookeeper high
availability can be set up without
zookeeper but that would mean that the
admins intervention would be required to
make a name node as active from standby
or also to take care of failover
now at any point of time in high
availability a active name node would be
taking care of storing the edits about
whatever updates are happening on sdfs
and it is also writing these edits to a
shared location standby name node is the
one which is constantly looking for
these latest updates and applying to its
metadata which is actually a copy of
whatever your active name node has so in
this way your standby name node is
always in sync with the active name node
and if for any reason active name node
fails your standby name node will take
over and become the active remember
zookeeper plays a very important role
here it's a centralized coordination
service one more thing to remember here
is that in your high availability
secondary name node will not be allowed
so you would have an active name node
and then you will have a standby name
node which will be configured on a
separate machine and both of these will
be having access to a shared location
now that shared location could be nfs or
it could be a quorum of general nodes so
for more information refer to the
tutorial where i have explained about
sdfs high availability and federation
now let's look at some logical question
here so if you have a input file of 350
mb which is obviously bigger than 128 mb
how many input splits would be created
by sdfs and what would be the size of
each input split so for this you need to
remember that by default the minimum
block size is 128 mb now that's
customizable if your environment has
more number of larger files written on
an average then obviously you have to go
for a bigger block size if your
environment has a lot of files being
written but these files are of smaller
size you could be okay with 128 mb
remember in hadoop every entity that is
your directory on sdfs file on sdfs and
a file having multiple blocks each of
these are considered as objects and for
each object hadoop's name nodes ram 150
bytes is utilized so if your block size
is very small then you would have more
number of blocks which would directly
affect the name node's ram if you keep a
block size very high that will reduce
the number of blocks but remember that
might affect in processing because
processing also depends on splits more
number of splits
more the parallel processing so
setting of block size has to be done
with consideration about your
parallelism requirement and your name
nodes ram which is available now coming
to the question if you have a file of
350 mb that would be split into three
blocks and here two blocks would have
128 mb data and the third block although
the block size would still be 128 it
would have only 94 mb of data so this
would be the split of this particular
file now let's
understand about rack awareness how does
rack awareness work or why do we even
have racks so organizations always would
want to place their nodes or machines in
a systematic way there can be different
approaches you could have a rack which
would have machines running on the
master processes and the intention would
be that this particular rack could have
higher bandwidth more cooling dedicated
power supply top of rack switch and so
on the second approach could be that you
could have one master process running on
one machine of every rack and then you
could have other slave processes running
now when you talk about your rack
awareness one thing to understand is
that if your machines are placed within
racks and we are aware that hadoop
follows auto replication the rule of
replication in a rack of air cluster
would be that you would never have all
the replicas placed on the same rack so
if we look at this if we have block a in
blue color you will never have all the
three blue boxes in the same rack even
if they are on different nodes because
that makes us that makes it less fault
tolerant so you would have at least one
copy of block which would be stored on a
different track on a different note now
let's look at this so basically here we
are talking about replicas being placed
in such a way now somebody could ask a
question can i have my block and its
replicas spread across three lakhs and
yes you can do that but then in order to
make it more redundant you are
increasing your bandwidth requirement so
the better approach would be two blocks
on the same rack on different machines
and one copy on a different track now
let's proceed how can you restart name
node and all demons in hadoop so if you
were working on an apache hadoop cluster
then you could be doing a start and stop
using hadoop demonscripts so there are
these hadoop demon scripts which would
be used to start and stop your hadoop
and this is when you talk about your
apache hadoop so let's look at one
particular file which i would like to
show you more information here and this
talks about your different clusters so
let's look into this and
so let's look at the start and stop and
here i have a file let's look at this
one
and this gives you highlights so if you
talk about apache hadoop this is how the
setup would be done so you would have it
download the adobe tar file you would
have to unturn it edit the config files
you would have to do formatting and then
start your cluster and here i have said
using scripts so this is in case of
apache hadoop you could be using a start
all script that internally triggers
start dfs and start yarn and these
scripts start dfs internally would run
hadoop demon multiple times based on
your configs to start your different
processes then your start yarn would run
yarn demon script to start your
processing related processes so this is
how it happens in apache hadoop now in
case of cloudera or hortonworks which is
basically a vendor specific distribution
you would have say multiple services
which would have one or multiple demons
running across the machines let's take
an example here that you would have
machine 1 machine 2 and machine 3 with
your processor spread across however in
case of cloudera and hortonworks these
are cluster management solutions so you
would never be involved in running a
script individually to start and stop
your processes in fact in case of
cloudera you would have a cloudera scm
server running on one of the machines
and then cloudera scm agents running on
every machine if you talk about
hortonworks you would have ambari server
an ambari agent running so your agents
which are running on every machine are
responsible to monitor the processes
send also their heartbeat to the master
that is your server and your server is
the one or a service which basically
will give instructions to the agents so
in case of vendor specific distribution
your start and stop of processes is
automatically taken care by these
underlying services and these services
internally are still running these
commands however only in apache hadoop
you have to manually follow these to
start and stop coming back
we can look into
some command related questions so which
command will help you find the status of
blocks and file system health so you can
always go for a file system check
command now that can show you the files
for a particular sdfs path it can show
you the blocks and it can also give you
information on
status such as under replicated blocks
over replicated blocks misreplicated
blocks default replication and so on so
your fsck file system check utility does
not repair if there is any problem with
the blocks but it can give you
information of
blocks related to the files on which
machines they are stored if they are
replicated as per the replication factor
or if there is any problem with any
particular replica now what would happen
if you store too many small files in a
cluster and this relates to the block
information which i gave some time back
so remember hadoop is coded in java so
here every directory every file and file
related block is considered as an object
and for every object within your hadoop
cluster name node's ram gets utilized so
more number of blocks you have more
would be usage of name nodes ram and if
you're storing too many small files it
would not affect your disk it would
directly affect your name nodes ram
that's why in production clusters admin
guys or infrastructure specialist will
take care that everyone who is writing
data to hdfs follows a quota system so
that you could be controlled in the
amount of data you write plus the count
of data and individual rights on hdfs
now how do you copy data from local
system onto sdfs so you can use a put
command or a copy from local and then
given your local path which is your
source and then your destination which
is your sdfs path remember you can
always do a copy from local using a
minus f option that's a flag option and
that also helps you in writing the same
file or a new file to hdfs so with your
minus f you have a chance of overwriting
or rewriting the data which is existing
on sdfs so copy from local or minus put
both of them do the same thing and you
can also pass an argument when you're
copying to control your replication or
other aspects of your file now when do
you use dfs admin refresh nodes or rm
admin refresh nodes so as the command
says this is basically to do with
refreshing the node information so your
refresh nodes is mainly used when say a
commissioning or decommissioning of
nodes is done so when a node is added
into the cluster or when a node is
removed from the cluster you are
actually informing hadoop master that
this particular node would not be used
for storage and would not be used for
processing now in that case
you would be once you are done with the
process of commissioning or
decommissioning you would be giving
these commands that is refreshed nodes
and rm admin refresh nodes so internally
when you talk about commissioning
decommissioning there are include and
exclude files which are updated and
these include and exclude files will
have entry of machines which are being
added to the cluster or machines which
are being removed from the cluster and
while this is being done the cluster is
still running so you do not have to
restart your master process however you
can just use these refresh commands to
take care of your commissioning
decommissioning activities now is there
any way to change replication of files
on sdfs after they are already written
and the answer is of course yes so if
you would want to set a replication
factor at a cluster level and if you
have admin access then you could edit
your sdfs hyphen site file or you could
say hadoop hyphen site file and that
would take care of replication factor
being set at a cluster level however if
you would want to change the replication
after the data has been written you
could always use a setrep command so set
rep command is basically to change the
replication after the data is written
you could also
write the data with a different
replication and for that you could use a
minus d dfs dot replication and give
your application factor when you are
writing data to the cluster so in hadoop
you can let your data be replicated as
per the property set in the config file
you could write the data with a
different replication
you could change the replication after
the data is read so all these options
are available now who takes care of
replication consistency in a hadoop
cluster and what do you mean by under
over replicated blocks now as i
mentioned your fsck command can give you
information of over or under replicated
blocks now in a cluster it is always an
always name node which takes care of
replication consistency so for example
if you have set up a replication of
three and since we know the first rule
of replication which basically means
that you cannot have two replicas
residing on the same node it would mean
that if your replication is three you
would need at least three data nodes
available now say for example you had a
cluster with three nodes and replication
was set to three at one point of time
one of your name node crashed and if
that happens your blocks would be under
replicated that means there was a
replication factor set but now your
blocks are not replicated or there are
not enough replicas as per the
replication factor set this is not a
problem your master process or name node
will wait for some time before it will
start the replication of data again so
if a data road is not responding or if a
disk has crashed and if name node does
not get information of a replica name
node will wait for some time and then it
will start re-replication of those
missing blocks from the available nodes
however while name node is doing it the
blocks are in under replicated situation
now when you talk about over replicated
this is a situation where name node
realizes that there are extra copies of
block now this might be the case that
you had three nodes running with a
replication of three one of the node
went down due to a network failure or
some other issue within few minutes name
node re-replicated the data and then the
failed node is back with its set of
blocks again name node is smart enough
to understand that this is a over
replication situation and it will delete
set of blocks from one of the nodes it
might be the node which has been
recently added it might be your old node
which has joined your cluster again or
any node that depends on the load on a
particular node now we discussed about
hadoop we discussed about sdfs now we
will discuss about mapreduce which is
the programming model and you can say
processing framework what is distributed
cache in mapreduce now we know that when
we talk about map reduce the data which
has to be processed might be existing on
multiple nodes so when you would have
your mapreduce program running it would
basically read the data from the
underlying disks
now this could be a costly operation if
every time the data has to be read from
disk
so distributed cache is a mechanism
wherein
data set or data which is coming from
the disk can be cached
and available for all worker nodes now
how will this benefit so when a map
reduce is running instead of every time
reading the data from disk
it would pick up the data from
distributed cache and this this will
benefit your mapreduce processing so
distributed cache can be set in your
jobconf where you can specify that a
file should be picked up from
distributed cache
now let's understand about these roles
so what is a record reader what is a
combiner what is a partitioner and what
kind of roles do they play in a
mapreduce processing paradigm or map
reduce operation so record reader
communicates with the input split and it
basically converts the data into key
value pairs and these key value pairs
are the ones which will be worked upon
by the mapper your combiner is an
optional face it's like mini radius so
combiner does not have its own class
it relies on the reducer class
basically your combiner would receive
the data from your map tasks
which would have completed works on it
based on whatever reducer class mentions
and then passes its output to the
reducer phase partitioner is basically a
phase which decides how many reduced
tasks would be used aggregate or
summarize your data so partitioner is a
phase which would decide based on the
number of keys based on the number of
map tasks your partition would decide if
one or multiple reduced tasks would be
used to take care of processing so
either it could be partitioner which
decides on how many reduced tasks would
run or it could be based on the
properties which we have set within the
cluster which will take care of the
number of reduced tasks which would be
used always remember your partitioner
decides how outputs from combiner are
sent to reducer and to how many reducers
it controls the partitioning of keys of
your intermediate map outputs so map
phase whatever output it generates is an
intermediate output and that has to be
taken by your practitioner or by a
combiner and then partitioner to be sent
to one or multiple reduced tasks this is
one of the common questions which you
might face
why is mapreduce lower
in processing so we know mapreduce goes
for parallel processing we know we can
have multiple map tasks running on
multiple nodes at the same time we also
know that multiple reduced stars could
be running now why does then mapreduce
become a slower approach
first of all your mapreduce is a batch
oriented operation now mapreduce
is very rigid and it strictly uses
mapping and reducing phases so no matter
what kind of processing you would want
to do you would have to still provide
the mapper function and the reducer
function to work on data not only this
whenever your map phase completes
the output of your map face which is an
intermittent output would be written to
hdfs and thereafter underlying disks and
this data would then be shuffled and
sorted and picked up for reducing phase
so every time your data being written to
hdfs and retrieved from sdfs makes
mapreduce a slower approach the question
is for a mapreduce job is it possible to
change the number of mappers to be
created
now
by default you cannot change the number
of map tasks because number of map tasks
depends on the input splits however
there are different ways in which you
can either set a property to have more
number of map tasks which can be used or
you can customize your code or
make it use a different format which can
then control the number of map tasks by
default number of map tasks
are equal to the number of splits of
file you are processing
so if you have a 1 gb of file that is
split into 8 blocks of 128 mb there
would be eight map tasks running on the
cluster these map tasks are basically
running your mapper function
if you have hard coded properties in
your map red hyphen site file to specify
more number of map tasks then you could
control the number of map tasks
let's also talk about some data types so
when you prepare for hadoop when you
want to get into big data field you
should start learning about different
data formats now there are different
data formats such as
avro parque
you have a sequence file or binary
format and these are different formats
which are used now when you talk about
your data types
in hadoop these are implementation of
your writable and writable comparable
interfaces so for every data type in
java you have a equivalent in hadoop so
end in java would be intriguable in
hadoop float would be float writable
long would be long writable double
writable boolean writable array writable
map writable and object credible so
these are your different data types that
could be used within your mapreduce
program and these are implementation of
writable and writable comparable
interfaces what is speculative execution
now imagine you have a cluster which has
huge number of nodes and your data is
spread across multiple slave machines or
multiple nodes now at a point of time
due to a disk degrade or network issues
or machine heating up or more load being
on a particular node there can be a
situation where your data node will
execute task in a slower manner now in
this case if speculative execution is
turned on there would be a shadow task
or a another
similar task running on some other node
for the same processing so whichever
task finishes first will be accepted and
the other task would be killed so
speculative execution could be good if
you are working in an intensive workload
kind of environment where if a
particular node is slower you could
benefit from a unoccupied or a node
which has less load to take care of your
processing going further this is how we
can understand so node a which might be
having a slower task you would have a
scheduler which is maintaining or
having knowledge of what are the
resources available so if speculative
execution as a property is turned on
then the task which was running slow a
copy of that task or you can say shadow
task would run on some other node and
whichever task completes first will be
considered this is what happens in your
speculative execution now how is
identity mapper different from chain
mapper now this is where we are getting
deeper into mapreduce concepts so when
you talk about mapper identity mapper is
the default mapper which is chosen when
no mapper is specified in mapreduce
driver class so for every mapreduce
program you would have a map class which
is taking care of your mapping phase
which basically has a mapper function
and which would run one or multiple map
tasks right your programming your
program would also have a reduce class
which would be running a reducer
function which takes care of reduced
tasks running on multiple nodes
now if a mapper is not specified within
your driver class so driver class is
something which has all information
about your flow what's your map class
what is your reduced class what's your
input format what's your output format
what are the job configurations and so
on so identity mapper is the default
mapper which is chosen when no mapper
class is mentioned in your driver class
it basically implements an identity
function which directly writes all its
key pairs into output and it was defined
in old mapreduce api in this particular
package but when you talk about chaining
mappers or chain mapper this is
basically a class to run multiple
mappers in a single map task or
basically you could say multiple map
tasks would run as a part of your
processing the output of first mapper
would become as an input to second
mapper and so on and this can be defined
in the under mentioned class or package
what are the major configuration
parameters required in the mapreduce
program
obviously we need to have the input
location we need to have the output
location so input location is where the
files will be picked up from and this
would preferably on sdfs directory
output location is the path where your
job output would be written by your
mapreduce program you also need to
specify input and output formats if you
don't specify the defaults are
considered then we need to also have the
classes which have your map and reduce
functions and if you intend to run the
code on a cluster you need to package
your class in a jar file export it to
your cluster and then this jar file
would have your mapper reducer and
driver classes so these are important
configuration parameters
which you need to consider for a map
reduce program now what is the
difference or what do you mean by maps
height join and reduce side join map
side join is basically when the join is
performed at the mapping level or at the
mapping phase or is performed by the
mapper so each input data which is being
worked upon has to be divided into same
number of partitions
input to each map is in the form of a
structured partition and is in sorted
order so map site join you can
understand it in a simpler way that if
you compare it with rdbms concepts where
you had two tables which were being
joined it will always be advisable to
give your bigger table as the left side
table or the first table for your join
condition and it would be your smaller
table on the left side and your bigger
table on the right side which basically
means the smaller table could be loaded
in memory and could be used for joining
so map site drawing is a similar kind of
mechanism where input data is divided
into same number of partitions when you
talk about reduced side join here the
join is performed by the reducer so it
is easier to implement than website join
as all the sorting and shuffling will
send the values
or send all the values having identical
keys to the same reducer so you don't
need to have your data set in a
structured form so look into your map
side join or reduce side join and other
joins just to understand how mapreduce
works however i would suggest not to
focus more on this because mapreduce is
still being used for processing but the
amount of map reduce based processing
has decreased overall or across the
industry now what is the role of output
committer class in a mapreduce job so
output committer as the name says
describes the commit of task output for
a mapreduce job so we could have this as
mentioned or apache hadoop mapreduce
output committer you could have a class
which extends your output committer
class
so mapreduce relies on this mapreduce
relies on the output committer of the
job to
set up the job initialization cleaning
up the job after the job completion that
means all the resources which were being
used by a particular job setting up the
task temporary output checking whether a
task needs a commit committing the task
output and discarding the task out so
this is a very important class and can
be used within your mapreduce job what
is the process of spilling in mapreduce
what does that mean
so spilling is basically a process of
copying the data from memory buffer to
disk when obviously the
buffer usage reaches a certain threshold
so if there is not enough memory in your
buffer in your memory then the content
which is stored in buffer or memory has
to be flushed out so by default a
background thread starts spilling the
content from memory to disk after eighty
percent of buffer size is filled now
when is the buffer being used so when
your mapreduce processing is happening
the data from data is being read from
the disk loaded into the buffer and then
some processing happens
same thing also happens when you are
writing data to the cluster
so you can imagine for a 100 megabyte
size buffer the spilling will start
after the content of buffer reaches 80
megabytes this is customizable how can
you set the mappers and reducers for a
mapreduce job so these are the
properties
so number of mappers and reducers as i
mentioned earlier can be customized so
by default your number of map tasks
depends on the split and number of
reduced tasks depends on the
partitioning phase which decides number
of reduced tasks which would be used
depending on the keys however we can set
these properties either in the config
files or provide them on the command
line or also make them part of our code
and this can control the number of map
tasks or reduce tasks which would be run
for a particular job let's look at one
more interesting question what happens
when a node running a map task fails
before sending the output to the reducer
so there was a node which was running a
map task and we know that there could be
one or multiple map tasks running on one
or multiple nodes and all the map tasks
have to be completed before the further
stages that such as combiner or reducer
come into existence so in a case if a
node crashes where a map task was
assigned to it the whole task will have
to be run again on some other note so in
hadoop version 2 yarn framework has a
temporary demon called application
master so your application master is
taking care of execution of your
application and if a particular task on
a particular node failed due to
unavailability of node it is the role of
application master to have this task
scheduled on some other node now can we
write the output of mapreduce in
different formats of course we can so
hadoop supports various input and output
formats so you can write the output of
mapreduce in different formats so you
could have the default format that is
text output format wherein records are
written as line of text you could have
sequence file which is basically to
write sequence files or your binary
format files where your output files
need to be fed into another mapreduce
jobs you could go for a map file output
format to write output as map files you
could go for a sequence file as a binary
output format so that's again a variant
of your
sequence file input format it basically
writes keys and values to a sequence
file so when we talk about binary format
we are talking about a non-human
readable format db output format now
this is basically used when you would
want to write data to say relational
databases or say no sql databases such
as hbase so this format also sends the
reduce output to a sql table now let's
learn a little bit about yarn yarn which
stands for yet another resource
negotiator it's the processing framework
so what benefits did yan bring in hadoop
version 2 and how did it solve the
issues of mapreduce version 1. so
mapreduce version 1 had major issues
when it comes to scalability or
availability because sorry in hadoop
version 1 you had only one master
process for processing layer and that is
your job tracker so your job tracker was
listening to all the task trackers which
were running on multiple machines so
your job tracker was responsible for
resource tracking and job scheduling in
yarn you still have a processing master
but that's called resource manager
instead of job tracker and now with
hadoop version 2 you could even have
resource manager running in high
availability mode you have node managers
which would be running on multiple
machines and then you have a temporary
demon called application master so in
case of hadoop version 2 your resource
manager or master is only handling the
client connections and taking care of
tracking the resources the
jobs scheduling or basically taking care
of execution across multiple nodes is
controlled by application master till
the application completes
so in yarn you can have different kind
of resource allocations that could be
done and there is a concept of container
so container is basically a combination
of ram and cpu cores
yarn can run different kind of workloads
so it is not just map reduce kind of
workload which can be run on adobe
person too but you would have graph
processing massive parallel processing
you could have a real-time processing
and huge processing applications could
run on a cluster based on yarn so when
we talk about scalability
in case of your hadoop version 2 you can
have a cluster size of more than 10 000
nodes and can run more than 100 000
concurrent tasks and this is because for
every application which is launched you
have this temporary demon called
application master so if i would have 10
applications running i would have 10 app
masters running taking care of execution
of these applications across multiple
nodes compatibility so hadoop version 2
is fully compatible with whatever was
developed as per hadoop version 1 and
all your processing needs would be taken
care by yarn
so dynamic allocation of cluster
resources taking care of different
workloads
allocating resources across multiple
machines and using them for execution
all that is taken care by yarn
multi-tenancy which basically means you
could have multiple users or multiple
teams
you could have open source and
proprietary data access engines and all
of these could be basically hosted using
the same cluster now how does yarn
allocate resources to an application
with help of its architecture so
basically you have a client or an
application or an api which talks to
resource manager resource manager is as
i mentioned managing the resource
allocation in the cluster when you talk
about resource manager you have its
internal two components one is your
scheduler and one is your applications
manager so when we say resource manager
being the master is tracking the
resources the source manager is the one
which is negotiating the resources with
slave it is not actually resource
manager who is doing it but these
internal components
so you have a scheduler which allocates
resources to various running
applications so scheduler is not
bothered about tracking your resources
or basically tracking your applications
so we can have different kind of
schedulers such as fifo which is first
in first out you could have a fair
scheduler or you could have a capacity
scheduler and these schedulers basically
control how resources are allocated to
multiple applications when they are
running in parallel so there is a queue
mechanism so scheduler will schedule
resources based on requirements of
application but it is not monitoring or
tracking the status of applications
your applications manager is the one
which is accepting the job submissions
it is monitoring and restarting the
application masters so it's application
manager which is basically then
launching a application master which is
responsible for an application so this
is how it looks
so whenever a job submission happens we
already know that resource manager is
aware of the resources which are
available with every node manager so on
every node which has fixed amount of ram
and cpu cores
some portion of resources that is your
ram and cpu cores are allocated to node
manager now resource manager is already
aware of how much resources are
available across nodes so whenever a
client request comes in resource manager
will make a request to node manager it
will basically request node manager to
hold some resources for processing node
manager would basically approve or
disapprove this request of holding
resources
and these resources that is a
combination of ram and cpu cores are
nothing but containers we can allocate
containers of different sizes within
yarn hyphen site file so your node
manager based on a request from resource
manager guarantees the container which
would be available for processing that's
when your resource manager starts a
temporary demon called application
master to take care of your execution so
your app master which was launched by
resource manager or we can say internal
away applications manager will run in
one of the containers because
application master is also a piece of
code so it will run in one of the
containers and then other containers
will be utilized for execution this is
how yarn is basically taking care of
your allocation your application master
is managing resource needs it is the one
which is interacting with scheduler and
if
a particular
node crashes it is the responsibility of
app master
to go back to the master which is
resource manager and negotiate for more
resources
so your app master will never ever
negotiate resources with node manager
directly it will always talk to resource
manager and the source manager is the
one which negotiates the resources
container as i said is a collection of
resources like your ram cpu network
bandwidth and your container is
allocated based on the availability of
resources on a particular node so which
of the following has occupied the place
of a job tracker of mapreduce so it is
your resource manager so resource
manager is the name of the master
process in adobe portion 2. now if you
would have to write yarn commands to
check the status of an application so we
could just say yarn application minus
status and then the application id and
you could kill it also from the command
line remember your yarn has a ui and you
can even look at your applications from
the ui you can even kill your
applications from the ui however knowing
the command line commands would be very
useful can we have more than one
resource manager in a yarn based cluster
yes we can that is what hadoop version 2
allows us to have so you can have a high
availability yarn cluster where you have
active and standby and the coordination
is taking care by your zookeeper at a
particular time there can only be one
active resource manager and if active
resource manager fails your standby
resource manager comes and becomes
active however zookeeper is playing a
very important role remember zookeeper
is the one which is coordinating the
server state and it is doing the
election of active to standby failover
what are the different schedulers
available in yan so you have a fifo
scheduler that is first in first out and
this is not a desirable option because
in this case a longer running
application might block all other small
running applications your capacity
scheduler is basically a scheduler where
dedicated queues are created and they
have fixed amount of resources so you
can have multiple applications accessing
the cluster at the same time and they
would be using their own cues
and the resources allocated to them if
you talk about fair scheduler you don't
need to have a fixed amount of
resources you can just have a percentage
and you could decide what kind of
fairness is to be followed which
basically means that if you were
allocated 20 gigabytes of memory however
the cluster has 100 gigabytes and the
other team was assigned 80 gigabytes of
memory then you have 20 percent access
to the cluster another team has 80
percent however if the other team does
not come up or does not use the cluster
in a fair scheduler you can go up to
maximum 100
of your cluster to find out more
information about your schedulers you
could either look in hadoop definitive
guide or what you could do is you could
just go to google and you could type for
example yarn
scheduler
let's search for yarn scheduler and then
you can look in
hadoop definitive guide
and so this is your hadoop definitive
guide and it beautifully explains about
your different schedulers how do
multiple applications run and that could
be in your fifo kind of scheduling it
could be in capacity scheduler or it
could be in a fair scheduling so have a
look at this link it's a very good link
you can also search for yarn untangling
and this is a blog of four or this is a
series of four blocks where it's
beautifully explained about your yarn
how it works how the resource allocation
happens what is a container and what
runs within the container so you can
scroll down you can be reading through
this and you can then also search for
part two of it which talks about
allocation and so on so coming back
we basically have these schedulers what
happens if a resource manager fails
while executing an application in a high
availability cluster so in a high
availability cluster we know that we
will have two resource managers one
being active one being standby and
zookeeper which is keeping a track of
the server states so if a rm fails in
case of high availability the
standby will be elected as active and
then basically your
resource manager or the standby would
become the active one and this one would
instruct the application master to abort
in the beginning then your resource
manager recovers it's a running state
so there is something called as rm state
store where all the applications which
are running their status is stored so
resource manager recovers
its running state by looking at your
state store
by taking advantage of container
statuses and then continues to take care
of your processing now in a cluster of
10 data nodes each having 16 gb and 10
cores what would be total processing
capacity of the cluster take a minute to
think 10 data nodes 16 gb ram per node
10 cores
so if you mention the answer as 160 gb
ram
and 100 cores then you went wrong now
think of a cluster which has 10 data
nodes each having 16 gb ram and 10 cores
remember on every node in a hadoop
cluster you would have one or multiple
processors running those processes would
need ram the machine itself which has a
linux file system would have its own
processes so that would also be having
some ram usage which basically means
that if you talk about 10 data nodes you
should deduct at least 20 to 30 percent
towards the overheads towards the cloud
database services towards the other
processes which are running and in that
case i could say that you could have 11
or 12 gb available on every machine for
processing and say 6 or 7 cores multiply
that by 10 and that's your processing
capacity remember the same thing applies
to the disk usage also so if somebody
asks you in a 10 data node cluster where
each machine has 20 terabytes of disks
what is my total storage capacity
available for sdfs so the answer would
not be 200 you have to consider the
overheads and this is basically which
gives you your processing capacity now
let's look at one more question so what
happens if requested memory or cpu cores
beyond or goes beyond the size of
container now as i said you can have
your configurations which can say that
in a particular data node which has 100
gb ram i could allocate say 50 gb
for the processing like out of 100 cores
i could say 50 cores for processing so
if you have 100 gb ram and 100 cores you
could ideally allocate 100 for
processing but that's not ideally
possible so if you have 100 gb ram you
would go for 50 gb and if you have 100
cores you would go for 50 cores now
within this
ram and cpu course you have the concept
of containers right so container is a
combination of ram and cpu cores so you
could have a minimum size container and
maximum size container now at any point
of time if your application starts
demanding
more memory or more cpu cores
and this cannot fit into a container
location your application will
fail your application will fail because
you requested for a memory or a
combination of memory and cpu cores
which is
more than the maximum container size now
here we will discuss on hive peg hbase
and these components of do which are
being used in the industry for various
use cases let's look at some questions
here and let's look how you should
prepare for them so first of all we will
learn on hive which is a data
warehousing package so the question is
what are the different components of a
hive architecture now when we talk about
hive we already know that hive is a data
warehousing package which basically
allows you to work on structured data or
data which can be structuralized so
normally people are well versed with
querying or basically processing the
data using sql queries a lot of people
come from database backgrounds and they
would find it comfortable if they know
structured query language hive is one of
the data warehousing package which
resides within a hadoop ecosystem it
uses hadoop's distributed file system to
store the data and it uses rdbms usually
to store the metadata although metadata
can be stored locally also so what are
the different components of an hive
architecture so it has a user interface
so user interface calls the execute
interface to the driver this creates a
session to the query and then it sends
the query to the compiler to generate an
execution plan for it usually whenever
hive is set up it would have its
metadata stored in an rdbms now to
establish the connection between rdbms
and hadoop we need odbc or jdbc
connector jar file and that connector
jar file has a driver class now this
driver class is mandatory to create a
connection between hive and hadoop so
user interface creates this interface
using the driver now we have metastore
metastore stores the metadata
information so any object which you
create such as database table indexes
their metadata is stored in metastore
and usually this metastore is stored in
an rdbms so that multiple users can
connect to hive so your metastore stores
the metadata information and sends that
to the compiler for execution of a query
what does the compiler do it generates
the execution plan
it has a dag now dag stands for direct
acyclic graph so it has a dag of stages
where each stage is either a metadata
operation a map or reduced job or an
operation on sdfs and finally we have
execution engine that acts as a bridge
between hive and hadoop to process the
query so execution engine communicates
bi-directionally with metastore to
perform operations like create or drop
tables so these are four important
components of hive architecture now what
is the difference between external table
and manage table and height
so we have various kinds of table in
hive such as external table manage table
partition table the major difference
between your managed and external table
is in respect to what happens to the
data if the table is dropped usually
whenever we create a table in hive it
creates a manage table or we could also
call that as an internal table now this
manages the data and moves it into
warehouse directory by default whether
you create a manage table or external
table usually the data can reside in
hive's default warehouse directory or it
could be residing in a location chosen
however when we talk about manage table
if one drops a manage table not only the
metadata information is deleted but the
table's data is also deleted from sdfs
if we talk about external table it is
created with an external keyword
explicitly and if an external table is
dropped nothing happens to the data
which resides in sdfs so that's the main
difference between your managed and
external table what might be the use
case if somebody asks you there might be
a migration kind of activity or you are
interested in creating a lot of tables
using your queries so in that case you
could dump all the data on sdfs and then
you could create a table by pointing to
a particular directory or multiple
directories now you could then do some
testing of your tables and would decide
that you might not need all the tables
so in that case it would be advisable to
create external tables so that even if
the table is later dropped the data on
sdfs will be intact unlike your manage
table where dropping of table will
delete the data from sdfs also let's
learn a little bit on partition so what
is partition and hive and why is
partitioning required in hive if
somebody asks you that now normally in
world of rdbms partition is the process
to group similar type of data together
and that is usually done on basis of a
column or what we call as partitioning
key now each table usually has one
column in context of rdbms which could
be used to partition the data and why do
we do that so that we can avoid scanning
the complete table for a query and
restrict the scan to
set of data or to a particular partition
in hive we can have any number of
partition keys so partitioning provides
granularity in hive table it reduces the
query latency by scanning only relevant
partition data instead of whole data set
we can partition at various levels now
if i compare rdbms with hive in case of
rdbms you could have
one column which could be used for
partitioning and then you could be
squaring the specific partition so in
case of rdbms
your partition column is usually a part
of the table definition so for example
if i have an employee table i might have
employee id employee name employee age
and employee salary as four columns and
i would decide to partition the table
based on salary column now why would i
partition it because i feel that
employee table is growing very fast it
is or it will have huge amount of data
and later when we query the table we
don't want to scan the complete table so
i could split my data into multiple
partition based on a salary column
giving some ranges in hive it is a
little different
in hive you can do partitioning and
there is a concept of static and dynamic
partitioning but in hive the partition
column is not part of table definition
so you might have an employee table with
employee id
name age
and that that's it that would be the
table definition but you could then have
partitioning done based on salary column
which will then create a specific folder
on sdfs in that case when we query the
data we can see the partition column
also showing up so we can partition the
transaction data for a bank for example
based on month like chan feb etc and any
operation regarding a particular month
will then allow us to query that
particular folder that is where
partitioning is useful now why does hive
not store metadata information in sdfs
if somebody asks you so we know that
hives data is stored in sdfs which is
hadoop distributed file system however
the metadata is either stored locally
and that mode of hive would be called as
embedded mode or you could have hives
metadata stored in rdbms so that
multiple clients can initiate a
connection now this metadata which is
very important for hive would not be
stored in sdfs so we already know that
sdfs read and write operations are time
consuming it is a distributed file
system and it can accommodate huge
amount of data so hive stores metadata
information in metastore using rdbms
instead of sdfs so this allows to
achieve low latency and faster data
access
now if somebody asks what are the
components used in hive query processor
so usually we have the main components
are your parser your execution engine
logical plan generation optimizer and
type checking so whenever a query is
submitted it will go through a parser
and parser would check the syntax it
would check for objects which are being
queried and other things to see if the
query is fine now internally you have a
semantic analyzer which will also look
at the query you have an execution
engine which basically will
work on the execution part that is the
best generated execution plan which
could be used to get the results for the
query you could also have user defined
functions which a user would want to use
and these are normally created in
java or java programming language and
then basically these user defined
functions are added to the class path
now you would have a logical plan
generation which basically looks at your
query and then generates a logical plan
or the best execution path which would
be required to get to the results
internally there is a physical plan
generated which is then looked in by
optimizer to get the best path to get to
the data and that might also be checking
your different operators which you are
using within your query finally we would
also have type checking so these are
important components in hype so somebody
might ask you if you are querying your
data using hive what are the different
components involved or if you could
explain what are the different
components which
work when a query is submitted so these
are the components now let's look a
scenario based question suppose there
are a lot of small csv files which are
present in a sdfs directory and you want
to create a single hive table from these
files so data in these files have fields
like registration number name email
address so if this is what needs to be
done what will be your approach to solve
it where will you create a single hive
table for lots of small files without
degrading the performance of the system
so there can be different approaches now
we know that there are a lot of small
csv files which are present in a
directory so we know that when we create
a table in hive we can use a location
parameter so i could say create table
give a table name give the column and
their data types i could specify the
delimiters and finally i could say
location and then point it to a
directory on sdfs in this directory
might be the directory which has lot of
csv files so in this case i will avoid
loading the data in the table because
table being point table pointing to the
directory will directly pick up the data
from one or multiple files and we also
know that hive does schema check on read
so it does not do a schema check on
write so in case there were one or two
files which did not follow the schema of
the table it would not prevent data
loading data would anyways be loaded
only when you query the data it might
show you null values if data which was
loaded does not follow the schema of the
table this is one approach what is the
other approach so let's look at that you
can think about sequence file format
which is basically a smart format or a
binary format and you can group these
small files together to form a sequence
file now this could be one other smarter
approach so we could create a temporary
table so we could say create table give
a table name give the column names and
their data types we could specify the
delimiters as it shows here that is row
format and fields terminated by and
finally we can store that as text file
then we can load data into this table by
giving a local file system path and then
we can create a table that will store
data in sequence file format so my point
one is storing the data instead text
file point three would be storing the
data in sequence file format so we say
create table give the specifications we
say row format delimited fields are
terminated by comma stored as sequence
file then we can move the data from test
table into test sequence file table so i
could just say insert overwrite my new
table as
select star from other table remember in
hive you cannot do insert update delete
however if the table is existing you can
do a insert overwrite from an existing
table into a new table so this could be
one approach where we could have lot of
csv files or smaller files club together
as one big sequence file and then store
it in the table now if somebody asks you
write a query to insert a new column
that is
integer data type into a hive table and
the requirement might be that you would
want to insert this table at a position
before an existing column now that's
possible by doing an alter table giving
your table name and then specifying
change column giving you a new column
with the data type before an existing
column this is a simple way wherein you
can insert a new column into a hive
table what are the key differences
between hive and pig
now some of you might have heard hive
high vision data warehousing package and
pig is more of a scripting language
both of them are used for data analysis
trend detection hypothesis testing data
transformation and many other use cases
so if we compare hive and pig hive uses
a declarative language called hive ql
that is hive querying language similar
to sql and it is for reporting or for
data analysis even for data
transformation or for your data
extraction pig uses a high level
procedural language called pig latin for
programming both of them remember use
mapreduce processing framework so when
we run a query in hive to process the
data or when we create and submit a pick
script both of them trigger a mapreduce
job unless and until we have set them to
local mode hive operates on the server
side of the cluster and basically works
on structured data or data which can be
structuralized pig usually works or
operates on the client side of the
cluster and allows both structured
unstructured or even i could say
semi-structured data hive does not
support avro file format by default
however that can be done by using the
write serializer d serializer so we can
have hive table related data stored in
avro format in sequence file format in
part k format or even as a text file
format however when we are working on
smarter formats like avro or sequence
file or par k we might have to use
specific serializers d serializers for
avro this is the package which
allows us to use avro format pig
supports avro format by default hive was
developed by facebook and it supports
partitioning and pig was developed by
yahoo and it does not support
partitioning so these are high level
differences there are lots and lots of
differences remember hive is more of a
data housing package and pig is more of
a scripting language or a
strictly procedural flow following
scripting language which allows us to
process the data now let's get more and
let's get more deeper and learn about
pig which is as i mentioned a scripting
language which can be used for your data
processing it also uses mapreduce
although we can even have pig run in a
local mode let's learn about pig in the
next section now let's learn on some
questions about pig which is a scripting
language and it is extensively used for
data processing and data analysis so the
question is how is apache pig different
from mapreduce now we all know that
mapreduce is a programming model it is
it's quite rigid when it comes to
processing the data because you have to
do the mapping and reducing you have to
write huge code usually mapreduce is
written in java but now it can also be
written in python it can be written in
scala and other programming languages so
if we compare pig with mapreduce pig
obviously is very concise it has less
lines of code when compared to mapreduce
now we also know that pig script
internally will trigger a mapreduce job
however user need not know about
mapreduce programming model they can
simply write simple scripts in pig and
that will automatically be converted
into mapreduce however mapreduce has
more lines of code peak is
high level language which can easily
perform join operations or other data
processing operations mapreduce is a low
level language which cannot perform job
join operations easily so we can do join
using mapreduce however it's not really
easy in comparison to pick now as i said
on execution every pig operator is
converted internally into a mapreduce
job so every pick script which is run
which would be converted into mapreduce
job now map reduce
overall is a batch oriented processing
so it takes more time to compile it
takes more time to execute either when
you run a mapreduce job or when it is
triggered by pig script pig works with
all versions of hadoop and when we talk
about mapreduce program which is written
in one hadoop version may not work with
other versions it might work or it might
not it depends on what are the
dependencies what is the compiler you
are using what programming language you
have used and what version of hadoop you
are working on so these are the main
differences between apache pig and
mapreduce what are the different ways of
executing pig script so you could create
a script file store it in dot pic or dot
text and then you can execute it using
the big command you could be bringing up
the grunt shell that is pig's shell now
that usually starts with map reduce mode
but then we can also bring it up in a
local mode and we can also run pig
embedded as an embedded script in other
programming language so these are the
different ways of executing your big
script now what are the major components
of pig execution environment this is
this is a very common question
interviewers would always want to know
different components of hive different
components of pig even different
components which are involved in hadoop
ecosystem so when we want to learn about
major components of big execution
environment here also so you have pick
scripts now that is written in pig latin
using built-in operators and
user-defined functions and submitted to
the execution environment that's what
happens when you would want to process
the data using pic now there is a parser
which does type checking and checks the
syntax of the script the output of
parser is a tag direct cyclic graph so
block and wikipedia for dag so dag is
basically a sequence of steps which run
in one direction then you have an
optimizer now this optimizer performs
optimization using merge transform split
etc it aims to reduce the amount of data
in the pipeline that's the whole purpose
of optimizer you have a internal
compiler so pick compiler converts the
optimized code into a mapreduce job and
here user need not know the mapreduce
programming model or how it works or how
it is written they all need to know
about running the pick script which
would be internally converted into a
mapreduce job and finally we have an
execution engine so mapreduce jobs are
submitted to the execution engine to
generate the desired results so these
are major components of pig execution
environment now let's learn about
different complex data types in pig
supports various data types the main
ones are tuple bag and map what is tuple
or tuple as you might have heard a tuple
is an ordered set of fields which can
contain different data types for each
field so in array you would have
multiple elements but that would be of
same types list can also have different
types your tuple is a collection which
has different fields and each field can
be of different type now we could have
an example as one comma three or one
comma three comma a string or a float
element and all of that form a tuple bag
is a set of tuples so that's represented
by curly braces so you could also
imagine this like a dictionary which has
various different collection elements
what is a map map is a set of key value
pairs used to represent data so when you
work in big data field you need to know
about different data types which are
supported by pig which are supported by
hive which are supported in other
components of hadoop so tuple bag map
array array buffer you can think about
list you can think about dictionaries
you can think about map which is key
value pair so these are your different
complex data types other than the
primitive data type such as integer
character string boolean float and so on
now what are the various diagnostic
operators available in apache pic so
these are some of the operators or
options which you can give in a pic
script you can do a dump now dump
operator runs the pig latin scripts and
displays the result on the screen so
either i could do a dumb and see the
output on the screen or i can even do a
dump into and i could store my output in
a particular file so we can load the
data using load operator and pick and
then pico also has different internal
storage like json loader or big storage
which can be used if you are working on
specific kind of data and then you could
do a dump either before processing or
after processing and dump would produce
the result the result could be stored in
a file or seen on the screen you also
have a describe operator now that is
used to view the schema of a relation so
you can load the data and then you can
view the schema of relation using
describe operator explain as we might
already know displays the physical
logical and mapreduce execution plans
normally in rdbms when we use x-plane we
would like to see what happens behind
the scenes when a particular script or a
query runs so we could load the data
using load operator as in any other case
and if we would want to display the
logical physical and mapreduce execution
plans we could use explain operator
there is also an illustrate operator now
that gives the step-by-step execution of
sequence of statements so sometimes when
we would want to analyze our script to
see how good or bad they are or would
that really serve our purpose we could
use illustrate and again you can test
that by loading the data using load
operator and you could just use a
illustrate operator to have a look at
the step-by-step execution of the
sequence of statements which you would
want to execute so these are different
diagnostic operators available in apache
pic now if somebody asks state the usage
of group order by and distinct keywords
in big script so as i said pig is a
scripting language so you could use
various operators so group basically
collects various records with the same
key and groups the data in one or more
relations here is an example you could
do a group data so that is basically a
variable or you can give some other name
and you can say group relation name by h
now say i have a file where i have field
various fields and one of the field is
relation name so i could group that by a
different field order by is used to
display the contents of relation in a
sorted order whether ascending or
descending so i could create a variable
called relation 2 and then i could say
order relation name 1 by ascending or
descending order distinct basically
removes the duplicate records and it is
implemented only on entire records
not on individual records so if you
would want to find out the distinct
values and relation name field i could
use distinct what are the relational
operators in pig so you have various
relational operators which help data
scientists or data analysts or
developers who are analyzing the data
such as co-group which joins two or more
tables and then performs group operation
on the join table result you have cross
it is used to compute the cross product
that is a cartesian product of two or
more relations
for each is basically to do some
iteration so if it will iterate through
tuples of a relation generating a data
transformation so for example if i say
variable a equals and then i load a file
in a and then i could create a variable
called b where i could say for each a i
would want to do something say group
join is to join two or more tables in a
relation limit is to limit the number of
output tuples or output results split is
to split the relation into two or more
relations union is to get a combination
that's it will merge the contents of two
or more relations and order is to get a
sorted result so these are some
relational operators which are
extensively used in pig for analysis
what is the use of having filters in
apache pig
now say for example i have some data
which has three fields year product
quantity and this is my phone sales data
so filter operator could be used to
select the required values from a
relation based on a condition it also
allows you to remove unwanted records
from data file so for example filter the
products where quantity is greater than
thousand so i see that i have
one row wherein or multiple rows where
the quantity is greater than thousand
such as 1500 1700 1200 so i could create
a variable called a i would load my file
using pix storage as i explained earlier
big storage is an internal parameter
which can be used to
specify the delimiters now here my
delimiter is comma so i could say using
pick storage as and then i could specify
the data type for each field so here
being integer product being character
array and quantity being integer then b
i could say filter a whatever we have in
a by quantity greater than thousand so
it's very concise it's very simple and
it allows us to extract and process data
in a simpler way now suppose there is a
file called test.txt
having 150 records in dfs so this is a
file which is stored on his dfs and it
has 150 records where we can consider
every record being one line and if
somebody asks you to write a big command
to retrieve the first 10 records of the
file first we will have to load the data
so i could create a variable called test
underscore data and i would say load my
file using pix storage specifying the
delimiter as comma as and then i could
specify my fields whatever fields our
file have and then i would want to get
only 10 records for which i could use
the limit operator so i could say limit
on test data and give me 10 records this
is very simple and we can extract 10
records from 150 records which are
stored in the file on sdfs
now we have learnt on pig we have
learned some questions on hive you could
always look more in books like
programming in hive or programming in
pig and look for some more examples and
try out these examples on a existing
hadoop setup now let's learn on hbase
which is a nosql database now hbase is a
four dimensional database in comparison
to your rdbms which usually are
two-dimensional so rdbms have rows and
columns but hbase has four coordinates
it has row key which is always unique
column family which can be any number
column qualifiers which can again be any
number per column family and then you
have a version so these four coordinates
make edge base a four dimensional key
value store or a column family store
which is unique for storing huge amount
of data and extracting data from hbase
there is a very good link which i would
suggest everyone can look at if you
would want to learn more on hbase and
you could just say hbase mapper and this
basically brings up a documentation
which is from mapr but then that's not
specific to map r and you can look at
this link which will give you a detailed
explanation of edge base how it works
what are the architectural components
and how data is stored and how it makes
hbase a very powerful nosql database so
let's learn on some of the important or
critical questions on hbase which might
be asked by the interviewer in an
interview when you are applying for a
big data admin or a developer position
role so what are the key components of
edge base now as i said this is one of
the favorite questions of interviewers
where they would want to understand your
knowledge on different components for a
particular service hbase as i said is a
nosql database and that comes as a part
of service with cloudera or hortonworks
and with apache hadoop you could also
set up hbase as an independent package
so what are the key components of hbase
hbase has a region server now hbase
follows the similar kind of topology
like hadoop now hadoop has a master
process that is named node and slave
processes such as data nodes and
secondary name node in the same way
hbase also has a master which is h
master and the slave processes are
called region servers so these region
servers are usually co-located with data
nodes however it is not mandatory that
if you have hundred data nodes you would
have hundred region servers so it purely
depends on admin so what does this
region server contain so region server
contains hbase tables that are divided
horizontally into regions or you could
say group of rows is called regions so
in edge base you have two aspects one is
group of columns which is called column
family and one is group of rows which is
called regions now these regions or
these rows are grouped based on the key
values or i would say row keys which are
always unique when you store your data
in each base you would have data in the
form of rows and columns so group of
rows are called regions or you could say
these are horizontal partitions of the
table so a region server manages these
regions on the node where a data node is
running a region server can have up to
thousand regions it runs on every node
and decides the size of region so region
server as i said is a slave process
which is responsible for managing hbase
data on the node each region server is a
worker node or a worker process
co-located with data node which will
take care of your read write update
delete request from the clients now when
we talk about more components of edge
base as i said you have hp h master so
you would always have a connection
coming in from a client or an
application what does h master do it
assigns regions it monitors the region
servers it assigns regions to region
servers for load balancing and it cannot
do that without the help of zookeeper so
if we talk about components of hbase
there are three main components you have
zookeeper you have h master and you have
region server region server being the
slave process your edge master being the
master process which takes care of all
your table operations assigning regions
to the region servers taking care of
read and write requests which come from
client and for all of this edge master
will take in help of zookeeper which is
a centralized coordination service so
whenever a client wants to read or write
or change the schema or any other
metadata operations it will contact
hmaster edge master internally will
contact zookeeper so you could have
hbase setup also in high availability
mode where you could have a active edge
master than a backup edge master you
would have a zookeeper quorum which is
the way zookeeper works so zookeeper is
a centralized coordination service which
will always run with a quorum of
processes so zookeeper would always run
with odd number of processes such as 3 5
and 7 because zookeeper works on the
concept of majority consensus now
zookeeper which is a centralized
coordination service is keeping a track
of all the servers which are alive
available and also keeps a track of
their status for every server with
zookeeper is monitoring zookeeper keeps
a session alive with that particular
server edge master would always check
with zookeeper which region servers are
available alive so that regions can be
assigned to the region server at one end
you have region server which are sending
their status to the zookeeper indicating
if they are ready for any kind of read
or write operation and at other end
edgemaster is querying the zookeeper to
check the status now zookeeper
internally manages a meta table now that
meta table will have information of
which regions are residing on which
region server and what row keys those
regions contain so in case of a read
activity h master will query zookeeper
to find out the region server which
contains that meta table once edge
master gets the information of meta
table it can look into the meta table to
find out the row keys and the
corresponding region servers which
contain the regions for those row keys
now if we would want to understand row
key and column families in each base
let's look at this and it would be good
if we could look this on an excel sheet
so row key is always unique it acts as a
primary key for any hbase table it
allows a logical grouping of cells and
make sure that all cells with the same
row key are co-located on the same
server so as i said you have four
coordinates for hbase you have a row key
which is always unique you have column
families which is nothing but group of
columns and when i say column families
one column family can have any number of
columns so when i talk about edge base
edge base is four dimensional and in
terms of edge base it is also called as
a column oriented database which
basically means that every row in one
column could have a different data type
now you have a row key which uniquely
identifies the row you have column
families which could be one or many
depending on how the table has been
defined and a column family can have any
number of columns or i could say for
every row within a column family you
could have different number of columns
so i could say for my row one i could
just have two columns such as name and
city within the column family for my row
2 i could have name city age designation
salary for my third row i could have
thousand columns and all that could
belong to one column family so this is a
horizontally scalable database so column
family consists of group of columns
which is defined during table creation
and each column family can have any
number of column qualifiers separated by
a delimiter now a combination of row key
column family column qualifier such as
name city h and the value within the
cell is makes the edge base a unique
four dimensional database for more
information if you would want to learn
on hbase please refer this link which is
hbase mapper and this gives a complete
hbase architecture that is three
components of name node
three components that is name node
region servers and zookeeper how it
works how each edge master interacts
with zookeeper what zookeeper does in
coordination how are the components
working together and how does hbs take
care of read and write coming back and
continuing why do we need to disable a
table so there are different table
operations what you can do in each base
and one of them is disabling a table now
if you would want to check the status of
table you could check that by is
disabled and giving the table name order
is enabled and the table name so the
question is why do we need to disable a
table now if we would want to modify a
table or we are doing some kind of
maintenance activity in that case we can
disable the table so that we can modify
or changes settings when a table is
disabled it cannot be accessed through
the scan command now if we have to write
a code to open a connection in hbase now
to interact with hbase one could either
use a graphical user interface such as
hue or you could be using the command
line h based shell or you could be using
hbase admin api if you are working with
java or say happy base if you are
working with python where you may want
to open a connection with hbase so that
you can work with that base
programmatically in that case we have to
create a configuration object that is
configuration my conf and then create a
configuration object and then you can
use different classes like edge table
interface to work on a new table you
could use h column qualifier and many
other classes which are available in
hbase admin api what does replication
mean in terms of hbase so edge base as i
said works in a cluster way and when you
talk about cluster you could always set
up a replication from one hbase cluster
to other hbase cluster so this
replication feature in edge base
provides a mechanism to copy data
between clusters or sync the data
between different clusters this feature
can be used as a disaster recovery
solution that provides high availability
for hbase so if i have a hbase cluster
one where i have one master and multiple
region servers running in a hadoop
cluster i could use the same hadoop
cluster to create a hbase replica
cluster or i could have a totally
different hbase replica cluster where my
intention is that if things are changing
in a particular table in cluster one i
would want them to be replicated across
different clusters so i could alter the
hbase table and set the replication
scope to one now a replication scope of
zero indicates that table is not
replicated but if we set the replication
to one we basically will have to set up
ah base cluster where we can replicate
edge based tables data from cluster one
to cluster so these are the commands
which can be used to enable replication
and then replicate the data of table
across clusters can we import and export
in hbase of course we can it is possible
to import and export tables from one
hbase cluster to other hbase cluster or
even within a cluster so we can use the
hbase export utility which comes in this
particular package give a table name and
then a target location so that will
export the data of hbase table into a
directory on sdfs then i could create a
different table which would follow some
kind of same definition as the table
which was exported and then i could use
import to import the data from the
directory on sdfs to my table if you
would want to learn more on hbase import
and export you could look at hbase
import operations let's search for the
link and this is the link where you
could learn more about hbase import
export utilities how you could do a bulk
import bulk export which internally uses
mapreduce and then you could do a import
and export into hbase tables moving
further what do we mean by compaction in
edge base now we all know that hbase is
a nosql database which can be used to
store huge amount of data however
whenever a data is written in hbase it
is first returned to what we call as
right ahead log and also to mem store
which is
write cache now once the data is written
in wall and your mem store it is
offloaded to form an internal hbs format
file which is called h5 and usually
these edge files are very small in
nature so we also know that sdfs is good
when we talk about few number of larger
files in comparison to
large number of smaller files due to the
limitation of name nodes memory
compaction is process of merging hbase
files that is these smaller edge files
into a single large file this is done to
reduce the amount of memory required to
store the files and number of disk seeks
needed so we could have lot of edge
files which get created when the data is
written to hbase and these smaller files
can then be compacted through a major or
minor compaction creating one big edge
file which internally would then be
written to sdfs and sdfs format of
blocks that is the benefit of compaction
there is also a feature called bloom
filter so how does bloom filter work so
bloom filter or hbase bloom filter is a
mechanism to test whether a h file
contains a specific row or a row column
cell bloom filter is named after its
creator burton hovered bloom it is a
data structure which predicts whether a
given element is a member of a set of
data it provides an in-memory index
structure that reduces the disk reads
and determines the probability of
finding a row in a particular file this
is one of very useful features of edge
base which allows for faster access and
avoids disk seeks
does hbase have any concept of name
space so namespace is when you have
similar elements grouped together so
namespace yes h based support such
namespace so namespace is a logical
grouping of tables analogous to a
database in rdbms so you can create hbs
namespace to the schema of rdbms
database so you could create a namespace
by saying create namespace and giving it
a name and then you could also list the
tables within a namespace you could
create tables within a specific
namespace now this is usually done in
production environment where a cluster
might be multi-tenant cluster and there
might be different users of the same
nosql database in that case admin would
create specific namespace and for
specific namespace you would have
different directories on sdfs and users
of a particular business unit or a team
can work on their hbase objects within a
specific name space
this is a question which is again very
important to understand about the writes
or reads so how does right ahead log
wall help when a region server crashes
now as i said when i write happens it
will happen into mem store and wall that
is your edit log or write a headlock so
whenever a write happens it will happen
in two places mem store which is the
right cache and wall which is a edit log
only when the data is written in both
these places and based on the limitation
of mem store the data will be flushed to
create an edge-based format file called
h-file these files are then compacted
and created into one bigger file which
will then be stored on sdfs and sdfs
data as we know is stored in the form of
blocks on the underlying data nodes so
if a region server hosting a mem store
crashes now where is region server
running that would be co-located with
data node so if a data node crashes or
if a region server which was hosting the
mem store write cache crashes data in
memory the data that in memory which was
not persisted is lost now how does hbase
recover from this as i said your data is
written into wall and mem store at the
same time hbase recovers against that by
writing to wall before the write
completes so whenever a write happens it
happens in mem store and wall at the
same time hbase cluster keeps a wall to
record changes as they happen and that's
why we call it as also an edit log if
edge base goes down or the node that
goes down the data that was not flushed
from mem store to edge file can be
recovered by replaying the right ahead
lock and that's the benefit of your edit
log or right ahead lock now if we would
have to write hbase command to list the
contents and update the column families
of a table i could just do a scan and
that would give me complete data of a
table if you are very specific and if
you would want to look at a particular
row then you could do a get table name
and then give the row key however you
could do a scan to get the complete data
of a particular table you could also do
a describe to see what are the different
column families and if you would want to
alter the table and add a new column
family it is very simple you can just
say alter give the hbase table name and
then give your new column family name
which will then be added to the table
what are catalog tables in hbase so as i
mentioned your zookeeper knows the
location of this internal catalog table
or what we call as the meta table now
catalog tables in edge base have two
tables one is hbase meta table and one
is
hyphen root the catalog table edge base
meta exists as an edge base table and is
filtered out of hbase shells list
command so if i give a list command on
edge base it would list all the tables
which space contains but not the meta
table it's an internal table this meta
table keeps a list of all regions in the
system and location of hbase meta stored
in zookeeper so if somebody wants to
find out or look for particular rows
they need to know the regions which
contain that data and those regions are
located on region server to get all this
information one has to look into this
meta table however we will not be
looking into meta table directly we
would just be giving a write or a read
operation internally uh based master
queries the zookeeper zookeeper has the
information of where the meta table
exists and that meta table which is
existing on region server contains
information of row keys and the region
servers where those rows can be found
your root table keeps a track of
location of the meta table what is hot
spotting in hbase and how to avoid hot
spotting now this is a common problem
and always admin guys or guys who are
managing the infrastructure would think
about it so one of the main idea is that
edge base would be leveraging the
benefit of sdfs your all read and write
requests should be uniformly distributed
across all of the regions in region
servers otherwise what's the benefit of
having a distributed cluster so you
would have your data stored across
region servers in the form of regions
which are horizontal partitions of the
table and whenever read and write
requests happen they should be uniformly
distributed across all the regions in
the region servers now hot spotting
occurs when a given region serviced by a
region server receives most or all of
read write request which is basically a
unbalanced way of read write operations
now hotspot can be avoided by designing
the row key in such a way that data
being written should go to multiple
regions across the cluster so you could
do techniques such as salting hashing
reversing the key and many other
techniques which are employed by users
of hbase we need to just make sure that
when the regions are distributed across
region servers they should be spread
across region servers so that your read
and write request can be satisfied from
different region servers in parallel
rather than all read and write request
hitting the same region server
overloading the region server which may
also lead to the crashing of a
particular region server so these were
some of the important questions of hbase
and then there are many more please
refer to the link which i specified in
during my discussion and that gives you
a detailed explanation of how each space
works you can also look into hp's
definitive guide by o'reilly or hbase in
action and these are really good books
to understand about hbase internals and
how it works now that we have learned on
hive which is a data warehousing package
we have learnt on pig which is a
scripting or a scripting language which
allows you to do data analysis and we
have learned some questions on a nosql
database just note it that there are
more than 225 nosql databases existing
in market and if you would want to learn
and know about more nosql databases you
can just go to google and type no sql
databases
org and that will take you to the link
which is for nosql databases and this
shows there are more than 225
nosql databases existing in market and
these are for different use cases used
by different users and for with
different features so have a look at
this link now when you talk about data
ingestion so let's look at data
ingestion and this is one good link
which i would suggest to have a look at
which lists down around 18 different
ingestion tools so when you talk about
different data injection tools some are
for structured data some are for
streaming data some are for data
governance some are for data ingestion
and transformation and so on so have a
look at this link which also gives you a
comparison of different data ingestion
tools so here let's learn about some
questions on scope which is one of the
data ingestion tools mainly used for
structured data or you could say data
which is coming in from rdbms or data
which is already structured and you
would want to ingest that you would want
to store that on sdfs which could then
be used for hive which could be used for
any kind of processing using mapreduce
or hive or pig or spark or any other
processing frameworks or you would want
to load that data into say high voltage
based tables scope is mainly for
structured data it is extensively used
when organizations are migrating from
rdbms to a big data platform and they
would be interested in ingesting the
data that is doing import and export of
data from rdbms to sdfs or vice versa so
let's learn about some important
questions on scope which you may be
asked by an interviewer when you apply
for a big data related position how is
scoop different from flume so this is a
very common question which is asked
scope which is mainly for structured
data so scope works with rdbms it also
works with nosql databases to import and
export data so you can import data into
sdfs you can import data into data
warehousing package such as hive
directly or also in hbase and you could
also export data from hadoop ecosystem
to your rdbms however when it comes to
flow flow is more of
a data injection tool which works with
streaming data or unstructured data so
data which is constantly getting
generated for example log files or
metrics from server or some chat
messenger and so on so if you are
interested in working on capturing and
storing the streaming data in a storage
layer such as sdfs or hbase you could be
using flue there could be other tools
also like kafka or storm or chokwa or
samsa nifi and so on scoop however is
mainly for structured data your loading
data in scope is not event driven so it
is not based on event it basically works
on data which is already stored in rdbms
in terms of flume it is completely event
driven that is as the messages or as the
events happen as the data is getting
generated you can have that data
ingested using flow scope works with
structured data sources and you have
various scope connectors which are used
to fetch data from external data
structures or rdbms so for every rdbms
such as mysql oracle db2 microsoft sql
server you have different connectors
which are available flume it works on
fetching streaming data such as tweets
or log files or server metrics from your
different sources where the data is
getting generated and if you are
interested in not only ingesting that
data which is getting generated in a
streaming fashion but if you would be
interested in processing the data as it
arrives scoop can import data from rdbms
onto sdfs and also export it back to
rdbms flume is then used for streaming
data now you could have one to one one
too many or many to one kind of relation
so in terms of loom you have components
such as your source sync and channel
that's the main difference between your
scoop and flow what are the different
file formats to import data using scope
well there are lots and lots of formats
in which you can import data into scope
when you talk about scoop you can have
delimited text file format now that's
the default import format it can be
specified explicitly using as text file
argument so when i want to import data
from an rdbms i could get that data in
sdfs using different compression schemes
or in different formats using the
specific arguments so i could specify an
argument which will write string based
representation of each record to output
files with delimiters between individual
columns and rows so that is the default
format which is used to import data
using scope so to learn more about your
scope and different arguments which are
available you can click on
scoop.apache.org
you can look into the documentation and
i would suggest choosing one of the
versions and looking into the user guide
and here you can search for arguments
and look for specific control arguments
which show how you can import data using
scope so here we have common arguments
and then you also have import control
arguments wherein we have different
options like getting data as avro as
sequence file as text file or parquet
file these are different formats you can
also get data in default compression
scheme that is gzip or you can specify
compression codec and then you can
specify what compression mechanism you
would want to use when you are importing
your data using scope when it comes to
default format for flume we could say
sequence file which is a binary format
that stores individual records in record
specific data types so these data types
are manifested as java classes and scope
will automatically generate these data
types for you so scoop does that when we
talk about your sequence file format in
terms of your scope you could be
extracting storage of all data in binary
representation so as i mentioned you can
import data in different formats such as
avro parque sequence file that is binary
format or machine readable format and
then you could also have data in
different compression schemes let me
just show you some quick examples here
so if i look in
the content and here i could search for
a scoop based file where i have listed
down some examples so if i would want to
use different compression schemes here
are some examples have a look at these
so i'm doing a scoop import i'm also
giving an argument so that scoop which
also triggers a map reduce job or i
would say map only job so when you run a
scoop import it triggers a map only job
no reduce happens here and you could
specify this parameter or this argument
on the command line
mapreduce.framework.name
so that you could run your map only job
in a local mode to save time or that
would interact with yarn and run a
full-fledged map only job we can give
the connection and then connect to
whatever rdbms we are connecting
mentioning the database name give your
username and password give the table
name give a target directory or it would
create a directory same as the table
name which would work only once and then
i could say minus z to get data in a
compressed format that is gzip or i
could be specifying compression codec
and then i could specify what
compression codec i would want to use
say snappy b lz4 default i could also
run a query by giving a scope import and
when i'm specifying a query if you
notice i have not given any table name
because that would be included in the
query i can get my data as a sequence
file format which is a binary format
which will create a huge file so we
could also have compression enabled and
then i could say the output of my map
job should use a compression at record
level for my data coming in sequence
file so sequence file or a binary format
supports compression at record level or
at block level i could get my data in an
avro file where data has embedded schema
within the file or a parquet file also
so these are different ways in which you
can set up different compression schemes
or you can even get data in different
formats and you could be doing a simple
scope import for these looking further
what is the importance of eval tool in
scope so there is something called as
eval tool so scoop eval tool allows
users to execute user-defined queries
against respective database servers and
preview the result in the console so
either i could be running a straight
away query to import the data into my
sdfs or i could just use scoop eval
connect to my external rdbms specify my
username and password and then i could
be giving in a query to see what would
be the result of the query which we
intend to import now let's learn about
how scope imports and exports data
between rdbms and sdfs with its
architecture so rdbms as we know has
your database structures your tables
which all of them are logical and
internally there is always metadata
which is stored your scope import
connects to an external rdbms and for
this connection it uses an internal
connector jar file which has a driver
class so that's something which needs to
be set up by admin but they need to make
sure that whichever rdbms you intend to
connect to they need to have the jdbc
connector for that particular rdbms
stored within the scope lib folder so
scope import gets the metadata and then
for your scoop command it converts that
into a map only job which might have one
or multiple map tasks
now that depends on your scoop command
you could be specifying that you would
want to do a import only in one task or
in multiple tasks these multiple map
tasks will then run on a section of data
from rdbms and then store it in sdfs
so at high level we could say scoop will
introspect database to get gathered the
metadata it divides the input data set
into splits and this division of data
into splits mainly happens on primary
key column of the table now if somebody
might ask what if my table in rdbms does
not have a primary key column then when
you are doing a scope import either you
will have to import it using one mapper
task by specifying hyphen hyphen m
equals one or you would have to say
split by parameter to specify a numeric
column from rdbms and that's how you can
import the data let me just show you a
quick example on this so i could just
look in again into the scope command
file and here we could be looking at an
example so if you see this one here we
are specifying minus minus m equals one
which basically means i would want to
import the data using one map task now
in this case whether the table has a
primary key column or does not have a
primary key column will not matter but
if i say a minus minus ms6 where i am
specifying multiple map tasks to be
imported then this will look for a
primary key column in the table which
you are importing now if the table does
not have a primary key column then i
could be specifying a split by and then
specify the column so that the data
could be split into multiple chunks and
multiple map tasks would take it now if
the second scenario is your table does
not have a primary key column and it
does not have a numeric column on which
you could do a split by in that case and
if you would want to use multiple
mappers you could still say split by on
a textual column but you will have to
add this property so that it allows
splitting the data which is non-numeric
all of these options are given in the
scoop apache.org link going further how
scoop imports and exports data between
rdbms and sdfs with its architecture so
as i said it submits the map only job to
the cluster and then it basically does a
import or export so if we are exporting
the data from sdfs in that case again
there would be a map only job it would
look at multiple splits of the data
which is existing which your map only
job would process through one or one
table map task and then export it to
rdbms suppose you have a database testdb
in mysql we if somebody asked you to
write a command to connect this database
and import tables to scoop so here is a
quick example as i showed you in the
command file so you could say scoop
import this is what we would want to do
you connect using jdbc now this will
only work if the jdbc connector already
exists within your scope lib directory
admin has to set up that so you can
connect to your rdbms you can point to
the database so
here our database name is test
underscore db i could give user name and
then either i could give password on the
command line or just say capital p so
that i could be prompted for the
password and then i could give the table
name which i would want to import i
could also be specifying minus minus m
and specify how many map tasks do i want
to use for this import as i showed in
previous screen how to export a table
back to rdbms now for this we need the
data in a directory on hdfs so for
example there is a departments table in
retail database which is already
imported into scoop and you need to
export this table back to rdbms so this
is the content of the table now create a
new department table in rdbms so i could
create a table specifying the column
names whether that supports null or no
if that has a primary key column which
is always recommended and then i can do
a scoop export i can connect to the
rdbms specifying my username and
password specify the table into which
you want to export the data and then you
give export directory pointing to a
directory on htfs which contains the
data this is how you can export data
into table same example on this so i
could again look into my file and here i
have an example of import this is where
you are importing data directly into
hive and you have scope import where you
are importing data directly into hbase
table and you can then query your hbase
table to look at the data you could also
do a export by
running your map only job in a local
mode connecting to the rdbms specifying
your username specifying the table where
you would want to export and the
directory on sdfs where you have kept
the relevant data this is a simple
example of export looking further
what is the role of jdbc driver in scope
setup so as i said if you would want to
use scoop to connect to an external
rdbms we need the jdbc odbc connector
jar file now one or admin could download
the jdbc connected jar file and then
place the jar file within the scoop lib
directory wherever scoop is installed
and this jdbc connector jar file
contains a driver now jdbc driver is a
standard java api which is used for
accessing different databases in rdbms
so this connector jar file is very much
required and this connector jar file has
a driver class and this driver class
enables the connection between your
rdbms and your hadoop structure each
database vendor is responsible for
writing their own implementation that
will allow communication with the
corresponding database and we need to
download the drivers which allow our
scope to connect to external rdbms so
your jdbc driver alone is not enough to
connect to scope we also need connectors
to interact with different database so a
connector is a pluggable piece that is
used to fetch metadata and allow scoop
to overcome the differences in sql
dialects so this is how connection can
be established so normally your admins
would when they are setting up scope and
hadoop they would download
say mysql jdbc connector and this is how
they would go to the mysql connectors if
you are connecting to mysql similarly
for your other rdbms you could be say
going in here you could be looking for a
previous version depending you could be
going for platform independent and then
you could be downloading the connector
jar file now if you enter this jar file
you would see a mysql connector jar and
if we look in com.mysql
so this is the package which is within
the connector jar file and this
has the driver class which allows the
connection of your scope with your rdbms
so these things will have to be done by
your admin so that you can have your
scope connecting to an external rdbms
now how do you update the columns that
are already exported so if i do a export
and i put my data in rdbms can i really
update the columns that are already
exported yes i can using a update key
parameter so scoop export command
remains the same the only thing i will
have to specify now is the table name
your fields terminated by if you have a
specific delimiter and then you can say
update key and then the column name so
this allows us to update the columns
that are already exported in rdbms
what is code gen so scope commands
translate into your mapreduce job or map
only job so code gen is basically a tool
in scope that generates data access
objects dao java classes that
encapsulate and interpret imported
records so if i do a scoop code gen
connect to an rdbms using my username
and give a table this will generate a
java code for employee table in the test
database so this code gen can be useful
for us to understand what data we have
in this particular table finally can
scoop be used to convert data in
different formats i think i already
answered that right if no which tools
can be used for this purpose so scope
can be used to convert data in different
formats and that depends on the
different arguments which you use when
you do a import such as avro file
parquet file binary format with record
or block level compression so if you are
interested in knowing more on different
data formats then i think i can suggest
a link for that and we can say hadoop
formats
i think it is tech
maggie avro
parque let's see you can find out the
link take maggie
yeah this is a very good link which
specifies or talks about different data
formats which you should know such as
your text file format different
compression schemes how is data
organization what are the common formats
what do you have in text file structured
binary sequence files with compression
without compression what is record level
what is block level what is a avro data
file what is a sequence what is a
parquet data file or a columnar format
and other formats like orc rc and so on
thanks ajay with that we've reached the
end of this complete big data course i
hope you enjoyed this video do like and
share it thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from simply learn
[Music]
you